>> WELCOME TO MLB GAME OF THE
WEEK PREGAME SHOW, PRESENTED BY
JIM BEAM.
THE FOCUS WILL BE THE THIRD OF A
THREE-GAME SET AT PNC PARK AS
THE DODGERS ARE TAKING ON THE
PIRATES.
THE DAUGHTERS HAVE WON 12 IN A
ROW AGAINST THE TOP -- AGAINST
THE PIRATES.
ONE SHY OF THE LONGEST WIN
STREAK OVER THE PIRATES IN
FRANCHISE HISTORY.
L.A. HAS OUTSCORED PITTSBURGH
90-39 IN THE LAST 12 WEEKS.
THE KEY THING FOR THE DODGERS IS
THEY ARE BEAT UP ON BAD TEAMS.
GAME TIME COMING UP IN JUST
ABOUT 30 MINUTES FROM NOW.
THE DODGERS AND PIRATES ON THE
WAY.
URIAS VERSUS KELLER.
WE WILL DEFTLY TALK A LOT ABOUT
THE L.A. DODGERS TODAY, BUT
FIRST UP, HIGHLIGHTS FROM
YESTERDAY IN CASE YOU MISSED IT.
>> NOW FACING A GUY THAT HAS HAD
A LOT OF SUCCESS AGAINST HIM,
JUSTIN TURNER.
>> THAT IS A HIGH FLY BALL.
DEEP CENTER FIELD.
REYNOLDS, IT IS GONE!
2-1, TURNER.
FLIES ONE DOWN TO THE LEFT.
OVER TO THE CORNER.
IT'S GONE!
TURNER GETS IT AGAIN.
TURNER, TWO, THE PIRATES ONE.
OFF THE GLOVE AND INTO THE
SEATS.
ADNAN: I FEEL BAD FOR TOM.
JUSTIN TURNER GETTING THOSE HOME
RUNS.
HERE IS HOW THE STANDINGS LOOK.
THE GIANTS WITH THAT GREAT
STARTING PITCHING, THEY ARE IN
FIRST PLACE, TWO GAMES UP ON LOS
ANGELES.
PADRES, YOU THEN YOU HAVE THE
ROCKIES -- PADRES, YOU THEN HAVE
THE ROCKIES AND THE D-BACKS.
THEY HAVE HAD SOME INJURIES AND
DEALING WITH THAT CHAMPIONSHIP
HANGOVER.
BUCK: I HAVE ALWAYS RESPECTED
PEOPLE THAT HAVE WON WHEN YOU
EXPECT THEM TO WIN.
EVERYBODY IS GUNNING FOR YOU.
THERE IS NO LITTLE ENGINE THAT
COULD SNEAKING UP ON ANYBODY.
THE DODGERS DON'T HAVE ANY
COMPLAINTS.
THEY HAVE A TALENTED SYSTEM,
SELF-INDUCED, AND THEY'VE GOT
GOOD PLAYERS.
AS A MANAGER, A GUY LIKE TURNER
IS A GUY YOU CAN COUNT ON, BUT
YOU DON'T EVER LET SOME EXCUSE
CREEP IN.
YOU DON'T SAY WOE IS ME.
THE ONLY THING I LOOK AT IS THE
LOSS COLUMN.
THEY'VE GOT PITCHING WHICH IS
SOLID.
YOU HAVE TO TRUST ALL OF THIS.
MAKE IT LOOK LIKE YOU ARE NOT
TRUSTING WHAT THEY ARE CAPABLE
OF DOING.
I THINK THEY ARE ACTUALLY IN A
GOOD PLACE.
YOU LIKE TO COME IN AND GO GUYS,
LISTEN, WHAT A GREAT OPPORTUNITY
WE HAVE.
YOU ALWAYS ASK YOURSELF IN THE
OFF-SEASON, WHAT IF?
WHAT IF THIS GUY GETS HURT?
WHAT IF THIS GUY CAN'T CLOSE
GAMES?
YOU ARE ALWAYS GOING TO GO TO
THE WHAT IF'S, SOMETIMES THE
INFUSION YOU GET FROM YOUR
YOUTH.
YOU LIKE ALL OF YOUR WHAT IF'S
TO COME IN FROM YOUR SYSTEM.
ADNAN: YOU LOOK AT THE INJURIES
THEY'VE GOT.
BELLINGER GOT HURT, COREY SEAGER
GOT HURT.
HOW ABOUT THE HALL OF FAME
IMPORT?
BUCK: THE ONLY REASON HE IS
PLAYING NOW IS TO WIN.
HE DOESN'T HAVE ANYTHING TO
PROVE.
ALL OF A SUDDEN HE DECIDES TO
SAY SOMETHING AND EVERYBODY'S
GOING TO LISTEN.
WE BROUGHT JIM IN BALTIMORE, IT
WAS LIKE WOW, WE ARE TRYING
HERE.
WE WON'T LEAVE ANY STONE
UNTURNED.
I THINK THE OPPORTUNITY TO STAY
CONNECTED AS ONE OF THOSE
THINGS.
TAKE A SHOT AT US NOW BECAUSE
WHEN WE GET THE COWBOYS BACK, IT
IS GOING TO BE TOUGH.
ADNAN:PULOL IS STILL EFFECTIVE.
WHATEVER HAPPENED IN LOS
ANGELES, FINE BUT IF YOU
MIX-AND-MATCH HIM WELL, HE IS
EFFECTIVE.
BUCK: YOU KNOW THERE IS A FORCE
OVER ON THE BENCH COMING OFF OF
THAT BENCH, BUT YOU CAN COUNT ON
THAT WILL GIVE YOU A
PROFESSIONAL BAT.
THE REALLY GOOD HITTERS CAN HIT
THE GOOD PITCHING LATE IN THE
GAME.
IF YOU ARE A MANAGER, ONE OF THE
GOING TO USE -- TO MAKE SURE I
HAVE SOME THING TO DEFEND
OURSELVES WITH?
ADNAN: I LOOK AT THAT PITCHING
AND GO OH MY GOODNESS.
KERSHAW, BUEHLER, YOU'VE GOT
SOME DIFFERENT OPTIONS.
BUCK: GOOD PITCHING MAKES RUNS
MATTER.
NOTHING WORSE THAN A DUGOUT FOR
PITCHERS TO GO HOW MUCH IS
ENOUGH?
THIS GAME WAS 9-2 AND NOW IT IS
9-6.
IT REALLY WEIGHS ON YOU, HOW
MUCH IS ENOUGH.
IT IS A GREAT COMBINATION TO
STAY ENGAGED.
THEY ARE GOING TO BE THERE AT
THE END.
WE ALL KNOW THAT.
ADNAN: AMONG THE 132 PITCHERS IN
40 INNINGS THIS SEASON, ONLY
HARVEY AND SHOEMAKER HAVE HAD A
WORSE YEAR.
IT IS GOING TO BE A TOUGH DAY
FOR THE PITTSBURGH PIRATES.
WHEN WE COME BACK, WE WILL KEEP
IT ROLLING.
ABOUT 20 51 -- 25 MINUTES UNTIL
FIRST PITCH.
JUSTGREAT.
A TWO HOME RUN GAME ON
WEDNESDAY.
WE WILL TALK TO J.T. ABOUT HIS
STATE OF AFFAIRS, NEXT.
>> LOOPED IT TO CENTER FIELD.
BACK TOWARD BELLINGER.
MAKING THE GRAB AT THE WALL!
BEAUTIFULLY DONE IN CENTER FIELD
BY CODY BELLINGER.
A TOWERING FLY BALL TO LEFT
FIELD.
IT BRINGS RAIN!
DRIVEN TO RIGHT CENTER FIELD.
HE'S ALREADY GOT ONE TONIGHT.
MAKE IT TWO.
GAVIN LUX!
0-1, BEATY HITS THE BALL IN THE
AIR.
IT IS GONE!
THIS GAME IS TIED.
BELLINGER HITS ONE WAY UP THERE.
WILLIAMS GOING BACK, AT THE
WALL.
GOODBYE!
GRAND SLAM.
GAME BUSTED WIDE OPEN.
11 RUN FIRST INNING.
14TH PITCH.
DRIVEN TO RIGHT CENTER FIELD!
EPIC STUFF!
CHRIS TAYLOR!
UNLOADS THE BASES!
ADNAN: WELCOME BACK TO MLB GAME
OF THE WEEK PREGAME SHOW,
PRESENTED BY JIM BEAM.
LOOK AT THE IMPACT JUSTIN TURNER
HAS HAD WITH THE LOS ANGELES
DODGERS.
IN DODGERS HISTORY, THE HIGHEST
O.P.S. WITH A MINIMUM OF 3000
PLATE APPEARANCES.
MIKE PIAZZA AT THE TOP OF THE
LIST.
DUKE SNIDER, JACKIE ROBINSON,
AND THERE IS JUSTIN TURNER ON
THAT LIST.
AWFULLY IMPRESSIVE WHAT HE HAS
DONE.
THE HIGHEST O.P.S. IN 3000 PLATE
APPEARANCES.
YOU ARE UP THERE WITH THE NAMES
OF DUKE SNIDER AND JACKIE
ROBINSON.
WHAT DOES IT MEAN TO HAVE MADE
AN IMPACT IN LOS ANGELES?
>> THAT IS PRETTY WILD.
TO HAVE MY NAME ON A LIST WITH
THOSE GUYS IN -- AND THAT
CALIBER OF PLAYER IS SOMETHING
THAT IS PRETTY SPECIAL.
BEING A DODGERS A SPECIAL AND
THE HISTORY OF THIS ORGANIZATION
AND THE PLAYERS THAT HAVE COME
THROUGH HERE AND CHANGE THE GAME
IN SOME ANYWAYS, IT IS ALWAYS
COOL TO HAVE YOUR NAME RELATED
WITH THOSE GUYS.
BUCK: THIS MIGHT BE A LONG
QUESTION.
ARE THE SPRINKLERS WORKING BACK
THERE FOR YOU?
>> I AM GETTING RAINED ON, AND
THERE IS NOT A CLOUD IN THE SKY.
BUCK: WALK THE FANS THROUGH LAST
NIGHT.
HAVE YOU CHANGED CLOTHES SINCE
YOU HAVE GOTTEN OFF THE BUS?
>> I HAVE NOT.
I AM USUALLY ONE OF THE LAST
GUYS AT THE PARK.
I GOT BACK TO THE HOTEL AT 1:30
LAST NIGHT, AND I LITERALLY JUST
GOT HERE TODAY.
I AM STILL IN THE CLOTHES I
WORE, AND WE HAVE A GAME IN
ABOUT TWO HOURS.
AFTER THIS INTERVIEW IS OVER, I
WILL CHANGE AND GET A QUICK BITE
AND GET TO WORK.
BUCK: WHEN I GOT TO BALTIMORE,
AND YOU HAD JUST LEFT AND I SAID
WHAT DO WE NOT LIKE ABOUT THIS
GUY?
WHAT WOULD YOU TELL GUYS?
YOU ARE WITH THREE CLUBS, ALL
THE SCOUTS LOVE GUYS OUT OF
THERE BECAUSE THEY PLAYED THE
GAME HARD AND RIGHT.
WHAT WOULD YOU TELL THOSE GUYS
OUT THERE, THAT THE DOOR HAS NOT
OPENED FOR THEM YET?
>> THE BIGGEST MESSAGE I SENT
THE GUYS IS ALL IT TAKES IS ONE
PARTICULAR GUY TO LIKE YOU.
IF YOU HAVE THAT ONE GUY IN YOUR
CORNER, THEY CAN HELP PROLONG
YOUR CAREER.
THAT IS WHAT HAPPENED TO ME.
I'VE BEEN ABLE TO BOUNCE AROUND
TO A FEW ORGANIZATIONS BECAUSE
ONE PARTICULAR GUY HAD HIS EYE
ON ME.
THERE IS A LOT OF PEOPLE IN THIS
GAME THAT CAN TELL YOU OR THAT
ARE GOING TO TELL YOU THAT YOU
ARE NOT FAST ENOUGH OR STRONG
ENOUGH, OR YOU CAN'T DO THIS OR
CAN'T DO THAT, BUT KEEP GOING.
ALL IT TAKES IS ONE GUY TO LIKE
WHAT YOU ARE DOING.
ADNAN: WHO WAS THE GUY WITH LOS
ANGELES THAT BELIEVED IN YOU?
>> I HAD GUYS LIKE TIM WALLACH,
WHO WAS A FORMER TITAN, CAME UP
TO ME AND ASKED ME WHAT WAS
GOING ON.
I TOLD HIM I WAS STILL A FREE
AGENT, AND THEN HE TOOK ME BACK
TO THE FRONT OFFICE AND SAID WE
SHOULD TRY AND TAKE A SHOT AT
THIS.
TIMMY WALLACH WAS HUGE FOR
GETTING ME OVER HERE.
ADNAN: AS FAR AS LAST NIGHTS
GAME WAS CONCERNED, OBVIOUSLY A
GREAT GAME FOR YOU.
TAKE ME THROUGH.
WHAT WAS YOUR REACTION?
>> WHEN I HIT IT, GET -- IT GOT
IN ON ME A LITTLE BIT.
I THOUGHT IT FLEW OUT TO LEFT,
AND THEN WHEN I WAS ROUNDING
FIRST, I WATCHED HIM JUMP AND
THE BALL CAME FLYING OUT OF HIS
GLOVE.
THE WAY THINGS WERE GOING FOR ME
LATELY, I WOULD TAKE THAT,
DEFINITELY.
I'M JUST GLAD I WASN'T RUNNING
ON FIRST BASE, BECAUSE THAT SAME
PLAY HAPPENED EARLIER IN THE
YEAR WITH CODY BELLINGER AND I
WAS ON FIRST BASE AND ACCOST HIM
-- AND I COST HIM A HOMER.
BUCK: HOW DO YOU GUYS KEEP THAT
COMPETITIVE SPIRIT AFTER THE
THINGS YOU ACCOMPLISHED LAST
YEAR?
EVERYBODY IS GIVING YOU THEIR
BEST SHOT AND YOU ARE TRYING TO
GET THE LURE OF MEDIOCRITY AFTER
A GREAT SEASON.
IT IS A CHALLENGE, ISN'T IT?
>> IT IS A CHALLENGE.
THIS HAS BEEN TALKED ABOUT IN
OUR CLUBHOUSE.
ONE COMMON THEME THAT COMES UP,
EVERYONE JUST WATCHED THAT
JORDAN DOCUMENTARY, AND THE TALK
ABOUT HOW NO MATTER WHAT HE IS
GOING THROUGH, HE JUST FINDS
WAYS TO MOTIVATE HIMSELF, EVEN
WHEN HE IS MAKING STUFF UP.
THAT IS WHAT MOTIVATES HIM.
FOR US, FINDING THE MOTIVATION
IS HEARING PEOPLE TALK ABOUT, IT
WAS ONLY A 60 GAME SEASON,
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE PLAYOFFS,
NOT BEING ABLE TO CELEBRATE OR
HAVE A PARADE.
THERE IS A LOT OF STUFF THAT WE
FEEL LIKE EVEN THOUGH WE WON THE
CHAMPIONSHIP, WE MISSED OUT ON,
AND THAT IS KIND OF DRIVING US
TO PURSUE THAT AGAIN AND GET TO
DO AT THE RIGHT WAY AND
CELEBRATE IT THE RIGHT WAY.
ADNAN: MOTIVATION COMES IN MANY
DIFFERENT FORMS.
I WANT TO GET YOUR THOUGHT ON
CHRIS TAYLOR.
HE PLAYS LITERALLY ALMOST ANY
POSITION EXCEPT PITCHER AND
CATCHER, AND HE IS HAVING A
GREAT YEAR OFFENSIVELY.
HOW IS HE DOING THIS?
>> HE IS ONE OF THOSE BASEBALL
GUYS AND LIKE YOU SAID, YOU CAN
PUT HIM ANYWHERE ON THE FIELD,
ANYWHERE IN THE LINEUP.
HE IS THE CATALYST THAT IS GOING
TO DO SOMETHING EVERY SINGLE
NIGHT TO HELP US WIN A BALLGAME.
IT IS MATTER IF IT IS
DEFENSIVELY OR SOME OF THE
AT-BATS HE PUTS TOGETHER -- HE
HITS FOR POWER AND HE TAKES
WALKS, USING THE WHOLE FIELD.
HE IS AN OUTSTANDING BASE RUNNER
.
GROUND BALL TO THIRD BASEMAN, HE
GETS INSIDE, IN THE THROWING
LANE.
THE BALL HITS, THE BACK AND THE
NEXT THING YOU KNOW, WE SCORE
SIX RUNS.
THE GUY DOES EVERYTHING
EXTREMELY WELL.
HE PAYS ATTENTION TO DETAIL, AS
WELL AS ANYONE I HAVE EVER
PLAYED WITH.
HE IS A HUGE PART OF ANY SUCCESS
WE HAVE HAD SO FAR.
ADNAN: HE IS A LOT OF FUN TO
WATCH, AS ARE YOU.
DAY GAME AFTER A NIGHT GAME.
NEVER FUN, BUT YOU LOOK FRESH.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
ADNAN: PUSH HER PLAYERS TO THE
TOP THE SUMMER.
THE GOOGLE MLB ALL-STAR BALLOT.
IT RUNS THROUGH JUNE 24.
FINALISTS WILL BE REVEALED ON
JUNE 27.
VOTE DAILY AT MLB.COM/VOTE TO
SEND THEM TO COLORADO.
TIME NOW FOR THE CREATOR
SPOTLIGHT, A PLEASURE TO BRING
IN COWBOY JEFF.
JEFF REYES WAS ALL ABOUT GAMING
AND SPORTS VIDEOS WITH AN AND
SPORTS VIDEOS WITH AN, BE FOCUS.
HE LOVES THE DODGERS AND HIS
FAVORITE MOMENT WAS THE STEVE
FINLEY WALKOFF GRAND SLAM TO
CLEANSE THE N.L. WEST, OCTOBER
2, 2004.
I LIKE THE FACT THAT HE WENT OFF
THE BOARD HERE.
A PLEASURE TO BRING IN COWBOY
JEFF RIGHT NOW.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
ALL-STAR GAME BECAUSE THAT IS
WHERE OUR FOCUS IS.
WHO IS THE ONE PLAYER RIGHT NOW,
YOU SAY YOU WANT TO SEE IN THE
ALL-STAR GAME?
>> THERE ARE SO MANY.
I DON'T WANT TO BE A HOMER, BUT
I FEEL LIKE I HAVE TO GO WITH
MAX MUNCY.
HE HAS PUT ON QUITE A YEAR.
IN MY OPINION, THE DODGERS
M.V.P. SO FAR.
I CAN SEE MAX MUNCY, THAT WOULD
BE SOMETHING FOR SURE.
ADNAN: YOU NAILED IT.
FREDDIE FREEMAN A REIGNING
M.V.P..
HIS O.P.S. IS UNDER POINT 800.
-- UNDER .800.
THAT IS NOT BEING A HOMER, THAT
IS BEING A GOOD PICK BY YOU.
>> I'M GLAD MY TAKE WASN'T
COMPLETELY HOMERISH OR OUT
THERE.
MAX MUNCY, WE PICKED HIM UP A
FEW WEEKS IT -- A FEW YEARS AGO
FROM THE A'S, AND HE WASN'T AS
BIG AS HE IS NOW.
JUST TO SEE HIM KIND OF CLIMB
AND ASCEND AND BE THE FIRST HE
IS NOW, TO MAKE IT TO THE
ALL-STAR GAME, THAT WOULD BE
SOMETHING, MY DREAM FOR SURE.
ADNAN: I THINK HE HAS A GOOD
CHANCE OF THAT HAPPENING.
LET'S FOCUS ON WHAT YOU ARE
DOING WITH YOUR YOUTUBE CHANNEL.
A LOT OF FOCUS AS FAR AS GAMING
AND MLB THE SHOW.
I GOT MLB THE SHOW FOR MY ELDEST
SON.
TELL ME ABOUT YOUR GAMING
EXPERTISE, PARTICULARLY WITH MLB
THE SHOW?
>> EXPERTISE IS KIND OF A STRONG
WORD.
I AM NOT THE GREATEST MLB THE
SHOW PLAYER.
FOR ME, I MOSTLY JUST TRY TO GO
OUT THERE AND HAVE FUN.
IF I COULD LIVE VICARIOUSLY
THROUGH MY ROAD TO THE SHOW
CHARACTER AND DO ALL KINDS OF
CRAZY STUFF LIKE THAT.
FOR ME, IT IS ALL ABOUT HAVING
FUN, BECAUSE LORDS KNOWS -- LORD
KNOWS I AM NOT ONE OF THOSE
TOP-TIER PLAYERS LIKE SOME OTHER
YOU TUBERS -- YOUTUBERS.
I HAVE TO MAKE UP WITH IT --
MAKE UP FOR IT WITH MY
PERSONALITY, I SUPPOSE.
ADNAN: YOU ALSO DO A LOT WITH
WII BASEBALL.
>> WII BASEBALL IS KIND OF A
NOSTALGIC GAME FOR ME.
THAT GAME CAME OUT WHEN I WAS 15
OR 16.
IT WAS COMPLETELY FOREIGN TO ME,
HAVING THE REMOTE, TAKING HACKS
LIKE A REAL BASEBALL PLAYER.
IT MAKES ME REALLY APPRECIATE
WHAT IT IS LIKE -- WHAT SOME OF
THESE PLAYERS GO THROUGH.
SOME OF THESE WII BASEBALL
PITCHES, THEY THROW YOU 80
MILE-PER-HOUR SPLITTERS AND THEN
THEY WILL THROW YOU A 104
MILE-PER-HOUR FASTBALL.
IT MAKES YOU WANT TO THROW THE
REMOTE AT THE TV.
ADNAN: YOU CAN APPRECIATE THE
FRUSTRATION FOR ACTUAL PLAYERS.
I LOVE THE NAME COWBOY JEFF.
WHERE DID THIS COME FROM?
I LIKE THE FACT THAT YOU ARE
KNOWN AS COWBOY JEFF.
>> COWBOY JEFF, IT KIND OF CAME
FROM MY GOOD FRIEND, BOBBY
CROSBY.
HE HAS HIS OWN CHANNEL, DODGER
FILMS.
I THINK IT WAS A HALLOWEEN
SPECIAL WE WERE PLAYING.
WE WERE ALL GETTING IN COSTUME
AND ALL OF THAT.
ONE OF THOSE DAYS, I WAS GOING
TO A PARTY AS A COWBOY, AND I
SHOWED BOBBY, LIKE I'M GOING TO
COME TO THE GAME JUST AS A
COWBOY.
HE SAID YOU HAVE TO BE A COWBOY
FOREVER.
TO BE HONEST, MY FIRST AT-BAT, I
HAD THE PONCHO ON, AND I FELT
LIKE IT FIXED MY SWING A LITTLE
BIT.
I WAS ABLE TO SWING BETTER IN A
PONCHO AND HAT.
IT IS NOT REALLY -- I AM NOT AN
ACTUAL COWBOY, BUT THAT IS
PRETTY MUCH HOW I GOT THE NAME.
ADNAN: YOU JUST PLAY ONE ON
YOUTUBE.
I THOUGHT MAYBE YOU WERE A BIG
FAN OF TOY STORY OR TOM HANKS.
LISTEN, COWBOY JEFF --
>> THAT IS PART OF THE REASON
WHY I WAS A COWBOY THAT YEAR,
FOR HALLOWEEN.
THAT IS MY TOP THREE FAVORITE
MOVIE OF ALL TIME, TOY STORY.
ADNAN: IT IS A GREAT FILM.
THE RARITY WITH TOY STORY IS THE
SEQUELS ARE JUST AS GOOD.
TOY STORY THREE IS OUR GILLY THE
BEST OF THE BUNCH.
THAT IS REALLY REALLY RARE.
TO INFINITY AND BEYOND, WE
CONTINUE WITH STEVE FINLEY.
THIS IS YOUR FAVORITE WALK-UP
MOMENT.
YOU COULD HAVE POINTED TO SO
MANY.
WHAT IS IT ABOUT THAT FINLEY
WALKOFF THAT STANDS OUT TO YOU?
>> THAT WHOLE SITUATION IS A
SPECIAL PLACE IN MY HEART.
I'VE BEEN A DODGERS FAN SINCE
2000.
WE HAD NOT MADE -- WE HAD NOT
WON A PLAYOFF GAME SINCE 1988.
I REMEMBER THE SECOND TO LAST
GAME OF THE SEASON, IT WAS GOING
DOWN TO THE WIRE WITH THE
GIANTS.
WE WERE DOWN BY THREE RUNS IN
THE NINTH INNING.
I WAS AT MY FRIEND'S APARTMENT
COMPLEX.
I WAS LIKE, ARE WE REALLY GOING
TO COME BACK IN THE NINTH
INNING?
OUR GUYS WERE TAKING GOOD
AT-BATS, GETTING ON BASE.
STEVE FINLEY WITH THAT MAGIC
GRAND SLAM, PUTTING THEM AWAY.
I REMEMBER THE WHOLE APARTMENT
COMPLEX, IT SEEMED LIKE IT
EXPLODED.
IT WAS NUTS.
FOR ME, IT WAS BURNED INTO MY
MEMORY FOREVER.
I KNOW THIS IS KIND OF LIKE A 1B
MOMENT FOR ME BUT -- GOT US OUR
FIRST EVER PLAYOFF WIN.
THAT SERIES AGAINST THE
CARDINALS IN 2004.
I THINK THAT IS HOW I WANT TO
PLAY ON MY YOUTUBE CHANNEL, JUST
WITH THE PASSION THAT JOSE LIMA
HAD.
HE HAD SO MUCH PASSION AND FIRE.
ONE OF THOSE THINGS THAT STAYS
WITH ME TO THIS DAY.
ADNAN: HE WAS A TON OF FUN TO
WATCH.
I HAVE ACTUALLY MET STEVE
FINLEY.
I CALLED THE CELEBRITY SOFTBALL
GAME ONE YEAR.
HE WAS VERY DOWN TO EARTH.
IF I EVER SEE HIM AGAIN, I WILL
SAY COWBOY JEFF IS A BIG FAN OF
THAT GRAND SLAM.
BEST OF LUCK FOR THE CHANNEL, GO
DODGERS.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
I APPRECIATE IT.
ADNAN: COWBOY JEFF, NOT AN
ACTUAL COWBOY.
COMING UP NEXT, DODGERS AND
PIRATES.
FOUR CAREER APPEARANCES AGAINST
PITTSBURGH.
STRETCHING OUT AND LOOKING
PRETTY GOOD.
WE HAVE OUR PICKS TO CLICK,
WE WILL PUT BUCK ON THE SPOT.
YOU WANT THESE PICKS, COMING UP
NEXT.
>> ANOTHER ONE OF THOSE DELAYED
STEALS.
>> THAT IS TOUGH.
>> REYNOLDS, SWITCH HITTER,
BATTING LEFT.
DEEP FOR THE WALKOFF -- WALK ON
HOME RUN FOR BRYAN REYNOLDS!
REYNOLDS WITH HIS EIGHTH HOME
RUN OF THE YEAR, TIES THE GAME
AT ONE.
>> SENDING HIM BACK TO THE
TRACK, TO THE WALL!
CLEARED THE DECK WITH A
CANNONBALL.
KE'BRYAN HAYES, YOU'VE GOT TO BE
GETTING ME!
LINE DRIVE TO LEFT FIELD!
THIS IS GOING TO GET DOWN!
JACOB STALLINGS, THE CHEETAH
JUST DOUBLED IN, 1, 2 AND THREE
RUNS!
HOW ABOUT THAT!
>> FLY BALL, CENTER FIELD.
THAT'LL DO IT!
WALK IT OFF CHEETAH!
WHAT A GRIND IT OUT WIN IN 12
FOR THE BATTLING BUCS.
THE PIRATES WIN THE FIRST THREE
GAMES OF THIS FOUR-GAME SERIES
AGAINST THE MARLINS.
ADNAN: RAISE THE JOLLY ROGER.
WELCOME BACK TO MLB GAME OF THE
WEEK PREGAME SHOW, PRESENTED BY
JIM BEAM.
TIME NOW FOR PICKS TO CLICK,
PRESENTED BY BETMGM.
YOU SAW JUSTIN TURNER OUT THERE
TALKING SHOP.
DO YOU THINK HE WAS TALKING
WORLD SERIES?
BUCK: WITHOUT A DOUBT.
ADNAN: FIRST QUESTION, ARE THE
DODGER STILL YOUR FAVORITE TO
REPRESENT THE NATIONAL LEAGUE IN
THE WORLD SERIES?
BUCK: YES.
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE THE PADRES
BECAUSE I THINK IT WOULD BE
GREAT FOR BASEBALL.
IT WOULD BE GOOD AT THE DODGERS
GOT THERE TOO.
I THINK THEY ARE THE FAVORITE.
ADNAN: TO ME, THE SURPRISE IS
THE METS ARE AT PLUS 500.
THE BRAVES I STILL THINK WILL
TURN AROUND.
THE BREWERS, I DON'T KNOW BUT
THEIR STARTING PITCHER HAS BEEN
GREAT -- STARTING PITCHING HAS
BEEN GREAT.
I'M SURPRISED THE CUBS ARE NOT
IN THE TOP FIVE.
BUCK: I AM NOT SURE ABOUT THEIR
STARTING PITCHING YET.
ADNAN: BUT AS ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY I LIKE THE GIANTS IS THEIR
STARTING PITCHING, BUT A TOUGH
DIVISION WITH THE DODGERS AND
THE PADRES.
WHICH DODGER HAS THE BEST SHOT
AT THE N.L. M.V.P. AWARD?
BUCK: I WOULD SAY CHRIS TAYLOR,
BUT A LOT OF PEOPLE WOULD NOT
CONSIDER HIM SEXY ENOUGH.
I LIKE WALKER BUEHLER.
I THINK AT SOME POINT, I THINK
THE PITCHING IS SUCH A SEPARATOR
FOR THEM AND I THINK HE IS
GETTING READY TO HAVE A MONSTER
YEAR AND REALLY HAVE PEOPLE --
IF YOU ASKED THOSE GUYS IN THE
CLUB WHAT HAS BEEN THE ROCK, IT
HAS BEEN THOSE STARTING
PITCHERS.
WE BEGIN WITH MOOKIE BETTS, MAX
MUNCY ON A ROLL SINCE MAY 1.
JUSTIN TURNER AND THEN
BELLINGER, MCKINSTRY, LUX,
BARNES IS AT CATCHER TODAY AND
URIAS WILL BE PITCHING.
LET'S GET GOING.
IT IS THE PIRATES AND THE
DODGERS, LIVE ON YOUTUBE.
A FASTBALL DELIVERED UPSTAIRS TO
MOOKIE BETTS TO START THE DAY IN
THE FIRST.
MOOKIE GOING 0-5 YESTERDAY.
THREE FOR HIS LAST 22.
WE SPOKE TO DAVE ABOUT AT THIS
MORNING, AS HE SAID HE IS
MISSING SOME BASEBALLS THROUGH
THE ZONE AND NOT ENDING AT BATS.
HERE IS MITCH KELLER ON THE
MOUND FOR PITTSBURGH.
E.R.A. IS THIRD WORST IN THE
SPORT.
THE TALENT IS THERE.
IT IS JUST ABOUT FASTBALL
COMMAND AS THE 2-0 IS SOCKED TO
CENTER FIELD.
REYNOLD LOOKS BACK, FORGET ABOUT
IT!
THIRD PITCH OF THE GAME, MOOKIE
BETTS GOES LONG.
IT IS 1-0 DODGERS.
JERRY: YOU SET -- SEAN: YOU SAID
IT BEST RIGHT THERE, SCOTT.
93 MILES PER HOUR, YOU CAN'T
MISS THE MOOKIE BETTS RIGHT DOWN
THE MIDDLE.
HE IS GOING TO MAKE YOU PAY.
IF KELLER DOESN'T HIT HIS SPOTS,
IT IS GOING TO BE A LONG DAY.
LOOK AT THE SWING RIGHT HERE.
CENTER CUT, MOOKIE BETTS.
RIGHT DOWN THE MIDDLE.
MOOKIE BETTS SAYS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, LET'S GET ON THE BOARD.
SCOTT: THERE IS A STRIKE TO
MUNCY.
25TH CAREER LEADOFF HOME RUN.
JERRY: GOOD TO SEE MOOKIE BETTS
GET ON THE FASTBALL.
HE HAS BEEN STRUGGLING WITH
FASTBALLS AND DAVE ROBERTS
TALKED ABOUT IT WITH US EARLIER.
REALLY HARD TO GET ON TOP OF THE
FASTBALL.
HE CERTAINLY GOT ON TOP OF THE
FASTBALL THAT TIME.
SCOTT: AND HE WENT TO CENTER
FIELD.
WE SPOKE TO DAVE THIS MORNING
ABOUT THE POLE POWER THAT -- THE
PULL POWER THAT MOOKIE HAS.
THAT TIME, HE WAS GOING TO A
DEEP PART OF THE BALLPARK AND
SHOWING OFF SKILLS.
JERRY: POUND FOR POUND, ONE OF
THE STRONGEST BASEBALL PLAYERS
AROUND.
YOU SEE A BALL INSIDE.
ONLY 5'9", ABOUT 170 POUNDS.
HE HAS TREMENDOUS POWER.
SCOTT: MOOKIE BETTS WITH SICK
BAT SPEED.
MUNCY HAS THE I HAVE A CHAMPION
-- HAS THE EYE OF A CHAMPION.
HE LEADS THE N.L. WITH HIS .420
ON-BASE PERCENTAGE.
JERRY: YOU MENTIONED THE WALKS,
SCOTTY.
HE CERTAINLY HAS A GREAT EYE.
THIS PAST MONTH OR SO, HE HAS
BEEN AGGRESSIVE, ESPECIALLY IN
THE ZONE.
SCOTT: HE STRIKES OUT ON SOME
HIGH HEAT FROM KELLER.
LET'S HAVE A LOOK AT THE BETMGM
ODDS TODAY.
TOTAL RUNS, EIGHT.
OVER/UNDER, DO WE THINK THIS IS
GOING TO BE A HIGH-SCORING
EVENT?
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THE RUN
LINE?
JERRY: THAT IS A GENEROUS OVER,
OVER EIGHT.
I THINK IT IS GOING TO BE AROUND
EIGHT.
I KNOW KELLER HAS STRUGGLED A
BIT WITH HIS COMMAND, BUT THE
DODGERS ARE LOOKING TO SWING THE
BAT.
SCOTT: THE THING WITH THE
DODGERS OFFENSE, IT HAS BEEN
STREAKY BUT IN ABOUT THE PAST
WEEK, WE HAVE SEEN THEM EXPLODE
FOR A DOUBLE DIGIT RUN INNING.
WE HAVE ALSO SEEN THEM ON FRIDAY
PUT UP EIGHT AGAINST THE BRAVES.
JUSTIN TURNER HAS HIMSELF A
KNOCK, AS HE KEEPS THE MOMENTUM
GOING FROM YESTERDAY.
CASE, JUSTIN TURNER WITH TWO
HOMERS.
A MULTI-HIT PERFORMANCE AND HE
IS LOCKED IN.
SEAN: HIS BAT, WHEN TURNER GETS
GOING, WHEN YOU SEE HIM HIT THE
BALL CENTER FIELD OR LEFT FIELD,
THIS IS WHERE HE IS THE BEST.
THAT IS THE GREAT -- THAT IS A
GREAT SIGN FOR THE DODGERS RIGHT
THERE.
JERRY: HE'S GOT ONE OF THE
PRETTIEST RIGHT-HANDED SWINGS
YOU WILL EVER SEE.
SCOTT: NOW IT IS BELLINGER,
TAKING A BREAKING BALL FOR A
STRIKE.
SEAN: CODY SPENT SOME TIME THIS
SEASON LOOKING TO GET HIS TIMING
BACK IN THE BATTER'S BOX.
ONCE HIS TIMING IS BACK, HE IS
AS DEADLY A HITTER AS THERE IS.
THE KIDS CALL HIM CODY LOVE, ON
THE WEST COAST.
SCOTT: I'M GOING TO RELY ON YOU
FOR ALL THE NICKNAMES.
I WAS WATCHING YOU YESTERDAY, TO
GIVE JUSTIN TURNER SOMETHING I
HADN'T HEARD BEFORE.
I BELIEVE IT WAS DREAM RED, AS
BELLINGER STRIKES OUT ON THREE
PITCHES.
GOOD FASTBALL FROM KELLER.
JERRY: HE HAS A VARIETY OF
NICKNAMES.
MR. J.T., ESPECIALLY WHEN HE HAS
MULTI-HOMER GAMES.
WE ALSO CALL HIM THE RED DREAM.
THAT IS A PRETTY GOOD FASTBALL
UP IN THE ZONE.
SCOTT: THAT IS WHAT THEY WOULD
LIKE TO SEE MORE OF, FROM MITCH
KELLER.
FASTBALL COMMAND WASN'T A HUGE
ISSUE FOR HIM IN THE MINOR
LEAGUES.
THEN IN THE MAJOR LEAGUES SO
FAR, THERE HAS BEEN A BEVY OF
WALKS TO HIS LINE, THE PAST
COUPLE OF SEASONS.
ALSO SOME MISSES OVER THE PLATE.
IF YOU DO THAT TO THIS DODGER
TEAM, YOU ARE IN TROUBLE.
SEAN: DEFINITELY IN TROUBLE.
WHEN YOU WATCH KELLER PITCH, HE
DOESN'T ATTACK THE ZONE
SOMETIMES.
THAT IS WHERE YOU TALK ABOUT
FASTBALL COMMAND.
HE IS KIND OF DANCING A LITTLE
BIT.
FOR MITCH KELLER, HE HAS TO BE
RIGHT ON.
IF HE MISSES TODAY, THE DODGERS
WILL MAKE HIM PAY.
JERRY: EVEN THOUGH THE DODGERS
ARE A PATIENT GROUP, THEY ARE
HUNTING PITCHES UP IN THE ZONE,
ESPECIALLY MIDDLE OF THE PLATE.
THEY WILL TRY TO GET INTO
FAVORABLE COUNTS, ESPECIALLY
AGAINST YOUNG PITCHERS LIKE
KELLER.
SCOTT: BRINGING THE GOOD STUFF.
HE LASTED JUST TWO INNINGS ON
FRIDAY AGAINST MIAMI, GAVE UP A
COUPLE HITS AND A PAIR OF RUNS.
LEFT THE GAME EARLY WITH HEAT
ILLNESS.
IT ENDED UP AFFECTING HIM WITH
HIS STOMACH AS WELL.
THEY PLACED HIM ON THE COVID
INJURED LIST FOR A COUPLE DAYS.
EVERYTHING CHECKED OUT OK, AND
HE IS BACK IN ACTION, ON TURN
FOR THIS OUTING.
THAT IS SENT TO LEFT FIELD.
KA'AI TOM, RIGHT THERE.
THIRD PITCH OF THE AFTERNOON,
AND THIS IS THE BAT SPEED.
QUICK HANDS, THE FORMER M.V.P.
PUTTING THE DODGERS ON THE
FIRST.
>> HARD TO CENTER FIELD.
TO THE TRACK, TO THE WALL!
CLEARED THE DECK WITH A
CANNONBALL!
KE'BRYAN HAYES, YOU'VE GOT TO BE
GETTING ME!
-- YOU GOTTA BE KIDDING ME!
>> HE HIT THE HECK OUT OF THAT.
>> TWO HITS FOR HAYES, ON BASE
FOR A THIRD TIME.
TWO RUN HOMER IN THE FIRST.
HARD TO RIGHT.
LOOKING UP, AND IT IS OFF THE
WALL.
ANOTHER ROCKET TO RIGHT FIELD
FOR KE'BRYAN HAYES.
INTO THIRD WITH A TRIPLE, AND
WELCOME BACK.
HE IS TO FOR THREE.
-- HE IS TWO FOR THREE.
>> A FLY BALL TO LEFT CENTER
FIELD.
THAT IS IN THE GAP.
KE'BRYAN HAYES, INTO SECOND BASE
WITH A LEADOFF DOUBLE.
>> TOP OF THE ZONE, JUST A GREAT
SWING.
I DON'T REMEMBER EVER SEE A GUY
-- EVER SEEING A GUY START LIKE
HE HAS.
SCOTT: DODGERS UP A RUN ALREADY.
IT IS THE JIM BEAM STARTING
LINEUP FOR THE HOMETOWN
PITTSBURGH PIRATES.
ADAM FRAZIER, KE'BRYAN HAYES
BRINGS THE BAT AND THE GLOVE.
BRYAN REYNOLDS IS THE SWITCH
HITTER.
JACOB STALLINGS HAVING HIS BEST
OFFENSIVE SEASON.
EVANS, GONZALEZ, TOM, NEWMAN
WITH HIS CONTACT AND KELLER IN
THE NINE SPOT.
URIAS DEALS TO FRAZIER.
FASTBALL MISSES AWAY.
JULIO URIAS MAKING HIS 13TH
START OF THE SEASON.
E.R.A. IN THE MID-THREES.
HE HAS BEEN EXCELLENT, GIVING
THIS TEAM MUCH MORE LENGTH THIS
SEASON AS WELL.
FRAZIER FOULS IT BACK.
LET'S GO OVER THE KEYS FOR URIAS
, PRESENTED BY JIM BEAM.
JERRY: THE KEYS FOR URIAS AND
FOR THE DODGERS, URIAS HAS TO
PITCH DEEP IN THIS BALLGAME.
LAST NIGHT TURNED OUT TO BE A
BULLPEN GAME.
WE NEED SIX OF SEVEN INNINGS OUT
OF URIAS.
EARLY OFFENSE GOT THAT WITH
MOOKIE BETTS.
URIAS, A LEFT-HANDED PITCHER,
YOU CANNOT LET RIGHT-HANDED
HAYES BEAT YOU.
HE'S GOT TREMENDOUS POWER.
SCOTT: KE'BRYAN HAYES ON-DECK.
FRAZIER UNFAZED WITH TWO STRIKES
AS HE HAS 78 HITS ON THE SEASON,
RIDING A STREAK AT THE MOMENT.
LAST YEAR WAS JUST A 60 GAME
SEASON.
THERE WERE A FEW BATS IN THIS
LINEUP THAT JUST NEVER GOT IT
GOING.
THEN YOU START PRESSING BECAUSE
YOU KNOW THE END IS YEAR -- END
IS NEAR.
FRAZIER FOULS ANOTHER ONE OFF.
SEAN: I THINK DEREK SHELTON WAS
TALKING ABOUT THAT BEFORE THE
GAME.
ONCE YOU STRUGGLE SOMETIMES AS A
PLAYER, YOU TRY AND GET THOSE
THREE OR FOUR HITS THAT NEXT
GAME WITH A SIX TO GAME SEASON,
YOU NEVER CATCH UP.
ADAM FRAZIER HAS COME OUT WITH
THAT SHORT SWING, GOT HOT EARLY
AND HE HAS NEVER STOPPED.
JERRY: ESPECIALLY TODAY'S
BALLGAME, WITH A LOT OF GUYS
TRYING TO LIFT THE BASEBALL AND
TRYING TO HIT HOME RUNS.
FRAZIER IS A THROWBACK, CONTACT
GUY, LOOKING TO GO THE OTHER
WAY.
DOESN'T STRIKE OFFENSE, SO HE
HAS BEEN OUTSTANDING PUTTING THE
BAT ON THE BASEBALL.
SCOTT: LOOK AT THIS BATTLE FROM
ADAM FRAZIER, TRYING TO WORK UP
THAT PITCH COUNT.
STATCAST, POWERED BY GOOGLE
CLOUD.
ADAM FRAZIER KNOWS HOW TO SWING
THE BAT.
ERIC SHELTON TOLD US HE HAD
NEVER SEEN ANYONE AS SHORT TO
THE BASEBALL AS FRAZIER.
THERE IS A LOT OF RED ON THIS
BATTING AVERAGE ZONE.
SEAN: THERE IS NO WAY TO PITCH
THIS GUY.
IT IS THAT UP AND IN.
URIAS GOT HIM OUT FRONT BUT
FRAZIER HAS COVERED THE WHOLE
PLATE AND EVERY ZONE SO FAR THIS
SEASON.
SCOTT: HE TAKES WHAT HE IS
GIVEN.
NICELY DONE BY URIAS TO WIN THE
BATTLE.
IT IS THE DODGERS DEFENSE,
PRESENTED BY JIM BEAM.
LUX AND TURNER IN FIELD.
BEATY, BELLINGER AND BETTS
OUTFIELD.
JERRY: THEY CAN GO GET IT.
SCOTT: INSIDE TO HAYES, AND ALSO
KEEP IN MIND THAT IN PITTSBURGH,
IT IS THE LARGEST LEFT FIELD
TERRITORY IN MLB.
THERE WILL BE EXTRA WORK, EXTRA
RUNNING FOR BEATY THIS
AFTERNOON.
JERRY: THAT IS WHERE CODY
BELLINGER COMES IN.
MATT BEATY DOES NOT PLAY A WHOLE
LOT OF LEFT FIELD.
CODY BELLINGER SHOULD BE SHADING
A LITTLE BIT TOWARD LEFT CENTER
FIELD, TO HAVE -- TO HELP BEATY
BECAUSE YOU KNOW YOU HAVE MOOKIE
IN RIGHT.
SCOTT: HAYES WITH A DRIVE, LEFT
CENTER.
BELLINGER GIVING IT A LOOK AND
IT IS GOING TO KICK UP OFF OF
THE WALL.
KE'BRYAN HAYES WILL HEAD TO THE
DASCHLE HAD TO SECOND BASE.
-- KE'BRYAN HAYES WILL HEAD TO
SECOND BASE.
JERRY: YOU GO BACK AND LOOK AT
THAT.
URIAS TRIES TO COME MIDDLE IN
WITH THE FASTBALL.
HE DROPS A CHANGEUP ON THE WAY.
GETS IT TO 2-0.
HE GETS IT HERE AND THROWS
ANOTHER CHANGEUP.
WHEN YOU GET A CHANGEUP THAT
DOESN'T DO THAT MUCH ACTION AND
STAYS UP, IT IS LIKE AVP
FASTBALL.
KE'BRYAN HAYES DOES A GREAT JOB
OF STAYING THROUGH IT.
JERRY: IT WAS A HANGING COMBO BY
URIAS AND HAYES WAS ALL OVER IT.
VERY FORTUNATE FOR URIAS THAT HE
KEPT IT IN THE YARD.
SCOTT: NUMBER THREE HITTER,
BRYAN REYNOLDS.
JERRY: I THINK I SEE THAT MORE
OFTEN FOR JULIO.
MORE OF THAT CHANGEUP TO KEEP
THESE PIRATES HITTERS
OFF-BALANCE.
SCOTT: THOSE TWO HAVE BEEN HIS
MOST DOMINANT PITCHES.
THE CURVEBALL IS HOW HE STARTS
REYNOLDS.
SECOND PITCH, HE GOES AFTER IT.
CENTER, DRIFTING BACK, BELLINGER
TO MAKE THE CATCH.
HAYES WILL TAG UP.
JERRY: BELLINGER JUST COMING
BACK FROM THAT LEG INJURY,
SHOWING HIS GREAT RANGE RIGHT
THERE, GOING BACK ON THE BALL.
HE'S AS GOOD AS IT GETS IN
CENTER FIELD, AS FAR AS GOING
BACK ON THE BASEBALL.
SCOTT: DAVE ROBERTS TOLD US.
JERRY: SHOW HAIR.
SCOTT: ELITE DEFENSE.
HASN'T COMPLETELY TURNED IT ON
YET, THE 2019 M.V.P., BUT HIS
MANAGER GAVE US A PREDICTION WE
CAN USE TODAY.
HE GOES, CODY IS GOING DEEP ON A
HANGING BREAKING BALL THIS
AFTERNOON.
BOOK IT.
[LAUGHTER]
JERRY: THERE IS DOC, RIGHT
THERE IN THE SHADES.
CAREER 91 HITTER IN PITTSBURGH.
DOC COULD SWING IT.
WE TALK ABOUT HIS STOLEN BASES
BUT HE COULD SWING IT TOO.
THIS IS A GUY RIGHT HERE THAT
HAS REALLY GOT A CHANCE TO PLAY.
THEY LOVE HIM AS A GOLD GLOVER
BEHIND THE DISH BUT HE HAS SWUNG
THE BAT WELL FOR THE PIRATES
THIS YEAR.
SCOTT: LUX WILL THROW A CROSS
ATHLETIC PLAY TO COMPLETE THE
FIRST, IS STRANDED AT
THIRD.
URIAS AND THE DODGERS UP 1-0
AFTER ONE.
>> YOU SEE >> >> -- KE'BRYAN --
>> KE'BRYAN HAYES.
HARD THE OTHER WAY.
IT IS GONE!
IT HIT THE POLE.
OPPOSITE FIELD HOME RUN FOR
KE'BRYAN HAYES!
>> DODGERS ARE EITHER ASKING FOR
A REVIEW OF THE HOME RUN, OR
THEY ALSO APPEAL FIRST BASE.
HE DID MISS FIRST.
THEY ARE CALLING HIM OUT.
THAT IS UNBELIEVABLE.
HOLY SMOKES.
>> MOOKIE BETTS SWATS THIS ONE
IN THE AIR.
BACK GOES REYNOLDS.
HE CAN'T GET IT!
UP AGAINST THE WALL.
SPRINTING FOR THIRD WITH AN
R.B.I. TRIPLE.
DODGERS LEAD IT 2-0.
THAT PITCH IS DRILLED, LEFT
CENTER FIELD.
FORGET ABOUT IT!
HOME RUN, CHRIS TAYLOR.
SOUNDED LIKE A SHOTGUN GOING
OFF.
EIGHTH OF THE SEASON FOR TAYLOR.
THE DODGERS LEAD 5-0.
SCOTT: HERE IS A LOOK AT MITCH
KELLER, AND THE INCONSISTENCIES
WE HAVE SEEN SO FAR THIS SEASON.
SOME STARTS, HE IS ELECTRIC.
OTHERS, HE IS SEARCHING.
FASTBALL COMMAND IS THE STORY.
LET'S SET UP THE JIM BEAM PITS
-- JIM BEAM KEYS FOR THE
PITTSBURGH PIRATES.
SEAN: I THINK THAT IS THE KEY
RIGHT HERE.
MITCH KELLER HAS TO THROW
STRIKES.
HE HAS 26 WALKS IN ONLY 44
INNINGS PITCHED.
THAT IS GOING TO BE THE KEY
TODAY.
TOP OF THE ORDER PRODUCTION.
KE'BRYAN HAYES ALREADY HAS THAT
BIG HIT.
THAT HAS TO BE HUGE FOR THEM.
BULLPEN CONSISTENCY FOR DEREK
SHELTON.
RODRIGUEZ AT THE BACK END.
THEY HAVE BEEN GOOD.
THEY HAVE TO BE CONSISTENT AGAIN
TODAY.
SCOTT: WE HAD A NICE CHAT WITH
DEREK SHELTON THIS MORNING.
I LOVE HIS DEMEANOR.
HE KNOWS WHAT HE IS WORKING WITH
RIGHT NOW.
THE PIRATES CHECKING IN AT
23-37, THEY HAD THE WORST RECORD
IN THE NATIONAL LEAGUE LAST
YEAR.
THEY ARE STILL BUILDING
THEMSELVES BACK.
YOU HAVE TO BRING THAT POSITIVE
ATTITUDE, EVERY DAY TO THE
BALLPARK AND UTILIZE YOUR JOB
NOT JUST AS TRYING TO WIN GAMES
BUT ALSO TEACH AND VILLA
BASEBALL PLAYERS.
-- AND DEVELOP BASEBALL PLAYERS.
SEAN: AND HE IS VERY
INTELLIGENT.
HE KNOWS HIS GAME.
SCOTT: WHERE DID YOU GO TO
SCHOOL JERRY?
JERRY: I ALSO WENT TO SOUTHERN
ILLINOIS.
SCOTT: THERE WE GO.
[LAUGHTER]
JERRY: LOOK AT THOSE SHADES.
A GOOD LOOKING BEAST RIGHT
THERE.
HE REMINDS ME OF A BETTER
LOOKING VERSION OF SKIP
SCHUMAKER.
SAME SWING, SAME APPROACH AT THE
PLATE.
WAY BETTER LOOKING.
SEAN: JERRY, WHAT DO YOU LIKE
ABOUT HIM?
WHAT DO YOU LIKE MOST ABOUT HIM?
JERRY: HE IS A THROWBACK
SCRAPPER TYPE.
GREAT BAT BALTIMORE BALL SKILLS
-- BALL TO BALL SKILLS.
HE CAN PLAY OUTFIELD, SECOND,
SHORT.
HE IS A POOR MAN'S CT3 RIGHT
NOW.
SCOTT: THIRD STRIKE OUT FOR
KELLER.
HERE IS A LOOK AT THE JIM BEAM
DEFENSIVE ALIGNMENT THE PIRATES.
KELLER AND STALLINGS THE
BATTERY.
FRAZIER AND NEWMAN THE DOUBLE
PLAY COMBO.
TOM, REYNOLDS, EVANS FROM LEFT
TO RIGHT IN THE OUTFIELD.
NOW IT IS GAVIN LUX, 23 YEARS
OLD.
HE HAS TAKEN OFF SINCE TAKING
OVER AS THE SHORTSTOP FOR THE
DODGERS, SINCE COREY SEAGER WENT
DOWN IN MID-MAY WITH A FRACTURED
RIGHT HAND.
JERRY: AND HE HAS REALLY GROWN
UP.
KNOWING THAT COREY SEAGER WAS
LOST FOR AT LEAST A MONTH, SO
THIS DODGER TEAM NEEDED HIM.
HE SWUNG THE BAT ON CUE, ROCKET
TO LEFT.
SCOTT: THROUGH THE LEFT SIDE.
HE IS ON WITH A ONE OUT SINGLE.
JERRY: HE HAS BEEN SOLID
DEFENSIVELY AS WELL AS
OFFENSIVELY.
HE IS STARTING TO GROW, INTO
THAT PLAYER THE DODGERS KNEW HE
COULD BECOME.
SEAN: WHEN I WATCHED LUX WHEN HE
FIRST CAME UP.
I SAID THIS KID REALLY USES THE
WHOLE FIELD.
HE DOES A GREAT JOB VISUALLY OF
LETTING THAT BALL TRAVELING AND
SHOOTING IT TO LEFT.
JERRY: ESPECIALLY IN TODAY'S
GAME WITH SO MANY SHIFTS.
IF YOU CAN HANDLE A BAT, THERE
ARE SO MANY HITS OUT THERE.
SCOTT: AND THAT IS WHY WHEN
SEAGER WENT DOWN, THE DODGERS
REALLY DON'T SKIP MUCH OF A
BEAT.
36 WINS, 25 LOSSES.
A VERY COMPETITIVE NATIONAL
LEAGUE WEST.
TWO CAME IS BACK -- TWO GAMES
BACK BEHIND THE GIANTS.
JERRY: YOU'VE GOT AUSTIN BARNES
AT THE PLATE RIGHT HERE.
THE KIDS CALL HIM THE REAL A.B.
HE DOESN'T OUTSTANDING JOB
HANDLING THE BAT AND HANDLING
THE PITCHING STAFF.
SEAN: JERRY, I HEARD TEAMMATES
ALSO CALL HIM SAM, A STORY THAT
GOES BACK TO CHASE UTLEY'S DAYS
WITH THE TEAM, WHEN HE WAS
TELLING THEM TO GRAB SOME FOOD
AND A.J. ELLIS AT THE TIME OF
THE DODGERS SAID YOU DON'T EVEN
KNOW HIS NAME, AND UTLEY JOKED,
HIS NAME IS SAM.
JERRY: AND IT STUCK.
CHASE UTLEY, STILL AROUND IN THE
L.A. AREA.
BUT YOU ARE RIGHT, HE WAS A
GREAT LEADER FOR THIS DODGER
TEAM.
SAM, ALSO KNOWN AS AUSTIN
BARNES, HAS BECOME QUITE A
LEADER HIMSELF.
SCOTT: AND A FOUR PITCH WALK.
TWO ON BOARD NOW FOR THE
DODGERS.
HOW COMPETITIVE IS THIS N.L.
WEST, EVEN MORE SO MAYBE THAN WE
THOUGHT?
>> I THINK SO.
THE GIANTS HAVE CHANGED
EVERYTHING.
YOU LOOK AT THIS DIVISION WITHIN
THE NATIONAL LEAGUE, THE TOP
THREE TEAMS IN RUN DIFFERENTIAL
AMONG ANY N.L. TEAM, ALL THREE
OF THEM RIGHT NOW ARE IN THE
NATIONAL LEAGUE WEST, OF COURSE,
LED BY THE SURPRISING SAN
FRANCISCO GIANTS.
ALL THOSE NAMES ON THE OLD WORLD
SERIES WINNING TEAMS, ALL
CONTRIBUTING IN A BIG WAY.
IT'S MADE THE DODGERS' BID TO
REPEAT ALL THE MORE CHALLENGING.
SCOTT: WE HAD THE GIANTS ON
YOUTUBE A COUPLE WEEKS AGO.
I BELIEVE THE FINAL TALLY WAS
19-4.
THEIR WIN OVER CINCINNATI.
IT'S A TEAM THAT HAS DONE A
REALLY NICE JOB OF PICKING UP
STARTING PITCHERS THIS
OFF-SEASON.
THAT'S A FOUL BALL.
DON'T WORRY.
BUT ALSO THE GIANTS HAVE SOME
SNEAKY BATS, BOTH VETERANS THAT
HAVE KIND OF HIT THEIR PRIME
AGAIN IN BUSTER POSEY AND
BRANDON CRAWFORD, AND THEN SOME
NEW GUYS AS WELL, LIKE MIKE
YASTRZEMSKI.
I KNOW JERRY, YOU GET TO SEE THE
GIANTS QUITE A BIT.
HOW SURPRISED ARE YOU WITH THEIR
PRODUCTION?
JERRY: A LITTLE SURPRISED,
ESPECIALLY THEIR STATTING
PITCHING HAS BEEN OUTSTANDING.
ANYTIME YOU GET GREAT STARTING
PITCHING, YOU ARE IN EVERY
BALLGAME AND THEN SCOTTY, YOU
MENTIONED THE REBIRTH OF BUSTER
POSEY.
EVAN LONGORIA HAS HAD A GREAT
SEASON SO FAR.
SCOTT: THAT'S A FAIR BALL.
URIAS WILL ADVANCE BOTH RUNNERS.
NICE JOB ON THE BUNT.
I SAW HIM DO THAT LAST WEEK ON
FRIDAY AGAINST THE BRAVES TO
SPARK THE BIG INNING FOR THE
DODGERS.
IT WAS ACTUALLY A SUICIDE
SQUEEZE AT THE TIME THAT SCORED
A RUN.
SO URIAS DOES HIS JOB THIS
AFTERNOON AND TWO ARE IN SCORING
POSITION.
JERRY: ALL ABOUT THE
FUNDAMENTALS.
JULIO DOES A GREAT JOB.
EVEN THOUGH IT'S A POP-UP, IT'S
DOWN.
SOFT BUNT.
ALL ABOUT THE EXECUTION.
THAT'S LIKE MY LOB WEDGE THERE,
CASE.
ON THE GREEN.
GET THE JOB DONE.
SEAN: JUST GOT TO PUTT IT FROM
THERE, JERRY.
JUST GOT TO PUTT IT FROM THERE.
SCOTT: NOW IT'S BETTS.
BETTS HAD THE HOMER IN HIS FIRST
A.B.
CASE, OR JERRY, I WILL GO TO YOU
FIRST, CASE, SHOULD KE'BRYAN
HAYES BE PLAYING EVEN CLOSER TO
URIAS ON THAT PLAY KNOWING
WHAT'S COMING?
SEAN: HE WAS IN -- HE WAS STILL
IN.
I DON'T THINK HE SHOULD HAVE
BEEN ANY CLOSER, BUT HE WAS
STILL IN AND THE BALL FELL IN
THAT BERMUDA TRIANGLE AND GOT
DOWN JUST ENOUGH THAT HAYES
COULDN'T GET IT.
JULIO IS ALSO A GOOD ATHLETE.
HE CAN HANDLE A BAT.
IF HAYES IS CHARGING, HE HAS THE
GO-AHEAD TO SLASH FROM DAVE
ROBERTS.
SO YOU GOT A CHANCE TO -- AS A
THIRD BASEMAN YOU HAVE TO LAY
BACK A LITTLE BIT, MAKE SURE HE
GETS THE BUNT DOWN AND THEN MAKE
THE PLAY.
SCOTT: SCATCAST, MOOKIE BETTS ON
PITCH NUMBER THREE OF THE DAY.
LOBBED ALL OF THAT ONE, 417 FEET
TO DEEP CENTRAL.
JERRY: I LOVE THAT SWING BY
MOOKIE BETTS, GREAT SHOW CHAIN
RIGHT THERE, OUTSTANDING TOP
HAND.
THAT'S THE KEY TO HIS SWING.
WHEN HE FINISHES HIS SWING,
THAT'S WHEN YOU SEE THE POWER.
SEAN: IT LOOKS LIKE KELLER IS
PITCHING HIM REALLY CAREFUL
HERE.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE THE
INTENTIONAL, UNINTENTIONAL WALK.
THEY'RE NOT LOOKING TO GIVE HIM
MUCH THERE, A LITTLE CURVEBALL
3-1 ON THE OUTER HALF.
SCOTT: YOU HAVE MAX MUNCY ON
DECK.
JERRY: DON'T BE TOO CAREFUL.
SCOTT: TURNER AFTER THAT WHO
HOMERED TWICE YESTERDAY.
JERRY: OH, BOY.
SCOTT: HITTER'S COUNT.
DID HE GO?
HE DID.
FULL BOAT.
JERRY: THE 3-1 PITCH.
LOOKING FOR THE FASTBALL, GOT
THE SLIDER.
SCOTT: SLIDER IS THE SECOND MOST
USED PITCH IN THE ARSENAL FOR
KELLER, FOUR-SEAM DOMINATES.
THAT ONE JUST MISSED.
ALMOST LANDED IN THE ZONE BY
ACCIDENT, BUT IT'S BALL FOUR TO
BETTS.
SEAN: YOU GOT TO GIVE KELLER
SOME CREDIT THERE BECAUSE HE
COMES WITH THE 3-2 CURVEBALL,
LOOKS LIKE HE MIGHT HAVE GOT THE
TOP OF THE ZONE RIGHT THERE.
THE UMPIRE DIDN'T GIVE IT TO
HIM, BUT HE PITCHED MOOKIE BETTS
TOUGH RIGHT THERE, DIDN'T GIVE
IN TO HIM, WAS GIVING HIM SLIDE
-- SLIDERS AND CURVEBALLS AND
BARELY WALKED HIM IN THE END.
JERRY: NOW COMES MAX MUNCY, WHO
HAS BEEN THE DODGERS' BEST
OVERALL HITTER, 13 BOMBS ON THE
SEASON.
SCOTT: GOOD FASTBALL INSIDE.
FROM KELLER.
JERRY: THIS STAT IS SURPRISING,
.182 CAREER HITTER WITH THE
BASES LOADED.
SCOTT: JUST IN GENERAL THIS
SEASON, MUNCY IS 2-17 AND NOW
TWO STRIKES AGAINST HIM.
HE IS MAD ABOUT IT.
JERRY: THIS IS WHAT THEY WANT
KELLER TO DO WITH THE FASTBALL.
ESTABLISH THE FASTBALL IN.
THEY'RE ATTACKING MUNCY.
95 IN, 96 IN.
ANOTHER ONE RIGHT HERE.
IF YOU ARE GOING TO GET IT IN TO
MUNCY, YOU BETTER BURY IT WHERE
MUNCY WASN'T ABLE TO GET TO IT.
SCOTT: BASES LOADED.
BIG PITCH FROM KELLER.
AND HE MISSES INSIDE.
JERRY: PRETTY GOOD SLIDER THERE,
8  -- 87 MILES AN HOUR BY
KELLER.
YOU SEE THE DEFENSIVE SHIFT
THERE ON MUNCY.
MUNCY, LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS, HAS
DONE A PRETTY GOOD JOB WITH TWO
STRIKES GOING THE OTHER WAY.
LOOK FOR HIM TO TRY TO GET
SOMETHING UP, SHOOT IT TO LEFT
FIELD.
SCOTT: HE DOES SHOOT THAT BALL
TO DEEP RIGHT, BUT IT'S TWISTING
AND IT IS A LONG FOUL BALL.
JERRY: WOW.
MUNCY WANTS THAT PITCH BACK
BECAUSE THAT WAS A HANGER.
IF HE WAITS A TICK LONGER,
THAT'S WHY THIS GAME IS A GAME
OF INCHES.
IF HE WAITS A TICK LONGER, THAT
BALL IS IN THE RIVER, FAIR.
HE LOOKED LIKE HE WAS LOOKING TO
GO TO PHILADELPHIA WITH THAT
SWING.
SEAN: HE WAS.
MAN, HE HAS COME INSIDE TO MUNCY
ALMOST ON EVERY PITCH.
YOU WONDER IF HE IS GOING TO TRY
AND DO SOMETHING SOFT AWAY OR
DOES HE CONTINUE TO POUND HIM
INSIDE?
JERRY: YOU ARE RIGHT, CASE.
IF I AM MAX, I AM LOOKING OUT
THERE.
EVERYTHING HAS BEEN IN.
MAYBE TO KEEP ME HONEST, MAYBE A
FASTBALL OR A BREAKING BALL
AWAY.
SCOTT: 1-2 ON ITS WAY.
THAT'S A SPINNER.
THAT WILL TWIST OUT OF PLAY.
SEAN: HE CONTINUES TO COME BACK
IN THERE, 98 DOWN ADD IN.
I KNOW AS A HITTER, IF I AM
BEING ATTACKED AND YOU KEEP
ATTACKING ME IN, YOU KNOW, YOU
ARE TRYING TO DECEIVE ME AS A
HITTER, IF I KEEP SEEING IN,
MAN, AT SOME POINT I FEEL LIKE I
WILL BE ON IT.
THAT'S WHY I SAY, IT SHOULD BE
INTERESTING TO SEE IF KELLER AND
STALLINGS DON'T TRY AND GO AWAY
AT SOME POINT.
BUT IT LOOKS LIKE THE APPROACH
RIGHT NOW IS ATTACK HIM INSIDE
HARD.
JERRY: EITHER AWAY OR IN OFF THE
PLATE.
SCOTT: GOT HIM TO POP IT UP.
TOM HAS IT.
AND THE INNING IS OVER.
DODGERS LEAVES THE BASES LOADED.
THEY DO HAVE ONE FROM THE BETTSO
THE PIRATES' HALF OF THE SECOND.
>> NOW FACING A GUY WHO HAS HAD
A LOT OF SUCCESS AGAINST HIM IN
JUSTIN TURNER.
THAT IS A HIGH FLY BALL, DEEP
CENTER FIELD.
REYNOLDS OUT OF ROOM.
IT'S GONE.
HOME RUN, JUSTIN TURNER.
CONTINUES TO MASTER TYLER
ANDERSON, HIS SECOND HOME RUN
AGAINST HIM, HIS 10TH OF THE
YEAR.
>> TWO ABOARD FOR PO LANKO.
-- POLANCO.
LIPED OFF THE GLOVE -- LINED OFF
THE GLOVE OF PUJOLS.
WHAT A SLIDE IF IT HOLDS UP FOR
REYNOLDS.
RIGHT TO THAT EDGE.
FEETFIRST.
AND SNUCK IN THERE.
>> JUSTIN TURNER, WHO HOMERED IN
THE FIRST INNING.
>> 2-1, TURNER.
FLIES ONE DOWN THE LINE TO LEFT.
TOM MOVES OVER TO THE CORNER.
HE LEAPS AND IT'S GONE.
TURNER GETS HIM AGAIN.
TURNER 2, THE PIRATES 1.
>> OFF TOM'S GLOVE AND INTO THE
SEATS.
>> TWO OUTS, THE TYING RUN, TOM
MOVES TO SECOND.
IT'S ALL UP TO KE'BRYAN HAYES.
>> GAME OVER!
AND THE DODGERS WIN IT 2-1.
SCOTT: THIS IS THE MLB GAME OF
THE WEEK LIVE ON YOUTUBE
PRESENTED BY JIM BEAM.
SCOTT BRAUN, JERRY HAIRSTON JR.,
SEAN CASEY AND J.P. MOROSI.
LOOK AT THE GIANTS, 38 UP, 23
DOWN.
THE GIANTS IN THE TWO SPOT, JUST
A TICK AHEAD OF THE SAN DIEGO
PADRES.
IT'S THE BIG THREE IN THE
DIVISION AND IT CUES UP OUR
FIRST POLL QUESTION OF THE DAY
ON YOUTUBE.
YOU CAN WEIGH IN ON YOUR
SMARTPHONE, TABLET, COMPUTER.
WHERE WILL THE DODGERS FINISH
THE REGULAR SEASON?
CHAMPS IN THE DIVISION, FIRST
N.L. WILD CARD, SECOND N.L. WILD
CARD OR MISS POSTSEASON.
A TEAM THAT HAS WON EIGHT
CONSECUTIVE CROWNS.
JERRY, YOU WATCH THIS TEAM ON A
DAILY BASIS.
I FEEL LIKE I KNOW WHAT YOUR
ANSWER IS GOING TO BE.
JERRY: THEY'RE GOING TO WIN THE
DIVISION.
THE GIANTS HAVE PLAYED WELL.
THE DODGERS HAVE PLAYED WELL.
BUT THOSE TWO TEAMS SHOULD HAVE
SEPARATED THEMSELVES FROM THE
DODGERS WHILE CODY BELLINGER WAS
HURT FOR TWO MONTHS, WHILE COREY
SEAGER IS STILL HURT.
THE DODGER TEAM HAS BEEN PLAGUED
BY INJURY AND YET THEY'RE STILL
IN THE MIX.
SO ONCE THEY GET HEALTHY, I
EXPECT THEM TO TAKE OFF IN THE
SECOND HALF.
SEAN: I AGREE JERRY THERE.
THIS DODGER TEAM, I REALLY
BELIEVE THEY'RE BUILT FOR THE
MARATHON OF 162 AND THEY'VE HAD
SOME INJURIES AND THEY'RE STILL
11 GAMES ABOVE .500.
I THINK AT SOME POINT THEY MAKE
A NICE RUN HERE.
SCOTT: NICE TWO STRIKE KNOCK FOR
EVANS.
IT'S NOT JUST THE REGULAR
SEASON.
IT'S WHAT THIS TEAM IS CAPABLE
OF IN THE POSTSEASON.
THEY WON THE WORLD SERIES LAST
YEAR.
THEY'RE ALSO MISSING A FEW
PLAYERS.
BELLINGER IS BACK, BUT HE MISSED
46 GAMES.
MCKINSTRY, RIOS IS OUT FOR THE
SEASON.
POLLOCK IS FRESH OFF THE I.L.
SEAGER IS STILL HURT.
LUX SPENT A LITTLE BIT OF TIME
OFF THE ROSTER AND BETTS HAS
MISSED EIGHT GAMES AS WELL.
TEDGELY MISSING SOME OF THOSE
DAYS -- TECHNICALLY MISSING SOME
OF THOSE DAYS WITHOUT A TRIP TO
THE INJURED LIST, BUT THERE IS
BELLINGER WHO HAS MISSED THE
MOST TIME SO FAR.
POINT BEING, NOT THE HEALTHIEST
SQUAD.
THAT'S OPPOSITE FIELD HITTING
FOR THE PIRATES.
IT'S ERIK GONZALEZ IN BUSINESS.
THE PIRATES ARE GOING TO SEND
HOME EVANS.
HERE HE COMES.
HE IS IN THERE.
WE ARE TIED AT 1-1 ON THE R.B.I.
DOUBLE FROM ERIK GONZALEZ.
SEAN: GONZALEZ GOT A PITCH
THERE, WAS ABLE TO LOOP IT TO
RIGHT FIELD.
EVANS DOES A GREAT JOB GETTING
ON HIS HORSE AND SCORING FROM
FIRST BASE.
IT LOOKED LIKE IT RATTLED IN THE
CORNER.
BETTS ALMOST GOT HIM AT THE
PLATE.
YOU'LL SEE RIGHT HERE, GONZALEZ
GETS A PITCH MIDDLE IN.
DOES A GREAT JOB GETTING ON TOP
OF IT SHOOTING IT TO RIGHT
FIELD.
JERRY: REALLY GOOD JOB STAYING
INSIDE THE BASEBALL AND REALLY
GOOD BASERUNNING, UNDERSTANDING
I AM NOT GOING TO TAKE ANYTHING
FOR GRANTED EVEN THOUGH MOOKIE
BETTS IS IN RIGHT.
I WILL HUSTLE TO SCORE.
SCOTT: TWO HITS TO START THE
INNING FOR THE PIRATES.
EVANS, OPPOSITE FIELD SINGLE.
GONZALEZ WITH THE DOUBLE TO TIE
UP THE GAME.
NOW IT'S KA'AI TOM.
JERRY: THE KEY HERE FOR URIAS IS
TO LIMIT THE DAMAGE.
SCOTT: ALAN SKIPS AWAY FROM
BARNES.
MOVING UP 90 FEET IS GONZALEZ.
JERRY: IT'S ONE OF THOSE THINGS
AUSTIN TAKES PRIDE IN, BLOCKING
THE BASEBALL IN THE DIRT.
THIS BALL GETS AWAY.
IT WILL BE RULED A WILD PITCH.
USUALLY AUSTIN BARNES KEEPS THAT
IN FRONT OF HIM.
SUCH A GREAT CATCHER BACK THERE.
JERRY: THOSE SECONDARY PITCHES
ARE IMPORTANT FOR JULIO.
THE CURVEBALL AND CHANGEUP HAVE
TO BE DOWN.
SCOTT: THERE IS ONE OF THOSE
SECONDARY PITCHES.
THE FASTBALL HAS BEEN HIT AT A
REALLY HEALTHY CLIP BY OPPOSING
BATTERS SO FAR THIS YEAR AGAINST
JULIO.
YOU CAN SEE THE NONFASTBALLS AT
JUST .127.
THAT'S THE CURVEBALL AND THE
CHANGEUP.
2-2, TO RIGHT.
BETTS IS GOING TO GRAB IT.
MADE IT LOOK EASY, BUT HERE
COMES GONZALEZ.
WHAT A THROW FROM BETTS AND IT'S
ON THE MONEY.
JERRY: ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
SCOTT: HE DOES IT SO CASUALLY.
JERRY: WHIRL AND TWIRL.
A ROCKET TO HOME.
FOR THE OUT.
ONE OF THE BEST RIGHT FIELDERS
I'VE EVER SEEN.
SEAN: THE ATHLETICISM FROM
MOOKIE BETTS IS UNBELIEVABLE.
I WAS THINKING ON THIS BALL
RIGHT HERE, I DON'T KNOW IF THEY
SHOULD SEND HIM BECAUSE BETTS
HAS AN ABSOLUTE CANNON, BUT THE
ATHLETICISM HERE TO COME IN AND
WATCH THIS SPIN.
HE COMES IN, ALMOST LIKE HE IS
AN INFIELDER, SPIN, THROW, RIGHT
ON THE MONEY.
I MEAN, UNBELIEVABLE PLAY.
SCOTT: INCREDIBLE CATCH AND THEN
THE TURNAROUND AND THROW A DART
TO HOME PLATE ON TIME.
INCREDIBLE PLAY.
WE ARE ON TO MITCH KELLER.
JERRY: THIS GUY IS ONE OF THE
BEST ATHLETES IN ALL OF SPORTS,
INCREDIBLE GOLFER, INCREDIBLE
BOWLER.
HE TRAINS AS A BASKETBALL PLAYER
IN THE OFF-SEASON TO MAKE SURE
HE HAS HIS AGILITY.
A COMPLETE ATHLETE.
SCOTT: HE'S GOT IT.
MAKE THAT KEVIN NEWMAN IN THE
EIGHT SPOT FIRST BEFORE KELLER.
FIRST OUTFIELD ASSIST OF THE
SEASON FOR MOOKIE BETTS OUT
THERE IN RIGHT.
HE JUST DID IT SO SMOOTHLY.
SEAN: NOBODY RUNS ON HIM.
SCOTT: EXACTLY.
JERRY: CASE, YOU KNOW THIS.
BASEBALL PLAYERS ARE THE BEST
ATHLETES.
THEY HAVE TO BE ABLE TO DO
EVERYTHING.
YOU HAVE TO THROW LIKE A
QUARTERBACK.
YOU HAVE TO RUN LIKE A WIDE
RECEIVER.
HIT 95 TO 98 AND MOOKIE BETTS IS
AS GOOD AS IT GETS.
SEAN: ESPECIALLY A GUY LIKE
MOOKIE BETTS, WE REALLY GOT TO
SEE HIS TALENTS ON DISPLAY WITH
THE CATCHES HE WAS MAKING, THE
THROWS AND HOW HE WAS SWINGING
THE BAT.
SCOTT: FIRST STRIKEOUT OF THE
DAY FOR URIAS.
BETTS STAR OF THE SECOND.
MAKES A NAME FOR HIMSELF EVERY
GAME IN A VARIETY OF WAYS.
>> LIFTED TO CENTER FIELD.
BACK GOES BELLINGER, ON THE
TRACK.
LEAPING AND MAKING THE GRAB AT
THE WALL.
BEAUTIFULLY DONE IN CENTER FIELD
BY CODY BELLINGER.
>> OUT OF THE YARD.
IT BRINGS RAIN AND A SOLO SHOT
TO SCORE HIM.
>> DRIVEN TO RIGHT CENTER FIELD.
ALREADY GOT ONE TONIGHT.
MAKE IT TWO.
GAVIN LUX A MULTIHOMER GAME.
THE DODGE -- DODGERS LEAD 7-4.
>> HITS THE BALL IN THE AIR,
BACK TO RIGHT.
THAT IS GONE.
THIS GAME IS TIED.
>> BELLINGER HITS ONE WAY UP
THERE.
WILLIAMS GOING BACK, AT THE
WALL, GOODBYE!
GRAND SLAM!
HE BUSTS IT WIDE OPEN.
AN 11-RUN FIRST INNING.
DRIVEN TO RIGHT CENTER FIELD.
EPIC STUFF, CHRIS TAYLOR!
LOADS THE BASES ON THE 14TH
PITCH.
SCOTT: IT'S THE MLB GAME OF THE
WEEK LIVE ON YOUTUBE.
ADDING TO THIS UNIQUE VIEWING
EXPERIENCE DON'T FORGET TO CHECK
OUT YOUTUBE'S LIVE GAME
COMMENTARY THAT FEATURES MLB AND
THE TEAM CHANNEL, PIRATES AND
DODGERS AND A SELECT GROUP OF
CREATORS.
YOU CAN VIEW IT ON YOUR MOBILE
DEVICE, COMPUTER OR TV.
WE ARE GOING TO TALK TO THE
BENCH COACH FOR THE PIRATES VERY
SOON.
WE WILL TAKE YOUR QUESTIONS FOR
THAT.
N.L. WEST A HECK OF A DIVISION
DURING THAT DISCUSSION.
SCOTT: WE HOP INTO THE THIRD.
IT'S TURNER, BELLINGER AND BEATY
DUE UP FOR THE DODGERS.
TURNER FOULS OFF THE FIRST
PITCH.
ALSO IN THAT LIVE CHAT, ASHLEY
SANDERS SAID WOW.
LEAVES THE DODGERS WITH A GOOSE
EGG DURING THE TOP OF THE
INNING, TALKING ABOUT KELLER,
AND THE PIRATES CAPITALIZING
DURING THE BOTTOM.
THEY SCORE A RUN TO ANSWER, BUT
IT COULD HAVE BEEN MUCH MORE.
MOOKIE BETTS MADE A STANDOUT
PLAY IN RIGHT FIELD.
THE CATCH AND THEN THE THROW,
LIKE HE HAD BEEN DOING IT FOR
YEARS, SO EASILY.
SOMEBODY WHO IS CALM, COLLECTED,
JERRY, AND MOOKIE IS ALSO SO
SURE OF HIS ABILITY THAT THERE
WAS JUST NO RUSH FACTOR.
HE KNEW HOW THE BASEBALL WOULD
GET THERE IN TIME.
JERRY: MANAGER DAVE ROBERTS
TALKS ABOUT IT ALL THE TIME THAT
HE WORKS ON HIS CRAFT EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
YOU SEE JUSTIN TURNER GET HIT.
NOT IN THE FACE, J.T.
ESPECIALLY IF YOU WANT A CAREER
ON TV AFTER BASEBALL.
BACK TO MOOKIE BETTS -- HE IS
ONE OF THE BEST ATHLETES BUT HE
DOESN'T TAKE ANYTHING FOR
GRANTED.
HE WORKS EXTREMELY HARD.
SCOTT: IS THAT HIS LEFT TRICEP?
SEAN: THIS HURTS.
THIS HURTS HERE.
THERE IS A LITTLE MEAT ON THE
BONE.
HE HAS THE ELBOW PAD.
YOU ARE LIKE AH, IT'S NOT BAD.
IT WILL BE A LITTLE TIGHT.
THAT'S WHY HE HAS THE SHIELD ON
THE ELBOW.
THAT'S WHERE YOU DON'T WANT TO
GET IT, WHERE THERE IS NO MEAT.
JERRY: HE WORKS EXTREMELY HARD
IN THE WEIGHT ROOM.
THAT'S WHERE YOU BUILD THOSE
TRICEPS UP, JUST IN CASE YOU GET
HIT BY A BASEBALL, IT DOESN'T
FAZE YOU.
SCOTT: IT'S DIPS, IT'S PREACHER
CURLS.
JERRY: THAT'S RIGHT.
TRICEP TUESDAYS.
IN L.A., YOU GOT THE BEACHES
HERE, PERFECT WEATHER.
GOT TO HAVE THAT BEACH BODY.
I KNOW HIS WIFE IS ON HIM ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT BODY STAYS
TIGHT.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: GREAT JOB, COURTNEY.
WE KNOW YOU ARE WATCHING.
J.T. LOOKS FINE.
HE LEADS OFF THE THIRD ON FIRST.
NOW BELLINGER HAS A 3-0 COUNT.
JERRY: CASEY, 3-0 COUNT IF YOU
ARE THE MANAGER DO YOU LET HIM
HIT HERE?
SEAN: HECK, YEAH.
I WOULD LET BELLINGER TAKE A RIP
KNOWING THAT KELLER, HE LOOKS A
LITTLE ALL OVER THE PLACE.
BELLINGER CAN MAKE THIS 3-1.
SCOTT: HE DOES TAKE A HEALTHY
HACK.
HIS MANAGER ALSO PREDICTED A
HOME RUN FOR HIM, SO I AM SURE
HE IS GIVING HIM THE GREEN LIGHT
TODAY EVEN MORE SO.
SEAN: THAT'S RIGHT.
TAKE SOME RIPS, 3-1, WHENEVER
YOU WANT.
JERRY: WE TALK ABOUT DODGER NICK
NAMINGS.
J.T. CALLS HIM BOPPER BECAUSE OF
HIS POWER.
SCOTT: VERY HIP.
ANOTHER BIG SWING FROM
BELLINGER.
HE ACTUALLY HAS FOUR CAREER
HOMERS ON 3-0 COUNTS.
I KNOW FOR SOME GUYS THEY ALWAYS
AVOID.
BELLINGER, THOUGH, CAN BE
AGGRESSIVE.
HIS BEST SEASON AT THE PLATE IN
2019.
HIS FIRST HALF THAT YEAR WAS OUT
OF CONTROL.
HE REALLY GOT HIS STRIKEOUT TO
WALK RATIO IN CHECK THAT YEAR AS
WELL.
2017 ROOKIE OF THE YEAR.
PAYOFF PITCH, WE WILL DO
ANOTHER.
SEAN: DOC WAS SAYING BEFORE THE
GAME, HE WAS TALKING ABOUT
BELLINGER.
WE WERE SAYING WHAT DOES HE NEED
TO BE BETTER AT AND DOC WAS
SAYING HEY, HE NEEDS TO GET ON
THE HEATER.
WE WANT TO GET HIM BACK ON THE
HEATER.
YOU SAW HIM SWING THROUGH THE
FASTBALLS.
HE GETS THE PITCH DOWN THE
MIDDLE AND FOULS IT OFF.
I THINK KELLER WILL KEEP
ATTACKING HIM WITH THAT HEATER.
SCOTT: HE DOES.
HE PUNISHES IT TO RIGHT FIELD.
IT WILL DROP AND TURNER IS
CHUCKING FOR THIRD.
HE WILL MAKE IT THERE.
SO RUNNERS ON THE CORNERS TO
START THE INNING ON THE BASE HIT
FOR BELLINGER.
STATCAST POWERED BY GOOGLE
CLOUD.
CODY BELLINGER ONLY HAS ONE HOME
RUN SO FAR THIS SEASON BUT WE
HAVE SEEN DAMAGE TO DIFFERENT
PARTS OF THE BALLPARK FROM CODY
OVER THE PAST FEW SEASONS,
JERRY.
JERRY: HE HAS BEEN OUTSTANDING
SWINGING THE BAT.
THE BIGGEST THING FOR HIM IS
JUST GETTING BACK HIS SWING AS
FAR AS BEING ON TIME.
HE HAS MISSED TWO MONTHS OF THE
SEASON, SO ONCE WE START SEEING
CODY BELLINGER BE MORE RELAXED
AT THE PLATE, GOING THE OTHER
WAY WITH TWO STRIKES, LOOKING
FOR CONTACT LIKE HE DID THERE,
THEN THE POWER WILL COME.
SCOTT: HE HAS THAT WHIPPAGE
THROUGH THE ZONE, TOO, CODY,
WHERE IT'S WAITING AND ALL OF A
SUDDEN, YOU BLINK ADD THE BAT
CAME ACROSS.
JERRY: HE HAS INCREDIBLE HANDS,
BAT SPEED.
SEAN: A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T TALK
ABOUT IT.
HE IS AN INCREDIBLE ATHLETE.
HE CAN FLY.
GREAT RUNNER GOING FIRST TO
THIRD, SCORING FROM FIRST ON A
DOUBLE.
REALLY GOOD BASEBALL INSTINCTS.
YOU HAVE MATT BEATY UP FIRST AND
THIRD, NOBODY OUT.
YOU ARE LOOKING FOR CONTACT
HERE.
TRYING TO PUSH A RUN ACROSS.
SCOTT: BEATY FLEW OUT TO LEFT IN
THE FIRST.
AND THAT PITCH HIT HIM.
SO IT WILL LOAD UP THE BASES.
SEAN: THIS IS WHERE KELLER GETS
INTO TROUBLE.
HE STARTS LOSING COMMAND.
HE HIT TURNER TO START THE
INNING.
HE CAME AT BELLINGER AND LEFT
THE 3-2 BREAKING BALL DOWN THE
MIDDLE.
I DON'T KNOW WHY HE DIDN'T
CONTINUE WITH THE FASTBALL.
HE HITS BEATY TO LOAD THE BASES.
DEFINITELY LOSING A LITTLE BIT
OF COMMAND.
SCOTT: HE HIT THREE BATTERS IN
HIS CAREER AND TWO ALREADY IN
THIS INNING, JERRY.
JERRY: YEAH, AGAIN, COMMAND HAS
BEEN AN ISSUE FOR HIM.
IN THE MINOR LEAGUES, HE HAS HAD
EXCELLENT COMMAND FOR IT HASN'T
TRANSLATED TO THE BIG LEAGUES.
SCOTT: NOW IT'S MCKINSTRY, JUICY
OPPORTUNITY WITH THE BAGS FULL
OF DODGERS.
JERRY: IF I AM MCKINSTRY I AM
HUNTING THE FIRST PITCH
FASTBALL.
NOT GREAT COMMAND.
I AM HUNTING THE HEATER HERE.
SCOTT: THERE IS THE FASTBALL.
THE UMPIRE BEHIND THE PLATE SAID
IT MISSED.
IT LOOKED CLOSE.
JERRY: ZACH MCKINSTRY WENT TO
CENTRAL MICHIGAN, DID NOT HIT A
HOME IN COLLEGE.
HIS FIRST BIG LEAGUE HOMER,
INSIDE-THE-PARK HOME RUN.
SCOTT: 33RD ROUND SELECTION OF
THAT EPIC 2016 DRAFT CLASS BY
THE DODGERS.
SO MANY HITS SUCCESSFUL IN THAT
DRAFT FOR L.A.
MCKINSTRY, ONE OF THE LATEST
ONES, PICKED NUMBER 1,001.
THERE IS THE SAC FLY LINE.
THAT'S THE DEPTH YOU NEED TO
TAKE THE BASEBALL BASED ON
THROWING ARMS OUT THERE FROM
TOM, REYNOLDS AND EVANS.
JERRY: THE ARM STRENGTH THERE, I
LIKE THAT.
84, 86, 85.
CASE, WHAT WAS YOUR ARM STRENGTH
AT?
97?
SEAN: LIKE 66, 67.
[LAUGHTER]
I TOOK MY KIDS RECENTLY TO THE
PARK OUT HERE, AN AMUSEMENT PARK
IN PITTSBURGH.
I GOT THREE BALLS, LINED IT UP,
TOLD MY SON HERE WE GO.
67 I HIT.
SCOTT: PAST THE GREEN LINE FOR
MCKINSTRY.
THAT ENABLES TURNER TO SCORE
EASILY.
THE SAC FLY PUTS THE DODGERS
BACK IN FRONT.
IT'S 2-1 OFF THE R.B.I.
JERRY: EXECUTION IS SO
IMPORTANT.
SAC FLY RIGHT THERE, AT LEAST
GET ONE RUN WITH THE BASES
LOADED.
STILL THREATENING FIRST AND
SECOND.
ONE OUT.
IT'S ONE OF MY FAVORITE
BALLPARKS IN ALL OF BASEBALL.
A BEAUTIFUL PARK, ESPECIALLY IN
A DAY GAME.
SEAN: IT IS BEAUTIFUL.
I LIVE HERE AND GET A CHANCE TO
SEE THIS PARK A LOT.
IT'S ONE OF THE MOST SPECIAL
PARKS IN THE BIG LEAGUES WITH
THE THREE RIVERS COMING AND THE
BRIDGE IN THE BACKGROUND.
JERRY: IF YOU'VE NEVER BEEN TO
THAT BALLPARK, IF YOU ARE A FAN,
IF YOU LOVE BASEBALL MAKE IT A
POINT TO VISIT THAT STADIUM.
SCOTT: TWO BALLS, NO STRIKES TO
GAVIN LUX.
SEAN, I AM JEALOUS.
YOU ARE THERE.
YOU ARE THE -- YOU AND J.P. HALF
THE TEAM AT THE PARK TODAY CAN
SEE THE BRIDGE IN THE
BACKGROUND.
IT IS PICTURESQUE.
SEAN: IT IS A GORGEOUS DAY HERE,
GUYS.
YOU SHOULD BE JEALOUS.
JERRY: GAVIN LUX IS FROM
WISCONSIN.
YOU SEE ACTION IN THE BULLPEN
THERE FOR PITTSBURGH.
GAVIN LUX ONE OF THOSE RARE
KIDS, GREW UP IN WISCONSIN BUT
IS A BEARS FAN.
I AM A KID FROM CHICAGO, SO YOU
KNOW I LOVE THAT.
SCOTT: THREE BALLS AND A STRIKE.
HOW DOES THAT HAPPEN?
JERRY: WELL, HE'S SMART.
HE DOESN'T LISTEN AND DOESN'T
ADHERE TO THE PRESSURES OF THE
WISCONSIN AND THEIR CHEESES.
HE SAID, I AM GOING TO FOLLOW A
TEAM THAT I LOVE TO WATCH.
IT'S THE CHICAGO BEARS.
GOOD FOR HIM.
SCOTT: HE TAKES THE 3-1.
SEAN: INTERESTING RIGHT HERE TO
WATCH KELLER REALLY LOSING
FASTBALL COMMAND.
THE ONE PITCH HE HAS COMMAND
RIGHT NOW SEEMS LIKE THE LITTLE
BREAKING BALL HE HAS THROWN FOR
STRIKES.
IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE
WHAT HE DOES 3-2 HERE.
SCOTT: LET'S SEE IF HE DOUBLES
UP.
TWO ON FOR L.A.
ONE RUN IN THIS INNING.
THAT'S ON THE GROUND.
NICE BACKHANDED STOP BY
GONZALEZ.
HE GOES TO SECOND FOR THE FORCE,
AND THE FIELDER'S CHOICE PUTS
RUNNERS ON THE CORNERS.
KELLER GETS THE PITCH HE NEEDS.
TOUGH TO TURN TWO ON THAT ONE,
THOUGH.
JERRY: CASE, YOU WERE RIGHT.
3-1 BREAKING BALL, THREW A 3-2
BREAKING BALL, GOT THE GROUND
BALL.
SEAN: HITTING IS NOT JUST BAT TO
BALL SKILLS.
YOU GOT TO THINK AWLONG THE
PITCHER.
JERRY: YOU ARE ONE OF THE BEST
AT DOING THAT.
SEAN: I APPRECIATE THAT.
I AGREE WITH WHAT WE WERE
SAYING.
AS YOU CAN SEE WHEN YOU START
ELIMINATING PITCHES AS A HITTER
AND I SEE THAT KELLER IS NOT
THROWING HIS HEATER, THE ONLY
ONE HE LOOKS COMFORTABLE WITH IS
THE BREAKING BALL.
THREW IT 3-1 AND THREW IT AGAIN
3-2.
SCOTT: THEY'RE GOING TO LET HIM
PITCH TO BARNES.
YOU HAVE SECOND BASE OPEN AND
URIAS ON DECK.
IS THAT THE MOVE, JERRY?
JERRY: I THINK THEY'RE SEEING IF
HE CAN GET AUSTIN BARNES TO
CHASE.
YOU SAW THE FIRST PITCH BREAKING
BALL.
THEY MAY ELECT TO PUT HIM ON.
THEY'RE GOING TO SEE IF AUSTIN
BARNES CAN GET HIMSELF OUT.
SCOTT: THAT'S SHELTON'S SECOND
SEASON MANAGING THE PIRATES.
HE WAS THE TWINS' BINCH COACH IN
2018 AND 2019.
BARNES WALKED, FIRST TRIP TO THE
PLATE.
JERRY: THERE IS THAT BREAKING
BALL TRYING TO GET BARNES TO
CHASE.
AUSTIN BARNES AIN'T BITING.
SCOTT: YOU PUT A LOT OF PRESSURE
ON JACOB STALLINGS TO GRAB THOSE
DIRT BALLS SO THAT BELLINGER
DOESN'T SCURRY HOME.
SEAN: AT THIS POINT YOU MIGHT AS
WELL PUT HIM ON.
THEY'RE NOT PITCHING TO BARNES
HERE, NO WAY.
TRYING TO GET HIM TO CHASE, LIKE
YOU SAID, JERRY.
SCOTT: SO WHY RISK IT?
LET HIM GO TO FIRST.
THE FREE PASS OFFICIALLY ISSUED.
INTENTIONAL WALK.
IT WILL BE URIAS.
JERRY: EVEN THOUGH HE WENT TO
A.S.U., HE IS VERY INTELLIGENT,
HE KNEW WHAT WAS GOING ON.
HE SAID I AM NOT GOING TO CHASE
A PITCH.
SCOTT: HELPED THAT ON-BASE
PERCENTAGE.
LIKE YOU MENTIONED EARLIER,
URIAS CAN MAKE LOUD CONTACT AT
TIMES.
THE DODGERS HAVE SOME PRETTY
GOOD HITTING PITCHERS.
JERRY: THEY WORK ON IT QUITE A
BIT AT HOME.
THEY CHALLENGE EACH OTHER,
GETTING BUNTS DOWN BUT ALSO WHEN
YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY PUT THE
BAT ON THE BALL.
SCOTT: HE GOES AFTER THE FIRST
PITCH.
IT'S FOULED OFF.
I KNOW THERE IS A SOLID
COMPETITION THAT GOES ON.
I SAW BUEHLER CHATTING WITH
KERSHAW THE OTHER DAY, TALKING
ABOUT THEIR HITTING APPROACH.
WHEN YOU ARE SO GOOD ON THE
MOUND, YOU HAVE TO THINK ABOUT
OTHER THINGS TO BE COMPETITIVE
WITH.
JERRY: THEY DO CHALLENGE EACH
OTHER.
WHO WILL GET THE MOST HITS THIS
SEASON?
HE PROM IED ME HE WOULD GO DEEP
THIS YEAR.
SEAN: I TELL YOU WHAT, GUYS,
THIS IS A BIG VICTORY FOR KELLER
RIGHT HERE IF HE -- HE HAS HAD
SO MUCH TRAFFIC.
HE HAD BASES LOADED IN THE
SECOND, REALLY GOT OUT OF IT.
HE HAS OGE GIVEN UP ONE RUN
HERE.
IF HE CAN GET OUT OF THIS WITH
ONLY ONE RUN, THAT'S A WIN.
JERRY: THAT'S VERY TRUE.
HE HAS BEEN DANCING AROUND HERE,
A LOT OF TRAFFIC.
IF HE CAN LIMIT THE DAMAGE HERE,
YOU GOT TO FEEL GOOD ABOUT YOUR
CHANCES IF YOU ARE THE
PITTSBURGH PIRATES.
JULIO URIAS, FIVE R.B.I.'S THIS
SEASON.
YOU KNOW HE CAN SWING THE BAT.
SCOTT: SECOND MOST BY A PITCHER.
YNOA HAD A GRAND SLAM THIS YEAR
TO CONTRIBUTE TO SOME OF THOSE
RIBBIES.
FOR KELLER, WE SAW HIS 70TH TOSS
OF THE DAY.
WE ARE HERE IN THE THIRD.
THAT SOLID PIRATES BULLPEN
BETTER GET READY FOR SOME LONG
WORK THIS AFTERNOON.
JERRY: ESPECIALLY WITH THE QUICK
TURNAROUND.
SHELTON HAS DONE AN EXCELLENT
JOB.
BUT YOU ARE HOPING TO GET KELLER
AT LEAST TO FIVE TO KIND OF HELP
OUT HIS BULLPEN.
RIGHT NOW THAT PITCH COUNT IS
CLIMBING.
SCOTT: 2-2 SENT TO RIGHT AND
URIAS CONNECTS.
BELLINGER COMES HOME.
THAT WILL SCORE TWO FOR THE
DODGERS.
MAKE IT SEVEN R.B.I.'S ON THE
SEASON FOR THE DODGERS' STARTER.
IT'S 4-1.
JERRY: JULIO, THE PRIDE OF
MEXICO, GETS A BREAKING BALL UP
IN THE ZONE.
HIS IDOL GROWING UP WAS BIG
PAPI, DAVID ORTIZ.
HE GOT A BREAKING BALL, CENTER
CUT.
HE DOES NOT MISS IT.
GREAT SWING, HEAD DOWN ON
CONTACT, THROUGH THE BASEBALL.
TWO HUGE TWO-OUT R.B.I.'S.
SEAN: THE BIG PROBLEM HERE,
GUYS, KELLER COULDN'T THROW HIS
FASTBALL FOR STRIKES.
HAD TO GO TO THE BREAKING BALL
AGAIN.
GOES INTO THE -- WITH THE
PITCHER SPEEDS UP HIS BAT SPEED.
WITH KELLER NOT HAVING THAT
FASTBALL COMMAND, THAT REALLY
HURT HIM TODAY.
SCOTT: URIAS KNOCKS OUT THE
OPPOSING STARTER, MITCH KELLER
DODGERS 4, PIRATES 1.
NEW PITCHER COMING IN, IN THIS
THIRD INNING.
>> IT'S THE NEW YORK YANKEES 9
AND THE PITTSBURGH PIRATES 9.
>> I WAS JUST SITTING THERE
THINKING ABOUT HOW IN THE WORLD
ARE WE GOING TO BEAT THESE GUYS?
SOMEBODY YELLED YOU'RE UP.
I FORGOT I WAS UP.
>> SUDDEN DEATH NOW.
LAST OF THE NINTH.
9-9.
>> ONLY THING I COULD THINK
ABOUT WAS I GOT TO HIT THE BALL
HARD SOMEWHERE.
GET ON BASE AND GET THIS THING
STARTED.
I HAD NO VISIONS OF HISTORYING A
HOME RUN.
>> DRIVE INTO DEEP LEFT FIELD.
>> WHEN I HIT IT, I DIDN'T KNOW
FOR SURE IF IT WAS GOING OUT.
I WAS RUNNING MY BUTT OFF,
BUSTING MY TAIL TRYING TO GET TO
THIRD BASE.
I HEARD A NOISE.
PEOPLE YELLING.
I LOOK DOWN THE LEFT-FIELD LINE.
>> THAT BALL IS GOING, GOING,
GONE!
>> I HIT SECOND AND I DON'T
THINK I TOUCHED THE GROUND THE
REST OF THE WAY HOME.
I FLOATED HOME.
>> A HOME RUN.
THE PIRATES WIN IT AND WIN THE
WORLD SERIES.
SCOTT: AS CHRIS STRATTON WARMS
UP, WE DO HAVE SOME
PRECIPITATION IN PITTSBURGH
WHICH MAKES YOU WONDER DID AN
INABILITY TO GRIP THE BALL ON
THE LAST AT-BAT AGAINST JULIO
URIAS PERHAPS AFFECT MITCH
KELLER IN THOSE KEY PITCHES
WHERE CERTAINLY YOU WOULD SAY
THE DRIZZLE HAS INTENSIFIED.
WE WILL KEEP A CLOSE EYE ON THE
HOME PLATE UMPIRE AND THE
PIRATES GROUNDS CREW AS WELL.
SCOTT: THANKS, J.P.
STAY DRY FOR US, PLEASE.
BOTH GAMES BEFORE THIS IN THE
SERIES WERE DELAYED BY RAIN
YESTERDAY, 70 MINUTES BEFORE
FIRST PITCH COULD START UP.
THEY ENDED UP COMPLETING THE
GAME CLOSE TO MIDNIGHT, ABOUT 12
HOURS LATER WE ARE BACK ON THE
FIELD.
THERE IS MORE PRECIPITATION.
THERE IS A NEW PITCH NER THE
GAME.
IN THE THIRD INNING TAKING OVER
FOR MITCH KELLER, WHO LASTED
JUST 2 1/3.
IT'S CHRIS STRATTON TAKING OVER.
FORMER STARTER.
HE CAN GIVE THIS TEAM LENGTH.
ALREADY THREE RUNS ACROSS FOR
THE DODGERS IN THE THIRD.
FOUR TOTAL.
THE FIRST CAME IN THE FIRST
INNING FROM MOOKIE BETTS, A HOME
RUN ON PITCH NUMBER THREE OF THE
DAY.
HIS SIXTH OF THE SEASON.
A THREE-RUN GAME WITH THE RAIN
COMING DOWN A LITTLE BIT HARDER
NOW IN THE BURG.
JERRY: STRATTON QUICKLY AHEAD
0-2 ON MOOKIE BETTS.
MOOKIE TWO REALLY GOOD AT-BATS
THIS GAME, THE LEADOFF HOMER AND
THE WALK.
SCOTT: THIRD INNING, THIRD
AT-BAT FOR BETTS.
HE LAYS OFF THAT PITCH UP.
STRATTON LAST PITCHED ON
TUESDAY, GAVE UP TWO RUNS IN TWO
INNINGS.
FOUR-SEAM FASTBALL, CURVEBALL,
SLIDER, AND SOME CHANGEUPS IN
THE REPERTOIRE.
SEAN: FIRST TWO PITCHES HE THREW
--
JERRY: ELEVATE THAT FASTBALL.
SEAN: FIRST TWO PITCHES HE KINDS
OF CAME WITH THE OFF-SPEED, TRY
TO GET HIM TO CHASE.
THEN HE COMES WITH TWO HEATERS,
TRYING TO PUT HIM AWAY.
BUT MOOKIE IS NOT BITING ON
THAT.
SCOTT: HE WENT AROUND.
STRATTON STRUCK HIM OUT.
SO HE COMES IN, PICKS UP THE ONE
RUNNER BUT THE DODGERS ATTACK
WITH THREE.
THEY KNOCK OUT THE STARTER.
DODGERS UP 4-1.
>> ANOTHER ONE OF THOSE DELAYED
STEALS.
HE GOT THE TAG ON HIM.
HE IS OUT.
TOUGH PLAY.
>> WOW.
>> SWITCH HITTER BATTING LEFT.
>> BLASTED TO RIGHT.
DEEP TOWARD THE WALL.
GONE!
HOME RUN FOR BRYAN REYNOLDS.
REYNOLDS' EIGHTH HOME RUN OF THE
YEAR TIES THE GAME AT 1-1.
>> HARD TO CENTER FIELD.
MARTE BACK TO THE TRACK, TO THE
WALL.
CLEAR THE DECK WITH A
CANNONBALL!
THE KE'BRYAN HAYES, YOU GOT TO
BE KIDDING ME.
>> LOADED FOR STALLINGS.
LINE DRIVE TO LEFT FIELD.
JACOB STALLINGS, JUST DOUBLED IN
ONE, TWO AND THREE RUNS!
HOW ABOUT THAT?
>> FLY BALL, CENTER FIELD.
THAT WILL DO IT.
WALK IT OFF, CHEETAH, YOU ARE
HUNGRY, GO EAT.
WHAT A GRIND IT OUT WIN IN 12
FOR THE BATTLING BUCS.
>> THE PIRATES WIN THE FIRST OF
THE SERIES AGAINST THE MARLINS.
SCOTT: LAST OF THE THIRD IN
PITTSBURGH, DODGERS UP 4-1.
OUR FIRST POLL QUESTION OF THE
DAY ON YOUTUBE IS COMPLETE.
WE ARE LOOKING FOR WHERE THE
DODGERS ARE GOING TO FINISH UP
THE REGULAR SEASON IN THE
DIVISION.
DODGERS FANS WATCHING AND
THEY'RE WEIGHING IN BIG, JERRY.
64% SAY THEY'RE WINNING THE WEST
AGAIN FOR A NINTH CONSECUTIVE
YEAR.
JERRY: A LOT OF DODGER FANS ARE
WATCHING, BUT THE POLL THERE, 6%
MISS THE POSTSEASON, I WILL BET
THOSE ARE GIANTS FANS.
[LAUGHTER]
SEAN: YOU ARE PROBABLY RIGHT.
GIANTS FANS POLLED IN AND THEY
SAID NO, THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
MAKE IT.
ONLY 6% OF THEM.
SCOTT: YOU CAN DO SOME GOOD
TROLLING HERE WITH THESE POLL
QUESTIONS.
ANYONE THAT'S NOT A FAN OF THE
DODGERS' DOMINANCE OVER THE PAST
DECADE.
WE HAVE SEEN THEM TODAY IN A BIG
WAY, HOME RUN FROM BETTS,
PATIENT THIRD INNING TO WORK
THROUGH MITCH KELLER'S
INEFFECTIVENESS WITH HIS COMMAND
AND KNOCKING HIM OUT OF THE
GAME.
BETTS ALSO MADE AN ELITE PLAY IN
RIGHT FIELD, A CATCH, PREVENTING
THE SAC FLY FROM GOING DOWN
EARLIER AND THAT'S WHY THE
PIRATES JUST HAVE ONE SO FAR
THIS AFTERNOON.
PHILLIP EVANS SCORED ON A DOUBLE
FROM ERIK GONZALEZ.
NOW WE ARE IN THE THIRD, BACK TO
JULIO URIAS AFTER A LONG LAYOFF
BETWEEN INNINGS.
MLB ORIGINAL SEASON 2 IS LIVE ON
YOUTUBE WITH NEW EPISODES EVERY
WEEK.
LEARN MORE ABOUT THE GAME YOU
LOVE ON YOUTUBE.COM/MLB.
CHRIS STRATTON JUST TOOK OVER
FOR ONE OUT IN THE LAST HALF
INNING AND NOW HE WILL BE AT THE
PLATE.
HE ONLY TOOK OVER AS A RELIEF
PITCHER FULL-TIME LAST YEAR.
BEFORE THAT, HE HAD BEEN A
STARTER.
SO THERE ARE 63 CAREER AT-BATS
TO HIS NAME.
SEAN: IF YOU ARE THE PITCHER,
YOU ARE LOOKING FOR THE SHUTDOWN
INNING.
YOU JUST FINISHED SCORING SOME
RUNS.
YOU GOT A HUGE HIT.
YOU GOT TO THROW STRIKES AND GET
YOUR TEAM BACK IN THE DUGOUT.
SCOTT: IT'S SOMETHING URIAS HAS
DONE VERY WELL SO FAR THIS
SEASON COMPARED TO THE BEGINNING
OF HIS CAREER.
IN HIS FIRST 38 STARTS IN THE
BIG LEAGUES, THROUGH 2020, HE
AVERAGED 4 2/3 INNINGS PER
START.
THIS YEAR HE IS A BIT OVER SIX
INNINGS PER OUTING.
AND HE'S GOT HIM.
SEAN: YOU CAN'T TEACH EXPERIENCE
ON THAT, AS FAR AS GOING OUT
THERE AND LEARNING HOW TO FILL
UP THE STRIKE ZONE, PITCH IN THE
BIG LEAGUES.
YOU CAN TELL URIAS, ESPECIALLY
THIS YEAR, IS REALLY FILLING UP
THE STRIKE ZONE, MAXIMIZING HIS
PITCH COUNT AND GOING LATER INTO
GAMES.
SCOTT: SECOND STRIKEOUT TODAY
FOR URIAS.
NOW TOP OF THE ORDER.
ADAM FRAZIER, MOST HITS IN
BASEBALL AND HE WILL BAT WITH
HAYES ON DECK.
FRAZIER IS MIC'D UP TODAY.
SO SOME GOOD SOUND COMING SOON
FROM ADAM.
ON-BASE PERCENTAGE AT .390 SO
FAR THIS SEASON.
POTENTIALLY COULD BE A TRADE
CANDIDATE ABOUT A MONTH FROM NOW
WHEN WE GET CLOSE TO THE JULY 31
DEADLINE.
WE WILL TALK TO J.P. ABOUT THAT
SOON.
HE POPPED OUT TO FIRST BASE
FIRST TIME UP.
THIS TIME SCORCHES ONE DOWN THE
LINE.
THIS IS WHAT ADAM FRAZIER DOES
BEST.
HE WILL HUSTLE TO SECOND WITH A
ONE-OUT DOUBLE.
ALL RIGHT, ADAM.
WE SAW WHAT YOU CAN DO WITH THE
BAT.
WHAT ABOUT WITH THE MOUTH?
>> LET'S GO.
LET'S GO.
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
GOOD, YOU?
HAVE A GOOD ONE.
THE CHANGEUP HE THREW.
WOULD HAVE HIT ME IN THE MOUTH.
SCOTT: IT FEELS LIKE, CASE, THE
KIND OF GUY WHO IS TALKING
BASEBALL 24/7.
IT'S ONE OF THOSE HOW ARE YOU,
HOW IS THE FAMILY?
YESTERDAY DID YOU SEE THAT PLAY
IN RIGHT?
WE SEE HIS 22ND DOUBLE OF THE
SEASON, BEST IN BASEBALL.
SEAN: THIS GUY IS A BASEBALL
RAT.
HE LOVES IT SEVEN DAYS A WEEK.
YOU CAN TELL BY THE WAY HE PLAYS
THE GAME, HOW HARD HE PLAYS THE
GAME, HOW HE GETS AFTER THE BAT,
HOW HE PLAYS IN THE FIELD.
YOU SAW HIM BEFORE THE GAME
SAYING LET'S GO.
I LOVE -- THIS PITCH RIGHT HERE.
LOOK HOW SHORT AND QUICK IT IS.
LEFTY ON LEFTY, DOES A GREAT JOB
BEING SHORT AND QUICK, GETS THE
BARREL ON THE BALL, SHOOTS IT
DOWN THE RIGHT-FIELD LINE.
JERRY: SCOTTY, YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT POSSIBLE TRADE OPTIONS FOR
FRAZIER.
HE IS A GUY THAT COULD BE A
CANDIDATE FOR THE YANKEES, THAT
HAVE STRUGGLED WITH PUTTING THE
BAT ON THE BALL.
HE IS A LEFT-HANDED HITTER.
REALLY GOOD OVERALL BALL PLAYER,
SCRAPPY.
ANY TEAM WOULD BE LUCKY TO HAVE
HIM.
SCOTT: KE'BRYAN HAYES ON THE
1-2.
IT'S BACK TO URIAS.
THEY'VE GOT FRAZIER CAUGHT.
HAYES RACING AROUND, TAG
APPLIED.
THAT'S MCKINSTRY RECORDING OUT
NUMBER TWO.
HAYES HEADS TO FIRST.
JERRY: SOMETIMES I JOKE ABOUT
PITCHERS BEING KICKERS, BUT
JULIO URIAS INCREDIBLE ATHLETE.
HOW ABOUT THE GLOVE RIGHT THERE?
EASY SNAG RIGHT THERE.
GIVING IT TO ZACH WHO APPLIES
THE TAG.
SCOTT: NICELY EXECUTED.
SO NOW REYNOLDS STEPS UP WITH
HAYES ON FIRST.
WE ARE ABOUT TO SEE PITCH NUMBER
40 FROM JULIO THIS AFTERNOON.
SEAN: SEEING MORE AND MORE
CHANGEUPS, BREAKING BALLS FIRST
PITCH ATTACKING THESE PIRATES
HITTERS.
TRYING TO GET IT OVER THE PLATE.
SCOTT: DAVE ROBERTS TOLD US THE
DODGERS WOULD LOVE TO SEE EVEN
MORE OF THAT CURVEBALL AND
CHANGEUP FROM URIAS.
THERE IS THE SLURVE.
SEAN: THAT'S ALMOST UNHITTABLE.
IT'S A BACK DOOR CURVEBALL
THAT'S OFF THE PLATE AND THEN
IT'S CATCHING THE CORNER.
IF HE CAN THROW THAT THERE, KEEP
THROWING IT THERE, THAT'S A
TOUGH PITCH FOR THE PIRATE
HITTERS TO HIT.
JERRY: THE FASTBALL AFTER THAT
BREAKING BALL BECAUSE YOU HAVE
TO PROTECT AFTER THE BREAKING
BALL.
NOW YOU ARE JUST 1-0, YOU ARE
DOWN IN THE COUNT 1-2.
SCOTT: HE ESTABLISHES THAT
THREAT OF HIGH VELOCITY.
HE HAS TWO EXCELLENT SECONDARY
WEAPONS ON THE 1-2.
GOES WITH THE CURVE.
REYNOLDS HAMMERS IT, DEEP LEFT.
BEATY GIVES IT A LOOK, AND IT'S
GONE!
BRYAN REYNOLDS FOR TWO.
NUMBER 10 ON THE SEASON.
AND THE PIRATES MAKE THIS A
ONE-RUN GAME.
SEAN: THE POWER STROKE HAS BEEN
THERE THE LAST FEW WEEKS, GUYS.
HE HAS BEEN DRIVING IN A LOT OF
RUNS.
HE GETS A PITCH RIGHT HERE FROM
URIAS JUST OVER THE PLATE,
REALLY A HANGING BREAKING BALL.
REYNOLDS DOES A GREAT JOB
STAYING ON IT AND DRIVING
THROUGH IT AND GETTING IT OUT OF
THE PARK.
YOU'LL SEE RIGHT HERE, WATCH
THIS HANGER.
IT COMES RIGHT INTO THE NITRO
ZONE.
HIS EYES LIGHT UP.
HE WAITS ON IT, DROPS THE HEAD
ON IT.
SCOTT: NOW STALLINGS POPPED THAT
ONE UP.
AND BETTS WILL JOG IN AND KEEP
GOING TO THE DUGOUT.
TWO FOR THE
BACK.
BRYAN REYNOLDS THINKING BIG.
IT'S 4-3, DODGERS THROUGH THREE.
>> IT WAS ALWAYS HONEST AND IF
HE HURT YOUR FEELINGS IN THE
PROCESS OF TELLING YOU SOMETHING
HONEST, HE DIDN'T CARE BECAUSE
HE THOUGHT IT WAS IN YOUR BEST
INTEREST.
>> HE HAD VERY LITTLE TOLERANCE
FOR NOT PLAYING HARD.
>> HE MIGHT NOT BE ABLE TO GET
IT.
BUST YOUR ASS BACK THERE.
>> HE IS LIKE GET YOURSELF READY
TO PLAY.
IF YOU ARE NOT, I WILL FIND
SOMEONE WHO WILL.
THAT WAS A STRICT MESSAGE.
>> HE IS OLD SCHOOL.
OLD SCHOOL MEANS YOU DO THINGS
THE RIGHT WAY.
>> JIM LEYLAND IS I THINK THE
MOST KNOWLEDGEABLE BASEBALL MAN
THAT I KNOW STILL LIVING.
JIM WAS NOT JUST SMART BUT HE
WAS GUTSY.
HE WAS GOING TO TAKE THE BEST
SHOT TO WIN, DID NOT CARE ABOUT
BEING SECOND BEST.
>> I DID MY JOB AND I CAN LOOK
IN THE MIRROR.
>> JIM NEVER TAKES CREDIT FOR
WINNING, ALWAYS TAKES THE BLAME
FOR A LOSS.
AS A PLAYER YOU APPRECIATE THAT.
>> THE GAME BELONGS TO YOUR
PLAYERS.
THEY'RE THE ONES WHO WON IT.
I DIDN'T HAVE A LOT TO DO WITH
IT.
>> I THINK HE IS ONE OF THE MOST
AMAZING LEADERS IN ANY SPORT OF
OUR TIME.
SCOTT: PIRATES TRAIL BY A RUN.
BENCH COACH DON KELLY PLAYED
NINE SEASONS IN THE BIGS.
YOU CAN SEE HIS POSTPLAYING
CAREER, PART OF THE TIGERS,
ASTROS AND NOW THE BENCH COACH
OF THE PITTSBURGH PIRATES FOR
HIS SECOND SEASON.
ALSO A CLOSE FRIEND OF SEAN
CASEY.
AND YOUTUBE CREATORS WILL TAKE
YOUR QUESTIONS FOR THE PIRATES
BENCH COACH, WHO JOINS US RIGHT
NOW.
OUR JIM BEAM INTERVIEW IN THE
DUGOUT.
DON, GOOD AFTERNOON.
LET'S START WITH WHAT YOU JUST
SAW FROM BRYAN REYNOLDS.
THE LIVE COMMENTARY SECTION SAID
THIS HAS BEEN A FUN ONE SO FAR.
GREAT SWING BY REYNOLDS.
DO YOU AGREE?
DON: CAN YOU HEAR ME, GUYS?
SCOTT: WE GOT YOU, DON.
DON: IT WAS A GREAT SWING BY
BRYAN THERE, AND HE IS
TREMENDOUS.
GIVES GOOD AT-BATS EVERY NIGHT.
DOES A GREAT JOB.
WE GOT YOU, DON.
I THINK HIS MIKE IS STRUGGLING.
LET AS MOVE TO MITCH KELLER FOR
A MOMENT.
I KNOW LAST TIME OUT HE WAS
LIFTED EARLY BECAUSE OF SOME
HEAT ISSUES THAT LED TO SOME
STOMACH PROBLEMS.
WHAT DID YOU SEE FROM HIM TODAY
COMING OFF THE COVID I.L.?
DON: HE WAS DOING WELL THERE
EARLY, RAN INTO SOME TROUBLE
THERE IN THE THIRD INNING AND
JUST COMMAND WAS A LITTLE BIT
SPOTTY.
BUT HIS STUFF WAS REALLY GOOD
THERE EARLY IN THE GAME.
SCOTT: MAX MUNCY FACING A 1-1.
IT'S 1-2.
TELL US A LITTLE BIT -- CASE,
YOU BACK?
SEAN: YEAH, I AM BACK.
DON: WHAT'S UP, BROTHER?
SEAN: HEY, WHAT'S UP?
DID GOOD, MAN.
TELL US WHAT HAPPENED IN YOUR
OFFICE TODAY.
THERE WAS A FLOOD IN YOUR OFFICE
OR SOMETHING.
DON: I THINK HE SET THAT UP, A
LITTLE LEAK.
GOT MY COMPUTER OUT OF THE WAY.
SEAN: THAT'S GREAT, DUDE.
D.K., CAN YOU TALK A LITTLE
ABOUT FRAZIER, HOW GOOD HE HAS
BEEN FOR YOU GUYS?
YOU SEE HIM EVERY DAY.
WHAT DO YOU SEE EVERY DAY FROM
FRAZIER THAT MAKES HIM SO GOOD?
DON: HE IS A BABLING PLAYER.
HE SHOWS UP -- BASEBALL PLAYER.
HE SHOWS UP EVERY DAY.
YOU SEE THE PLAY HE MAKES
DEFENSIVELY, OFFENSIVELY.
HE IS THE TABLE SETTER FOR US.
THE AT-BATS THAT HE PUTS ON.
THE ENERGY AND CONSISTENCY HE
BRINGS EVERY SINGLE DAY.
CAN'T SAY ENOUGH GREAT, POSITIVE
THINGS ABOUT THE GUY.
SCOTT: AFTER MUNCY ROLLED INTO
THE SHIFT, IT'S JUSTIN TURNER
WHO HAS REACHED BASE TWICE SO
FAR.
WE ARE TALKING TO PIRATES BENCH
COACH DON KELLY THIS HALF INNING
AND TAKING QUESTIONS.
FIVE POINT BIDS WITH THIS GOOD
ONE.
IS MAKING IT AS A BENCH COACH IN
MLB SIMILAR TO TRYING TO MAKE IT
AS A PLAYER?
DON: THAT'S A REALLY GREAT
QUESTION.
YEAH, IT'S -- ANY JOB IN MAJOR
LEAGUE BASEBALL IS AWESOME.
PLAYING, COACHING, IT'S JUST
GREAT.
YOU SEE IT OUT HERE, GETTING TO
COMPETE AGAINST THE DODGERS AND
THE OTHER TEAMS.
ESPECIALLY BEING THE BENCH COACH
IN MY HOMETOWN HAS BEEN REALLY
AWESOME.
SCOTT: NEXT UP FROM MOVIE GAME
TV, WHICH COACH HAD THE BIGGEST
IMPACT ON YOU THROUGHOUT YOUR
PLAYING CAREER?
DON: OH, REALLY GREAT QUESTION,
THERE ARE SO MANY.
ONCE I GOT TO THE BIG LEAGUES,
JIM LEYLAND WAS THE BIGGEST GUY
FOR ME, I LEARNED A TON FROM HIP
IN DETROIT.
EVEN NOW COACHING, GETTING INTO
THE COACHING RANKS, BEING ABLE
TO CALL HIM AND JUST HAVE SUCH A
GREAT RESOURCE TO BOUNCE IDEAS
OFF OF.
JERRY: D.K., I GOT A QUESTION
FOR YOU AS FAR AS APPRECIATING
THE GAME.
THE PLAY BY MOOKIE BETTS A
COUPLE INNINGS AGO WHERE HE
COMES IN, SPIN THROWS AND GETS
RODRIGUEZ AT THE PLATE.
WHAT DID YOU THINK?
DON: UNBELIEVABLE.
TO MAKE A SHOESTRING TYPE CATCH,
HAVE THE BODY CONTROL, ARM
STRENGTH, THE WHOLE PACKAGE
THERE, GETTING THE THROW OFF TO
HOME PLATE.
GREAT PLAY BY BARNES TO PUT THE
TAG ON.
SCOTT: STATCAST POWERED BY
GOOGLE CLOUD.
LOOK AT BETTS WITH THE ARM.
DOES IT SO SMOOTHLY.
JUSTIN TURNER TAKES ONE HIGH AND
TIGHT.
FULL COUNT.
DON KELLY WITH US RIGHT NOW HERE
IN THE FOURTH.
DODGERS UP A RUN.
THE MLB CHANNEL ASKING A
QUESTION ABOUT COACHING LIFE,
DON.
HOW IS BEING A YOUNGER COACH
HELPED YOU DEAL WITH THE
PLAYERS?
I AM SURE YOU'LL HAVE THE LINE
MIXED IN THERE, YOUNGER COACH.
THAT'S ALWAYS GOOD TO HEAR.
DON: IT'S BEEN GREAT.
JUST GETTING -- FROM PLAYING
MYSELF TO BEING ABLE TO RELATE
TO THESE GUYS, UNDERSTAND WHAT
THEY'RE GOING THROUGH ON A DAILY
BASIS AND JUST THE CHALLENGES OF
PLAYING MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL,
THE PRESSURE THEY PUT ON
THEMSELVES, SUCH A TOUGH GAME TO
PLAY BUT TO BE ABLE TO RELATE TO
THAT IN THIS HAS BEEN GREAT GET
NOOG THE COACHING RANKS AND
BEING ABLE TO DO THAT.
SEAN: D.K., WHAT ABOUT SHELTY?
HOW HAS HE MADE IT EASY FOR YOU
AS THE BENCH COACH IN THAT ROLE
FOR YOU?
DON: GREAT QUESTION.
HE HAS BEEN AWESOME.
HE IS SO CONSIST YEPT, FUNNY --
CONSISTENT, FUNNY, DETAILED,
ORGANIZED.
REALLY HIM HAVING DONE THE JOB
BEFORE HAS HELPED ME OUT A TON,
BEING ABLE TO UNDERSTAND BEING A
BENCH COACH AND REALLY THE
CONVERSATIONS AND COMMUNICATION
IS TREMENDOUS, BEING ABLE TO --
HE LETS ME KNOW THINGS THAT HE
NEEDS AND JUST A TREMENDOUS GUY.
SCOTT: DON, THANKS FOR THE TIME.
WE WILL LET YOU GET BACK TO
WORK.
CASE, YOU CAN SAY GOODBYE TO
YOUR BUDDY.
SEAN: THANKS, D.K.
GOOD LUCK.
DON: THANKS, GUYS.
SEE YOU.
SCOTT: DON KELLY, BENCH COACH
FOR THE PIRATES WHO BRING IN
THEIR TO TAKE OVER
FOR CHRIS STRATTON.
DODGERS THREATENING IN THE
FOURTH.
>> IT'S TIME FOR ASK THE DODGERS
WHERE THE PLAYERS ANSWER SOME
QUESTIONS SUBMITTED BY THE FANS.
>> WHAT'S UP?
I LIVE IN CHARLESTON, SOUTH
CAROLINA.
MY FAVORITE PLAYER IS CLAYTON
KERSHAW BECAUSE I AM A
LEFT-HANDED PITCHER MYSELF.
I HAD ONE QUESTION FOR HIM.
TAKE ME MYSELF TO
GET I HAVE A QUESTION FOR HIM.
TAKE ME THROUGH YOUR PREGAME
ROUTINE LIKE DOMAIN AND
STRETCHING AND WHEN IT COMES TO
YOUR BULLPEN AND STUFF.
I JUST WANT TO KNOW ABOUT THAT.
THANKS.
CLAYTON: THANKS FOR THE
QUESTION.
MY ROUTINE IS DOWN TO THE
MINUTE.
I DON'T WANT TO BORE YOU WITH
EVERYTHING I DO BUT I THINK THE
BIGGEST KEY FOR ALL OF THAT IS
HAVING A ROUTINE THAT YOU STAY
CONSISTENT WITH.
WHATEVER YOU FEEL CONFIDENT IN,
WHATEVER GETS YOU READY TO PITCH
THE BEST.
THE MOST ABORTED THING IS TO TRY
TO BE CONSISTENT SO WHEN YOU DO
PITCH, IF YOU HAPPEN TO PITCH
WELL OR BAD, YOU CANNOT BLAME IT
ON SOMETHING ELSE.
YOU ARE ALWAYS PREPARED IN THE
MOMENT.
I AM A LITTLE EXCESSIVE.
I THINK MY TEAMMATES WOULD SAY
THAT AS WELL AS FAR AS MY
ROUTINE BUT IT MAKES ME FEEL
LIKE I AM READY TO PITCH, SO I
DO IT.
>> THANKS FOR ASK THE DODGERS --
THANKS FOR WATCHING "ASK THE
DODGERS."
[CAPTIONS MADE POSSIBLE BY MLB
NETWORK]
[CAPTIONING PERFORMED BY THE
NATIONAL CAPTIONING INSTITUTE,
WHICH IS RESPONSIBLE FOR ITS
CAPTION CONTENT AND ACCURACY.
VISIT NCICAP.ORG]
♪
SCOTT: STEP UP TO THE PLATE,
COMPETE ONLINE, AND CRUSHED
DINNERS IN MLB HOME RUN DERBY.
DOWNLOAD ON THE APP STORE AND
GOOGLE PLAY STORE FOR FREE
TODAY.
P.N.C. PARK IN PITTSBURGH,
PENNSYLVANIA.
A GOOD ONE SO FAR THIS
AFTERNOON.
CHASEN SHREVE, THE THIRD PITCHER
FOR THE PIRATES THIS AFTERNOON
AGAINST THE LOS ANGELES DODGERS.
SHREVE OFF TO A NICE START THIS
SEASON.
WE SAW THE SPLITTER THERE, AND
HE IS USING IT A CAREER-HIGH 43%
OF THE TIME.
IT PRODUCES A SWING AND MISS
FROM CODY BELLINGER IN THE
FOURTH WITH JUSTIN TURNER ON
FIRST.
SCOTT BRAUN, SEAN CASEY, JERRY
HAIRSTON, JUNIOR, AND J.P.
MOROSI.
IT IS FOUR-SEAM OR SPLITTER FROM
THE PIRATES LEFTY.
BELLINGER FOULS IT BACK.
LET'S GO TO J.B. FOR A MOMENT
FOR A LITTLE MORE ON CHASEN
SHREVE.
J.P.: THIS TIME OF YEAR, WE LOVE
TALKING ABOUT THE DRAFT, SO HOW
ABOUT THIS?
COLLEGE BASEBALL, CHASEN SHREVE
WAS AT THE COLLEGE OF SOUTHERN
NEVADA, A TEAMMATE OF BRYCE
HARPER.
THEY MET WHEN THEY WERE 16 YEARS
OLD AND BECAME COLLEGE
TEAMMATES.
SCOTT: BRYCE WAS HIS CATCHER AT
SOUTHERN NEVADA.
THIS SEASON ON A MINOR-LEAGUE
CONTRACT.
JERRY: GOOD TO SEE HIM JOIN
BRYCE HARPER IN THE BIG LEAGUES.
COLLEGE TEAMMATES.
EVERY TIME I THINK OF BRYCE
HARPER, I REMEMBER THE "SPORTS
ILLUSTRATED" COVER AT 16.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: BELLINGER STAYS ALIVE.
I DON'T THINK MANY PEOPLE
REALIZE ALSO THAT HARPER WAS
PLAYING CATCHER AT FIRST.
IF ANYTHING, I KNOW HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT THE FACT THAT IT
HELPED EXPAND HIS BASEBALL
KNOWLEDGE, UNDERSTANDING OF THE
GAME, AND UNDERSTANDING OF HOW
PITCHERS WORK.
JERRY: THAT IS A GREAT POINT,
SCOTT, BECAUSE AS A CATCHER YOU
ARE IN EVERY PITCH.
YOU ARE CALLING THE GAMES.
YOU ARE GAINING THE TRUST OF
YOUR PITCHING STAFF.
IT DEFINITELY HELPED BRYCE'S
DEVELOPMENT AS A PLAYER.
SCOTT: YOU SAW THE PIRATES
INFIELDERS BUNCHED UP TO THE
RIGHT SIDE.
THAT IS WHERE BELLINGER GOES,
AND THAT WILL SET UP A DOUBLE
PLAY EXECUTED BY THE PIRATES
DEFENSE.
SO CHASEN SHREVE COMES IN, GETS
THE GROUND BALL THEY NEED TO
ESCAPE THE FOURTH.
HERE IT IS AGAIN.
SEAN: GONZALEZ IS THE MIDDLE
INFIELDER PLAYING FIRST BASE.
THAT IS A GREAT PLAY.
SCOTT: BACKHAND SAUCE TO SECOND.
BRING IT ON BACK.
PIRATES TRAILED BY JUST A RUN.
>> AMERICA IN 1981 WAS A PLACE
AND TIME WHEN THE PAGES IN A
FOLKTALE TURNED AT THE RIGHT
PACE.
FASTER THAN THE EVENING PAPER,
SLOWER THAN A TWEET, WITH SPACE
TO SOAK IN THE WONDER IN EVERY
CHAPTER.
>> IT IS A FAIRYTALE SO
PREPOSTEROUS DODGER FANS DARE
NOT OPEN THEIR EYES.
EL NIÑO IS FERNANDO VALENZUELA.
>> FERNANDOMANIA WAS ONE OF THE
BEST CATCHES IN BASEBALL HISTORY
AND MORE -- WAS MORE THAN ONE OF
THE BEST AGES IN BASEBALL
HISTORY.
IT WAS A TIME WITHOUT COMPARE.
A SINGULAR STORY THAT BECOMES
MORE TRANSCENDENT EACH TIME WE
TELL IT.
>> 1981 WILL BE THE YEAR OF
FERNANDO VALENZUELA.
>> THE LEFT-HANDER FROM MEXICO
CAPTIVATED LOS ANGELES AND
ULTIMATELY THE COUNTRY WITH HIS
EXTRAORDINARY PITCHING,
ONE-OF-A-KIND WINDUP, AND
UNASSUMING WAY.
>> OF COURSE, HERE TODAY A LOT
OF FOLKS HAVE COME INTO TO SEE
THE MEXICAN PHENOM FERNANDO
VALENZUELA, AND WHY NOT?
HE IS THE HOTTEST SUBJECT IN
BASEBALL.
>> PERHAPS IT IS EARLY-SEASON
HYSTERIA BUT ONLY BORN IN
HOLLYWOOD.
WHAT ELSE CAN BE SAID BUT, VIVA
VALENZUELA.
JERRY: WATCHING MOOKIE BETTS'S
BRILLIANT CAT EARLIER TODAY, A
FLASHBACK TO OCTOBER.
SERIOUS PLAYS THAT HE MADE
AGAINST THE WALL AND ISSUE TOP
GRAB TO DOUBLE OFF A RUN THAT
WAS ABOUT TO SCORE FOR THE
BRAVES IN THAT RUN.
INCREDIBLE GAME CHANGING
DEFENSE.
BEING IN PITTSBURGH, WATCHING IT
LIVE, GOOSEBUMPS BECAUSE I AM
WATCHING HIM DO IT ALL IN FRONT
OF THE CLEMENTE WALL.
I SEE THE CLEMENTE BRIDGE IN THE
BACK ON.
I THINK OF A GREAT WIN-WIN
MOOKIE BETTS MAKES THE CATCH AND
UNLEASHES THE THROW.
IT IS BASEBALL POETRY AS
CLEMENTE ONCE AUTHORED YEARS
AGO.
SCOTT: THAT IS GOLFED INTO LEFT
CENTER.
IT IS A BASE HIT.
AS THE PIRATES START OFF THE
FOURTH INNING WITH A PHILLIP
EVANS SINGLE.
THANKS, J.P.
IN RIGHT FIELD, THE DIMENSIONS
ARE ALSO IN HONOR OF ROBERTO
CLEMENTE.
THAT WALL IN RIGHT IS 21 FEET
TALL.
SEAN: 21 IN THIS CITY MEANS
EVERYTHING, ESPECIALLY BECAUSE
OF CLEMENTE.
THAT 21 FOOT WHILE IN RIGHT
FIELD WHEN THIS PARK WAS BUILT
IN 2001, THAT WAS A BIG DEAL
THAT THEY MADE THAT ALL 21 FEET
HIGH FOR CLEMENTE.
JERRY: I HAVE SEEN A LOT OF
GREAT RIGHT FIELDERS.
I HAVE PLAYED WITH QUITE A FEW
OF THEM.
YASIEL PUIG WAS A REALLY GOOD
RIGHT FIELDER, BUT THE BEST
RIGHT FIELDER I HAVE EVER SEEN
IN MY EYES AS A PLAYER HAS BEEN
MOOKIE BETTS.
HE COMES IN ON BALLS.
THE ACCURACY OF HIS ARM.
SCOTT: IT IS A NICE BACKHANDED
STOP BY MCKINSTRY.
THE THROW ON A HOP NICELY PICKED
UP BY MUNCY FOR THE OUT.
JERRY: MCKINSTRY MAKING THE PLAY
LOOK EASY.
ONE HOP TO MAX MUNCY.
HELPING HIS FIRST BASEMAN OUT.
AS A FIRST BASEMAN, IF YOU THROW
IT ON A HOP, MAKE SURE IT IS A
LONG HOP REALLY GOOD PLAY BY
MAX.
SEAN: YEAH.
REALLY GOOD PLAY BY MUNCY RIGHT
HERE.
IT IS A TOUGH PICK RIGHT IN
FRONT OF THE LIP IT KIND OF
KICKS UP ON HIM.
HE DOES A GREAT JOB OF SNAGGING
THAT.
SCOTT: EVANS MOVES UP TO SECOND.
SEAN: I ALWAYS SAY, GUYS, YOU
DON'T SEE ANY PLACE IN THE
HIGHLIGHT REEL THAT THE FIRST
BASEMAN IS NOT PICKING IT.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
SCOTT: I AM ALWAYS SHOUTING GUYS
OUT.
JERRY: IMPORTANT TO HAVE A GOOD
FIRST BASEMAN.
SCOTT: FROM FREDDIE FREEMAN,
PAUL GOLDSCHMIDT, MUNCY DID A
HECK OF A JOB RIGHT THERE.
THAT IS A REALLY TOUGH BASEBALL
TO PICK UP.
FIRST BASEMEN LIKE YOU MAKE IT
LOOK SO SIMPLE.
SEAN: THAT'S RIGHT.
DON'T YOU FORGET THAT.
THEY DON'T GET ENOUGH
APPRECIATION.
THEY THINK YOU CAN THROW ANYONE
OVER THERE AND IT IS NOT TRUE.
THAT IS WHY HE IS SO VALUABLE.
HE PLACED SECOND, THIRD, AND
PLAYS A GREAT THIRD BASE, TOO.
JERRY: FIRST BASEMEN ARE LIKE
THE OFFENSIVE LINE.
THEY DON'T GET ENOUGH LOVE
HELPING THE RUNNING BACK OR
PROTECTING THE QUARTERBACK.
IMPORTANT PIECE TO THE INFIELD.
SCOTT: ONE OUT, ONE ON.
BREAKS HIS BAT.
LUX WILL HAVE TO HURRY.
HIS THROW IS THERE.
LOOK AT THIS INFIELD DEFENSE GO.
JERRY: THAT IS A GREAT PLAY
THERE BY GAVIN LUX.
LITTLE JAM SHOT.
HAS TO THROW IT ON THE RUN, IN A
HURRY, MAKE A STRONG ACCURATE
THROW.
GREAT PLAY.
SEAN: THE GAME IS SO FAST.
WATCH THAT TRANSFER.
THESE BIG LEAGUES SHORTSTOPS,
GUYS LIKE YOU KNOW THAT, AND THE
TIMING THAT'S GUYS THAT CAN DO
THAT, AND THE TIMING -- THESE
BIG LEAGUES SHORTSTOPS, GUYS
THAT CAN DO THAT, AND THE
TIMING.
SCOTT: THAT BRINGS US TO KEVIN
NEWMAN.
FIRST PITCH STRIKE, FASTBALL IN
FROM URÍAS.
JERRY: IT IS A BIG AT-BAT HERE
FOR NEWMAN.
YOU GOT TO OUTS AND RUNNER ON
THIRD BASE DOWN A RUN.
BIG MOMENT IN THE BALLGAME.
SCOTT: LOWEST O.P.S. IN BASEBALL
SO FAR THIS YEAR.
SENDS THAT ONE TO RIGHT.
BETTS LOOKING AND FINDING IT.
HE MAKES THE CATCH TO END THE
INNING.
HOW ABOUT THE DEFENSE FROM THE
DODGERS IN THE FOURTH?
MCKINSTRY, LUX, AND BETTS IS
ALWAYS THERE.
A SCORELESS FORTH FROM URÍASTHÍ.
♪
>> AND SO FROM THE BRINK OF YOU
LIMITATION, THE PIRATES GOT SET
FOR A GAME SEVEN IN BALTIMORE
CHOCK FULL OF CONFIDENCE.
>> I HAD JUST GOTTEN TRADED FROM
THE STEALERS TO THE 49ERS SO I
AM NOT IN SAN FRANCISCO BUT I
HAVE WATCHED THESE GUYS ALL
SUMMER AND HOW THEY ARE PLAYING.
I SAID THEY ARE GOING TO WIN
THIS.
I JUST KNOW IT.
IT WAS DESTINY.
>> STARGELL, THE BIG MAN.
>> WE SAID WE WERE NOT GOING TO
BE DENIED AT ALL.
>> JUST A LITTLE BIT AWAY FROM
WINNING ANOTHER WORLD
CHAMPIONSHIP.
>> KELLY HITS IT IN THE AIR TO
CENTER FIELD.
MARINO OVER TO RIGHT CENTER.
PITTSBURGH WINS IT.
AND SO THIS TEAM WITH ITS
REMARKABLE COMEBACK PROVED
ITSELF ALL OVER AGAIN.
>> PITTSBURGH PIRATES, 1979
WORLD CHAMPIONS.
THAT WAS YOUR FIRST ONE.
IT WAS WONDERFUL, HUH?
>> IT WAS.
PLAYED WITH SOME GREAT GUYS.
>> THIS IS SOMETHING I WANTED
ALL MY LIFE.
I DEFINITELY WANTED THIS.
SCOTT: WE GOT UP TO THE FIFTH IN
PITTSBURGH.
THE RAIN HAS DISAPPEARED FOR NOW
AND WE APPRECIATE YOU HANGING
OUT WITH US ON YOUTUBE AS WE
CHECK OUT THE TOP DRAFT
PROSPECTS.
THE DRAFT IS A MONTH AWAY.
THE 2021 TOP PLAYERS AVAILABLE.
YOU ARE LOOKING AT THE LIST,
WHICH IS VERY IMPORTANT FOR THE
PITTSBURGH PIRATES.
THEY HAD THE WORST RECORD IN
BASEBALL LAST YEAR.
THAT MEANS THEY GOT TO SELECT
FROM THAT LIST.
WE WILL KEEP IT SIMPLE FOR YOU.
WHO WOULD YOU CHOOSE WITH NUMBER
ONE?
ARE YOU GOING SEASONED COLLEGE
PLAYER OR HIGH SCHOOL PROSPECT?
JERRY: YOU KNOW WHO I AM
CHOOSING FIRST?
THE BEST PLAYER AVAILABLE.
I DON'T CARE IF IT IS A SEASONED
COLLEGE PLAYER OR A HIGH SCHOOL
PROSPECT.
THERE IS A LOT OF GREAT HIGH
SCHOOL PROSPECTS OUT THERE.
CODY BELLINGER CAME OUT OF HIGH
SCHOOL.
COREY SEAGER CAME OUT OF HIGH
I AM LOOKING AT BEST PLAYER
AVAILABLE.
SCOTT: THAT IS A SMART CALL.
BEATY POPS OUT INTO SHALLOW LEFT
CENTER.
J.V., WHAT DO YOU THINK -- J.P.,
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
J.P.: THIS IS THE YEAR OF THE
SHORTSTOP.
MARCELLO MAYOR, FOR ME, IS THE
ONE THAT I WOULD SAY THAT THE
MLB PIPELINE HAS GOING TO THE
PIRATES.
ALSO, JORDAN BOLLARD, BRANDY
HARRIS, AND OF COURSE THE
CO-ACES AT VANDERBILT, JACK
LEITER, HENRY DAVIS OVER
LOUISVILLE.
THE DODGERS HAD A PRETTY GOOD
CATCHER FROM LOUISVILLE
THEMSELVES IN WILL SMITH BEHIND
THE PLATE.
A LOT OF GREAT CHOICES.
WE EVEN HEARD DEREK SHELTON
SAYING AT THE DROP GETS CLOSER,
OF COURSE THIS YEAR FOR THE
FIRST TIME HAPPENING AT THE
ALL-STAR GAME IN DENVER.
DEREK SHELTON WILL PROBABLY
START LOOKING AT SOME SCOUTING
AS WELL, THE FUTURE OF THE
PITTSBURGH PIRATES.
SCOTT: THE DODGERS FOR YEARS NOW
ARE PICKING IN THE BACK OF THE
FIRST ROUND, BUT THEY HAVE DONE
WELL.
DEREK SHELTON IN PITTSBURGH WILL
HAVE A TOUGH CHOICE AT NUMBER
ONE.
IT IS NOT LIKE IT IS BETWEEN TWO
GUYS THIS YEAR.
IT IS BETWEEN FIVE OR SIX LIKE
WE ARE SHOWING YOU.
THE DODGERS JUST FIND GEMS IN
THE 33RD ROUND IN 2016 LIKE
MCKINSTRY.
SEAN: WITH THIS PICK WITH THE
PIRATES, THEY REALLY GOT TO HIT
ON THIS ONE, THE PIRATES.
THEY CANNOT AFFORD -- HAVING
THIS FIRST PICK, THEY HAVE TO
HIT WITH THE FIRST PICK IN THIS
DRAFT.
JERRY: I COMPLETELY AGREE.
YOU HAVE TO HIT ON THE FIRST
PICK OF THE DRAFT IF YOU ARE THE
PITTSBURGH PIRATES.
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU ARE TRYING
TO BUILD THE FARM SYSTEM UP, YOU
CANNOT AFFORD TO MAKE MISTAKES.
THEY ARE GOING TO DO THEIR
HOMEWORK AND SELECT THE BEST
PLAYER THAT NOT ONLY FITS THEIR
SYSTEM, BUT THE BEST PLAYER
AVAILABLE.
SCOTT: THEY HAD THE NUMBER ONE
PICK BACK IN 2011.
THEY HIT ON THE PICK.
IT WAS GERRIT COLE.
HIS BEST BASEBALL HAS BEEN WITH
THE ASTROS AND NOW WITH THE
YANKEES.
HERE IS COLE IN 2011.
MCKINSTRY TO A LEAPING GONZALEZ.
HE PLAYS A NICE FIRST BASE.
TWO OUTS IN THE FIFTH.
BEN CHERINGTON IS THE G.M. OF
THE PITTSBURGH PIRATES THIS
OFF-SEASON ALONE, HE PICKED UP
14 PROSPECTS IN DEALS FOR JOE
MUSGROVE, JAMESON TAILLON, AND
JOSH BELL.
THERE IS THE ONE FOR STARLING
MARTE LAST YEAR AT THE TRADE
DEADLINE WITH THE MARLINS AS
WELL.
SOME SERIOUS QUANTITY TO FILL UP
THE FARM SYSTEM, AND THAT IS
SOMETHING BEN SAID THEY
DESPERATELY NEEDED TO BUILD
THINGS BACK UP AND GET READY FOR
THE FUTURE, SEAN.
SEAN: BEN CHERINGTON HAS A TRACK
RECORD.
HE BUILT UP A LOT OF THAT FARM
SYSTEM IN BOSTON BEFORE HE WAS
LET GO THERE.
ONE OF THE ONES THAT WON THE
WORLD CHAMPIONSHIP, AND HE WAS
THERE, TOOO.
THE PIRATES -- TOO.
THE PIRATES, THEY DO WHEN THEY
HAD TO MELT SOME -- HAD TO MOVE
SOMEONE LIKE JOSH BELL.
THEY HAVE GUYS IN THE SYSTEM
THAT CAN COME UP AND HELP IN THE
BIG LEAGUES IN THE FUTURE.
JERRY: WE TALKED TO MANAGER
DEREK SHELTON EARLIER TODAY.
IT IS A TOUGH PROCESS.
YOU ARE TRYING TO WIN NOW AS A
BIG-LEAGUE CLUB BUT ALSO TRYING
TO DEVELOP GUYS.
PART OF THAT DEVELOPMENT IS
MAKING SURE YOU HAVE ENOUGH GUYS
IN THE MINOR LEAGUES SO WHEN
THEY ALREADY AT 21, 22 YEARS OF
AGE, THEY ARE READY TO COMPETE
AT THE BIG-LEAGUE LEVEL.
SCOTT: IT IS A GREAT INNING FROM
CHASEN SUP, THREE DOWN IN THE
FIFTH.
PIRATES DOWN A RUN.
THERE TURNED ABOUT.
-- THEIR TURN TO BAT.
♪
>> WELCOME BACK TO THE PARK
INTENT AND CISCO AS WE HEAD TO
THE BOTTOM OF THE NINTH INNING.
KEVIN BROWN IS JUST THREE OUTS
AWAY.
THE BOTTOM OF THE ORDER COMING
UP FOR SAN FRANCISCO.
9-0, THE MARLINS WITH A BIG
LEAD.
BUT RIGHT NOW, THE STORY IS
RIGHT-HANDER KEVIN BROWN.
KEVIN BROWN IS JUST TWO OUTS
AWAY.
ONLY ONE OUT AWAY.
SO NOW, BROWN IS JUST ONE STRIKE
AWAY FROM WHAT WOULD BE THE
SECOND NO-HITTER IN MARLINS
HISTORY.
IT IS A NO-NO.
KEVIN BROWN IS BEING MOBBED.
THE SECOND NO-HITTER IN MARLINS
HISTORY.
ON THIS TUESDAY AFTERNOON IN SAN
FRANCISCO, IT IS OVER AS THE
GIANTS DO NOT GET A HIT.
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS GETTING BY
HIM HERE.
IF IT DOES GET BY HIM, THEN I
CAN'T.
>> I SAW YOU TRY TO GO FOR
SECOND.
>> HE WAS ON THE DIRT AND THEN I
RAN FOR HIM.
LET'S GO.
SCOTT: WE DO THIS EVERY WEEK ON
YOUTUBE.
SOMETIMES THE GUYS ARE JOKING
AROUND.
THEY ARE GIVING US REALLY FUNNY
CONTENT.
WITH ADAM FRAZIER, YOU ARE
GETTING BASEBALL STRATEGY.
TRYING TO CREATE A LITTLE
OBSTRUCTION, IT SOUNDED LIKE.
JERRY: HE CERTAINLY WAS.
IT IS ONE OF THOSE THINGS WHERE
IT IS A TOUGH PLAY, A TOUGH READ
FOR A SECOND BASE RUNNER.
THAT BALL IS HIT BACK TO JULIO.
NOW THE COUNT IS 1-1.
BUT FRAZIER KIND OF TOOK AN
EDUCATED GAMBLE.
YOU HAVE TO CREDIT URÍAS RIGHT
THERE TO MAKE A GREAT PLAY AND
RUN HIM BACK AND GET HIM IN THE
RUNDOWN.
FRAZIER, A REALLY GOOD PLAYER,
REALLY HEADS UP PLAYER.
ONE OF THOSE THINGS WHERE HE
TOOK AN EDUCATED GAMBLE BUT IT
DID NOT WORK OUT.
SCOTT: 1-2 TO PINCH HITTER BEN
GAMEL.
ALSO, THE WAY THAT ADAM FRAZIER
SO SEAMLESSLY CAN PLAY A VARIETY
OF POSITIONS.
CONTACT HITTING MACHINE.
HE IS GOING TO BE VERY VALUABLE.
JERRY: YOU WERE JUST TALKING
ABOUT THE DRAFT.
SO MANY FRIENDS IN THE GAME OF
BASEBALL.
THEY ARE LOOKING FOR GUYS WHO
CAN PLAY BASEBALL, PLAY A
VARIETY OF POSITIONS, AND
CONTACT HIS KING IN THEIR
REPERTOIRE.
SURE, EVERYBODY LOVES HITTING
THE BALL OUT OF THE BALLPARK,
BUT YOU WANT TO HAVE THE GUYS
THAT HAVE GREAT BAT TO BALL
SKILLS, AND FRAZIER IS ONE OF
THOSE GUYS.
SCOTT: THERE HE IS, ON DECK
AFTER GAMEL.
JERRY, YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS LIKE
TO LEARN A VARIETY OF POSITIONS
AND THE CHALLENGES OF PLAYING
THOSE POSITIONS SO WELL.
YOU HAVE GOTTEN TO SEE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF TURNER
ON THE DODGERS AND HOW WELL HE
HAS BECOME BECAUSE YOU ARE NOT
JUST LEARNING YOUR SPOT AS A
PROFESSIONAL BUT YOU HAVE TO
PICK UP A DIFFERENT GLOVE AND
POSITION EVERY DAY.
WHAT IS THAT LIKE?
JERRY: IT IS NOT AN EASY
PROCESS.
TAYLOR AND FRAZIER, THESE GUYS
DO THIS AT THE BIG-LEAGUE LEVEL.
SOMETIMES YOU LEARN HOW TO PLAY
POSITIONS IN MINOR LEAGUES, SOME
IN COLLEGE, BUT A GUY LIKE CHRIS
TAYLOR NEVER PLAYED OUTFIELD
UNTIL HE GOT TO THE BIG LEAGUES
SO HE REALLY WORKED HARD NOT
JUST BEING AN AVERAGE
OUTFIELDER.
NOW HE IS A PLUS DEFENDER OUT
THERE.
HE HAS ALWAYS HAD THAT GREAT
ARM.
IF YOU ARE A REALLY GOOD ATHLETE
AND CAN PLAY SHORTSTOP, YOU CAN
PLAY A VARIETY OF POSITIONS.
SCOTT: URÍAS SPOTS ONE FOR
STRIKE THREE.
HIS THIRD K OF THE DAY.
DODGER DEFENSE, THEY TAKE A LOT
OF PRIDE IN RUN PREVENTION, AND
WE HAVE SEEN EXAMPLES TODAY,
LIKE MOOKIE BETTS IN RIGHT AND
ZACH MCKINSTRY AT SECOND BASE,
WHO CAN ALSO PLAY A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT POSITIONS.
GAVIN LUX DOES AN EXCELLENT JOB
AT SHORTSTOP.
BETTS CAN RUN DOWN JUST ABOUT
ANYTHING.
JERRY: WE JUST SAW MOOKIE BETTS
RIGHT THERE.
I SAY ALL THE TIME HE IS THE
ULTIMATE SUPER UTILITY GUY
BECAUSE HE CAN PLAY THE INFIELD.
HE CAME UP AS A SECOND BASEMAN.
BECAUSE HE HAS SUCH A GREAT ARM,
THEY PUT HIM IN RIGHT FIELD.
ALWAYS LOOKING TO DRAFT GUYS
THAT ARE GREAT ATHLETES.
SCOTT: POP-OUT AND A DOUBLE IN
THE THIRD INNING FOR FRAZIER,
AND NOW ANOTHER 0-2 PITCH COMING
UP.
JERRY: ONE THING THAT HAS
SEPARATED JULIO URÍAS THIS
SEASON FROM PAST SEASONS, THE
ABILITY TO PUT GUYS AWAY WITH
THE OFF-SPEED PITCH.
HE HAS 0-2 TO FRAZIER HERE,
LOOKING TO PUT HIM AWAY WITH A
COUPLE OF PITCHES.
THERE IS THE SLIDER IN THE DIRT.
SCOTT: IT REGISTERS AS A
CURVEBALL.
I HEAR DODGERS BRASS OFFICIALLY
CALL IT A SLURVE, WHICH IS NOT
AN OPTION ON THE STATCAST
SELECTION.
BUT JUST TO GIVE YOU AN IDEA
WHAT WE ARE DESCRIBING.
THIS TIME, URÍAS WITH THE
FASTBALL TOO HIGH.
JERRY: HE WANTED TO MAKE SURE
FRAZIER WAS NOT LOOKING OUT
THERE TO PROBABLY SET UP THE
FIRST PITCH.
GOT AWAY FROM IT A LITTLE BIT.
SCOTT: 2-2.
THAT IS A BREAKING BALL.
THAT IS FOR BELLINGER.
TWO GONE.
OK.
WITH ADAM FRAZIER JUST RETIRED,
WHICH IS NOT EASY TO DO, J.P.,
WE WONDERED, WILL HE STILL BE IN
THAT UNIFORM A MONTH FROM NOW?
J.P.: MY BELIEVE IS THE ANSWER
IS NO.
JERRY POINTED OUT THE YANKEES
ARE A TREMENDOUS FIT.
THE YANKEES ARE STRUGGLING TO
HIT FROM LEFT SIDE DUST FROM THE
LEFT SIDE.
FRAZIER CAN HELP THEM WITH MORE
CONTACT, THE VERSATILITY.
I WOULD SAY A COUPLE OF TEAMS
WITHIN THE N.L. CENTRAL, BOTH
THE BREWERS AND THE CARDINALS.
REFRESH MY MEMORY.
BACK IN 2009 WHEN THE YANKEES
WON THE WORLD SERIES, DID THEY
GO TO AN N.L. CENTRAL TEAM AND
FIND SOMEONE WHO WAS GREAT
PLAYING ALL ABOUT THE DIAMOND
AND MAKING CONTACT WHO HELPS
THEM WIN A WORLD SERIES THAT
YEAR?
JERRY: THEY DID.
THEY HAD A TEAM THAT WAS FULL OF
TALENT BUT THEY WERE LOOKING FOR
A GUY TO LEAD THAT GROUP WITH
DEREK JETER, MARIANO RIVERA, AND
ALEX RODRIGUEZ SO THEY TRADED
FOR THIS GUY FROM CINCINNATI
THAT CAN PLAY A VARIETY OF
POSITIONS.
THEY GO ON TO THE WORLD SERIES.
THEY DID NOT RE-SIGN HIM AND
THEY HAVE NOT WON A WORLD SERIES
SINCE.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: THAT'S GOOD.
I AM GOING TO GUESS THAT IS NOT
THE FIRST TIME YOU USED THAT,
BUT I LOVE IT.
JERRY HAIRSTON, JUNIOR, WORLD
SERIES RING.
YANKEES HAVE NOT WON SINCE 2009.
JERRY: I'M GOING TO GET A TEXT
FROM A COUPLE OF GUYS IN THE
NEXT COUPLE MINUTES.
SCOTT: SO GOOD.
STILL 1-2 TO COME BRIAN HAYES --
TO KE'BRYAN HAYES.
JERRY: IN ALL HONESTY, TEAMS CAN
ALWAYS USE A GUY LIKE FRAZIER.
HE CAN LEAD THEM OFF.
HE HAS SPEED.
VERY GOOD DEFENSIVELY.
CONTACT, ESPECIALLY NOWADAYS, IS
KING.
YOU ARE LOOKING FOR GUYS LIKE
FRAZIER.
SCOTT: BIG SWING AND A MISS FROM
HAYES.
SWINGING OUT OF HIS SHOES.
FOURTH STRIKEOUT FOR U FIFTH.
FRAZIER AND THE PIRATES TRAILED
BY A RUN THROUGH FIVE.
-- TRAIL BY A RUN THROUGH FIVE.
♪
>> THE SPLITS AT HOME PLATE ON A
PITCH IN.
>> YOU HAVE TO WATCH THIS GUY.
>> UNBELIEVABLE.
>> GROUNDED TO THIRD.
GONZALEZ SMOOTH AS SILK OVER
THERE.
THAT WILL COME OFF THE BAG.
ACTUALLY SHOULD NOT BE LAUGHING.
THAT IS NOT A BAD IDEA.
OH MY GOODNESS.
>> THERE IS NOBODY AT FIRST.
>> NO WAY.
>> WOW.
>> THAT IS UNBELIEVABLE.
NEVER SEEN THAT BEFORE.
JAVIER BAEZ JUST STOLE A RUN FOR
HIS CUBS.
>> 2-2 PITCH IS REACHED FOR.
LITTLE POP-UP.
HANG ON.
A HECK OF A PLAY HERE, FOLKS.
>> HE MADE THE PLAY WHILE
HOLDING HIS CELL PHONE AND
VIDEOTAPING HIMSELF AT THE SAME
TIME.
SO NOT ONLY DOES HE LEAVE WITH A
SOUVENIR, BUT HE LEAVES WITH A
POST AS WELL.
SCOTT: TOP SIX, DODGERS UP A
RUN.
EACH WEEK THIS SEASON, WE ARE
FOCUSING ON A YOUTUBE CONTENT
CREATOR FEATURED IN OUR, TO
RESECTION.
OUR SPOTLIGHT IS ON COWBOY JEFF.
YOU CAN WATCH THIS DODGER FAN
MAKE VIDEOS.
HIS GOAL IS TO SHARE HIS LOVE OF
BASEBALL WITH EVERYONE.
2.5 MILLION VIEWS ON HIS VIDEOS.
CLOSE TO 30,000 SUBSCRIBERS.
THE ONLY LAUNCHED HIS CHANNEL
TWO YEARS BACK.
KIDS, YOUTUBE CREATOR DREAMS CAN
COME TRUE.
HE IS ALSO FROM DODGER FILMS, A
BIG-TIME YOUTUBE CHANNEL.
HELLO, COWBOY JEFF.
GIVE US A HELLO AND WE WILL HIT
YOU BACK ON THE BROADCAST.
LET'S FINISH UP OUR SECOND POLL
QUESTION OF THE DAY.
WHO ARE YOU GOING TO PICK WITH
THE NUMBER ONE PICK IN THE
DRAFT?
TWO THIRDS OF THE AUDIENCE GOES
WITH THE SEASONED COLLEGE
PLAYER.
CASE, WE ARE OF COURSE
GENERALIZING WITH A QUESTION
LIKE THIS, BUT IT PLAYS TO THE
FACT THAT HOPEFULLY IT IS A GUY
THAT YOUR ORGANIZATION CAN SEE
SOONER IN THE BIG LEAGUES.
GUESS WHAT, FANS DON'T LIKE TO
WAIT.
SEAN: ESPECIALLY NOWADAYS.
THEY WANT TO SEE GUYS THERE
FAST.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS DRAFT,
THERE ARE SO MANY GOOD PLAYERS
AT THE TOP.
A LOT OF GOOD HIGH SCHOOL
SHORTSTOPS AND A LOT OF GOOD
COLLEGE ARMS.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, IF THE
APARTMENTS LOOK AT IT, MAYBE IT
IS THAT HIGH SCHOOL SHORTSTOP, A
GUY LIKE A DEREK JETER THAT CAN
BE A FRANCHISE TYPE GUY.
JERRY: I AGREE WITH SEAN RIGHT
THERE.
GET THE BEST PLAYER YOU CAN GET.
LOOKING AT THE DODGES DROPPED, I
MENTIONED EARLIER CODY
BELLINGER, COREY SEAGER, CLAYTON
KERSHAW.
THEY WERE ALL HIGH SCHOOL GUYS.
WHAT IF THEY WOULD HAVE TAKEN A
CHANCE ON A COLLEGE GUY AND NOT
GET A CHANCE TO DRAFT THOSE
STUDS?
YOU CAN GET COLLEGE STUDS AS
WELL, LIKE A HUGE STANDOUT,
PRIOR.
STRASBURG WAS A STUD.
SURE THE GUY YOU ARE PICKING IS
A STUD.
SCOTT: HIGH UPSIDE IS THE GOAL,
LIKE GERRIT COLE FOR THE
PIRATES OUT OF UCLA, THE LAST
TIME THEY SELECTED NUMBER ONE.
SEAN: DON'T FORGET, GERRIT COLE
HAD SOME GOOD YEARS HERE IN
PITTSBURGH.
ONE YEAR, HE WAS THIRD IN CY
YOUNG.
HE HAD SOME GOOD YEARS.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, THEY WERE
NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO SIGN HIM
LONG-TERM.
SCOTT: DUANE UNDERWOOD, JUNIOR,
INTO THE SIXTH INNING, AND HE
WALKS AUSTIN BARNES.
THIRD WALK OF THE DAY FOR
BARNES.
HE IS ON FIRST.
WE ARE GOING TO J.P. IN THE
BALLPARK.
J.P.: IN 2006, I WAS A YOUNG
MAN.
I WAS COVERING THE TIGERS FOR
THE FREE PRESS AND THEY TRADED
FOR SEAN CASEY.
CASEY IS ONE OF THE GREAT PEOPLE
IN BASEBALL.
I WAS EXCITED.
HE BACKS .529 AGAINST THE
CARDINALS THAT YEAR.
WHEN YOU FINALLY GOT TO FACE THE
CARDINALS, A TEAM THAT YOU KNEW
SO WELL FROM THIS DIVISION, HOW
MUCH DID THAT HELP?
HOW MUCH OF IT IS A FACTOR
SWITCHING LEAGUES?
HOW MUCH OF AN ADJUSTMENT
PERIOD WAS THERE FOR YOU IN
2006 AND IS THERE NOW FOR
PLAYERS STILL TO THIS DAY?
SEAN: BUT AS A QUICK QUESTION.
I KNOW FOR ME WHEN I WENT TO THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE WITH THE TIGERS
IN THE MIDDLE OF A PENNANT RACE,
WHICH WAS AWESOME, IT WAS A
LITTLE BIT OF AN ADJUSTMENT
FACING THOSE TEAMS I HAD NOT
SEEN ALL THE TIME.
WHEN I WENT TO THE WORLD SERIES
AND WE WERE FACING ST. LOUIS,
MAN, IT FELT SO GOOD TO BE IN A
PLACE AND A CITY AND AGAINST A
TEAM I PLAYED SO MUCH AGAINST IN
MY CAREER.
I THINK IT DEFINITELY HELPED ME
IN THE WORLD SERIES BEING
FAMILIAR WITH THEM.
JERRY: WE SEE JULIO HEADING BACK
TO THE BATTER'S BOX.
WE SAW HIM EARLIER GET THE BUT
DOWN AND GET A HUGE TWO OUT, TO
R.B.I. SINGLE EARLY IN THIS
BALLGAME.
TRYING TO EXECUTE.
SCOTT: HE IS THE PITCHING LEADER
IN R.B.I.'S AT THE PLATE THIS
SEASON, JUMPING PAST YNOA OF THE
BRAVES.
THAT IS BUNTED FOUL, AND URÍAS
IS OUT.
JERRY: YOU KNOW HE IS
DISAPPOINTED IN HIMSELF RIGHT
THERE, TRYING TO HELP THE CAUSE.
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE MOOKIE BETTS
BEHIND HIM AND YOU ONLY HAVE A
ONE RUN LEAD RIGHT NOW.
VERY DISAPPOINTED WITH HIMSELF.
USUALLY GETS THE BUNT DOWN AND
HANDLES THE BAT.
SCOTT: AND NOW, UNDERWOOD
AGAINST MOOKIE BETTS.
HOMER, WALK, STRIKEOUT IN THOSE
THREE AT-BATS IN THE FIRST THREE
INNINGS FOR L.A.
JERRY: IT HAS BEEN A JOY TO
WATCH AND SEE MOOKIE BETTS PLAY
ON AN EVERYDAY BASIS.
I KNEW HE WAS A GREAT PLAYER
WITH THE RED SOX BUT TO SEE HIS
ATHLETICISM ON DISPLAY ON
DEFENSE AND OFFENSE HAS BEEN
SPECIAL.
ONE OF THE BEST SKILLED BASEBALL
PLAYERS I HAVE EVER SEEN.
SEAN: I THINK THAT IS THE
BIGGEST THING ABOUT MOOKIE
.
HE HAS NOT GOTTEN OFF TO A SUPER
HOT START OFFENSIVELY BUT YOU
HAVE THE APPRECIATION TO SEE
THIS GUY RUN THE BASES, MAKE
PLAYS DEFENSIVELY, USE THE CANON
OF AN ARM.
THAT IS WHAT MAKES HIM ONE OF
THE BEST PLAYERS IN BASEBALL.
HE CAN BEAT YOU IN SO MANY
DIFFERENT WAYS.
SCOTT: AS WE CHECK OUT HIS LAST
FOUR SEASONS, THE BARREL
PERCENTAGE, WHICH IS GOOD, AND
THE HARD-HIT PERCENTAGE, WHICH
YOU WANT, IS DOWN THIS YEAR.
IT HAS TRICKLED DOWN THE LAST
FEW SEASONS FROM THE CAREER-HIGH
IN 2018 AS THE A.L. M.V.P.
YOU WONDER ALSO THIS YEAR IF
SOME OF THAT HAD TO DO WITH THE
LOWER BACK TIGHTNESS HE WAS
DEALING WITH IN THE MONTH OF
APRIL.
I KNOW HE MISSED A BIT OF TIME
SO I WONDER IF WE WILL
EVENTUALLY HAVE SPLITS ON THOSE
NUMBERS WHERE THE SECOND HALF OF
THE SEASON LOOKS MORE POWERFUL
FROM A STRONG MAN.
JERRY: YOU ARE RIGHT.
HE WAS DEALING WITH THE LOWER
BACK ISSUE AND HE ALSO HAD A
SHOULDER INJURY THAT HE DID NOT
DISCLOSE TO A LOT OF PEOPLE.
HE UNDERSTOOD THE IMPORTANCE OF
HAVING HIMSELF IN THE LINEUP
BECAUSE YOU ARE MISSING COREY
SEAGER CODY BELLINGER -- COREY
SEAGER, CODY BELLINGER FOR TWO
MONTHS.
HE IS AS TOUGH AS IT GETS.
SCOTT: EVEN WHEN THE BAT IS --
SEAN: HE IS A THROWBACK GUY THAT
SAYS -- JERRY: HE IS NOT
THROWBACK GUY THAT SAYS EVEN IF
MY BACK HURTS ME, MY TEAM NEEDS
ME.
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE THOUGHT CAL
RIPKEN, JUNIOR, WAS NOT HURT.
HE WAS HURT ALL THE TIME.
HE JUST WENT OUT THERE EVERY DAY
FOR HIS TEAM.
THAT IS HOW MOOKIE BETTS
APPROACHES THE GAME.
SCOTT: IT IS ALWAYS SOMETHING
FROM MOOKIE.
WE SAW THAT LAST YEAR IN THE
POSTSEASON IN 2020.
THE DODGERS INVESTED BIG IN
TRADING FOR HIM FROM THE RED SOX
AND THEN EXTENDING HIM FOR 12
MORE SEASONS.
SINCE THE START OF 2020, HE HAS
THE HIGHEST W.A.R. AMONG
POSITION PLAYERS, WINS ABOVE
REPLACEMENT, COMPETENCE OF STAT
TO SUM UP HIS BATTING,
BASERUNNING, HIS ELITE FIELDING
IN RIGHT FIELD.
THIS ONE HANGING UP THERE FOR
THE SECOND BASEMAN FRAZIER TO
HAUL IN FOR OUT NUMBER TWO.
JERRY: FRAZIER MADE THAT LOOK
EASY.
THAT IS NOT AN EASY PLAY.
ABLE TO MAKE THE BASKET CATCH
THERE.
REALLY GOOD JUMP ON THE
BASEBALL.
MAKES THE PLAY LOOK EASY.
HERE COMES MAX MUNCY.
MANAGER DAVE ROBERTS CALLED HIM
THE M.V.P. SO FAR THIS SEASON.
HAVING A GREAT OFFENSIVE YEAR.
SCOTT: WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
STATS, IT IS A FAIR POINT.
MAX BRINGING THE POWER.
ALWAYS THE PATIENCE.
HE HAS HAD SOME MONSTER SEASONS
WITH L.A.
2019, 35 HOMERS, 98 RUNS DRIVEN
IN.
TAKES THE 0-1, TWO OUTPITCHED,
AND THAT WILL GET CLEANED UP.
ONE LEFT STRANDED.
DODGERS STILL HANGING ONTO THAT
ONE RUN LEAD.
BACK TO JULIO URÍAS IN THE
SIXTH.
>> OH MY.
>> HANG ON.
>> THIS ONE IS --
>> OUT OF HERE.
♪
>> STALLINGS HITS ONE DEEP TO
LEFT FIELD, AND THIS ONE IS
GONE.
A WALKOFF TO RUN HOMER FOR JACOB
STALLINGS.
>> WHAT IS HAPPENING?
TOTALLY AWESOME.
>> THAT IS HIT HARD TO CENTER
FIELD.
GREAT TRY, BUT NO CHANCE.
SO STALLINGS IN TO SECOND BASE.
HE WANTS THREE.
LOOK AT HIM GO.
HE'S GOT A TRIPLE.
LINE DRIVE TO LEFT FIELD.
THIS IS GOING TO GET DOWN.
JACOB STALLINGS, THE CHEETAH,
JUST DOUBLED IN ONE, TWO, AND
THREE RUNS.
HOW ABOUT THAT?
THE BUCS LEAD IT NOW 5-3.
SCOTT: WE ARE IN THE HOME SIXTH.
CHECKING OUT SOME OF THE
PRETTIEST PARKS, MOST HISTORIC
BALLPARKS IN THE COUNTRY.
FENWAY TO ORACLE IN SAN
FRANCISCO, WHAT A VIEW WITH THE
WATER.
PITTSBURGH IS UP THERE FOR SURE
ALSO.
SOME WATER OUT THERE BEYOND THE
OUTFIELD, THE ALLEGHENY.
THIS WATER IS MAN-MADE IN CHASE
FIELD BUT STILL AWESOME TO DROP
A BASEBALL IN THERE IF YOU GO
ALONG.
SO OUR NEXT POLL ON YOUTUBE,
WHERE WOULD YOU MOST WANT YOUR
HOME RUN TO LAND?
MONSTER SEATS, MCCOVEY COVE,
ALLEGHENY, OR THE POOL IN
PHOENIX?
OH, I LIKE THIS ONE.
JERRY, WHERE DO YOU WANT YOUR
HOME RUN BALL TO LAND?
JERRY: I AM SO GLAD YOU ASKED ME
FIRST.
[LAUGHTER]
JERRY: MONSTER SEATS, I GOT A
CHANCE TO VISIT THE MONSTER
SEATS WHEN I WAS WITH THE
ORIOLES.
I TOOK MARTINA'S WAY BACK INTO
THE MONSTER SEATS SO I HAVE
ALREADY DONE THAT.
HOW ABOUT THE POOL?
I WAS ON THE 2012 DODGERS WHEN
WE CRINGED IN ARIZONA.
WE HAD A NICE POOL PARTY THERE
SO I WOULD NOT MIND HITTING A
HOME RUN IN THE POOL.
I HAVE ALWAYS BEEN A FAN OF POOL
PARTIES.
[LAUGHTER]
SEAN: I WAS FORTUNATE.
I HIT ONE IN THE POOL IN ARIZONA
SO I GOT THAT IN MY BOOKS.
I HIT THE FIRST HOME RUN EVER AT
P.N.C. PARK.
IT WAS NOT IN THE RIVER BUT IT
WAS THE FIRST ONE, EVEN BIGGER.
I THINK MCCOVEY COVE -- I ALWAYS
WANTED TO HIT ONE IN MCCOVEY
COVE AND NEVER DID.
I WANTED SOMEONE OUT THERE LIKE
SCOTT BRAUN PEDDLING HIS KAYAK
TO GET THE BALL SO MCCOVEY COVE
WOULD BE THE BIG ONE FOR ME.
JERRY: THOSE ARE GREAT ANSWERS.
I DID NOT KNOW YOU HIT THE FIRST
HOME RUN AT PNC BALLPARK.
OUTSTANDING.
CONGRATULATIONS.
I NEVER WANT TO HIT ONE IN
MCCOVEY COVE BECAUSE I HAVE
ALWAYS BEEN AFRAID OF SHARKS.
WE KNOW IN SAN FRANCISCO THERE
ARE SHARKS APLENTY THERE.
I DON'T WANT TO HIT A BALL IN
THAT AREA.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: YEAH.
I AM NOT ON A BOAT OUT THERE,
ESPECIALLY NOT THAT ONE.
SEAN: NO.
YOU ARE ONE OF THOSE GUYS THAT
WOULD LIKE TO DO STUFF LIKE
THAT.
I LOVE WHEN MADISON BUMGARNER --
WHEN ONCE HE HIT IT OFF OF
GARDNER AND SAID SOMETHING TO
MUNCY.
HE SAID, GO GET IT OUT OF THE
WATER.
SCOTT: GO GET THIS ONE.
THE CINCINNATI RED IN
PITTSBURGH, THE FIRST EVER HOME
RUN AT THE BALLPARK WHICH WAS
BORN INTO THOUSAND ONE.
APRIL 9, FOREVER PARK APARTMENTS
HISTORY.
SEAN: I LEFT 70 TICKETS FOR THAT
GAME.
70 TICKETS I LEFT.
SO WHEN I HOMERED, I GAVE THE
FAMILY AND FRIENDS THEIR MONEY'S
WORTH.
SCOTT: SEAN CASEY, A .314 CAREER
HITTER AT P.N.C. PARK.
YOU SAW THE BALL WELL THERE,
HUH?
SEAN: I WAS SO BAD I THREE
RIVERS STADIUM BECAUSE I STILL
FELT LIKE I WAS A FAN WITH MY
DAD OUT THE GAME.
I THINK I GET .150 -- I THINK I
HIT .150 THERE.
AT PNC COME I DID NOT FEEL LIKE
A FAN.
I FELT LIKE A LEGITIMATE PLAYER.
JERRY: THAT WAS A GOOD LINEUP
THROWN OUT THERE.
KEN GRIFFEY, JUNIOR, A COUPLE
GUYS THAT GO DEEP, BUT YOU WERE
THE ONE THAT HIT THE HOME RUN.
PRETTY IMPRESSIVE.
SEAN: WE HAD SOME BOPPERS IN
THOSE LINEUPS.
WE HAD SOME GUYS THAT COULD
SWING IT.
SCOTT: I JUST GOT THE SPLITS AT
THE BALLPARK IN PITTSBURGH.
.179?
.175.
SEAN: I WAS SO BAD.
IT WAS SO FRUSTRATING.
I WAS IN THE DUGOUT AT THREE
RIVERS THINKING TO MYSELF THIS
IS REALLY COOL.
I WOULD GROUND OUT EVERY TIME.
SCOTT: THAT'S WHY THEY KNOCKED
IT DOWN AND STARTED OVER FOR
YOU.
SEAN: THAT'S RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
SCOTT: STALLINGS SOLIDLY STRUCK
UP THE MIDDLE BUT THE DOCTORS
HAVE A MAN THERE.
THE SHIFT.
TWO OUTS.
JERRY: REALLY GOOD BALL STRIKING
THERE BUT NOT SMART HITTING.
RIGHT AT THE SECOND BASEMAN.
SCOTT: MCKINSTRY IS THERE TO PUT
AWAY STALLINGS, AND THAT BRINGS
US TO PHILLIP EVANS.
2-2, SINGLES AND THE SECOND AND
THE FOURTH TODAY.
PITCH NUMBER 85 FROM URÍAS.
JERRY: WE TALKED TO MANAGER DAVE
ROBERTS.
HE WANTED JULIO TO BE EFFICIENT
TODAY, TO PITCH DEEP IN THE
BALLGAME.
UP TO THIS POINT, HE HAS DONE
JUST THAT.
85 PITCHES AND WE ARE IN THE
SIXTH INNING.
HE HAS GIVEN HIS MANAGER A
PRETTY GOOD START.
SCOTT: EVANS CLOCK STATE TO
LEFT, AND THERE IS BEATY.
A 1-2-3 SIXTH JUST LIKE HE
PULLED OFF IN THE FIFTH.
ONLY FIVE OUTS YESTERDAY FROM
GONSOLIN, SO URÍAS SAYS, HEY,
BULLPEN, I GOT YOU TODAY.
>> HANG ON.
>> DEEP.
>>>> THIS ONE IS --
>> OUT OF HERE.
♪
>> BELLINGER HITS ONE WAY UP
THERE.
WILLIAMS GOING BACK AT THE WALL.
GOODBYE.
GRAND SLAM.
AN 11 RUN FIRST INNING.
PUJOLS HITS THE BALL THE OTHER
WAY DEEP TO RIGHT FIELD.
REDDICK IS GOING BACK.
AT THE WALL.
ALBERT PUJOLS, HIS FIRST. YOUR
HOME RUN -- HIS FIRST DODGER
HOME RUN.
HIS FIRST AS A LOS ANGELES
DODGERS.
>> LOOK AT THE JOY HE IS PLAYING
WITH RIGHT NOW.
>> 1-0.
>> LUX HITS THE BALL WAY BACK
THERE.
HIS BIGGEST BIG-LEAGUE SWING.
THREE RUN HOME RUN.
>> THAT SWING PUMPS SOME AIR
INTO THIS BUILDING, AND
ESPECIALLY INTO THAT DUGOUT.
SCOTT: NEW FOR US THIS SEASON,
THIS BEAUTIFUL HARDWARE.
THE YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME
TROPHY.
IF YOU ARE WATCHING ON YOUR
MOBILE DEVICE OR COMPUTER, YOU
VOTE.
YOU DECIDE WHO WILL RECEIVE THIS
CUSTOM TROPHY, NAME ENGRAVED ON
IT.
MAKES THIS ONE EXTRA SPECIAL.
BREAKING UP THINGS IN THE
REGULAR SEASON FOR THE PLAYERS.
STAY TUNED FOR THE PLAYER OF THE
GAME HOLDING OPTIONS LATER IN
THE SHOW.
WE WILL TALK TO THAT PLAYER
AFTER THE GAME IS COMPLETE LIVE
ON YOUTUBE TO A GLOBAL AUDIENCE
TODAY.
THE DODGERS 4, THE PIRATES 3.
INNING
UPPER SEVEN BEGINNING IN
PITTSBURGH.
IT LOOKS LIKE WE ARE IN GOOD
SHAPE -- ENDING NUMBER SEVEN
BEGINNING IN PITTSBURGH.
IT LOOKS LIKE -- INNING NUMBER
SEVEN BEGINNING IN PITTSBURGH.
IT LOOKS LIKE WE ARE GOOD WITH
THE RAIN.
A 4-3 GAME.
WE WILL SEE IF THE BULLPENS CAN
KEEP IT THAT WAY AS THE PIRATES
ACTUALLY HAVE THEIR RELIEVERS AS
THEIR STRENGTH OF THE TEAM, AND
THE DODGERS PEN HAS BEEN REALLY
SOLID IN THIS SERIES.
THERE IS JUSTIN TURNER FOULING
ONE OFF TO THE LEFT SIDE.
YESTERDAY, TONY GONSOLIN MADE
HIS SEASON DEBUT COMING OFF A
SHOULDER ISSUE.
ONLY PICKED UP FIVE OUTS.
THE DODGERS IT SAID, WE WILL
HANDLE IT FROM HERE.
JERRY: THE DODGERS BULLPEN ALL
SEASON LONG HAS BEEN
OUTSTANDING.
YESTERDAY, DAVE ROBERTS
WANTED LENGTH OUT OF GONSOLIN
MAKING HIS FIRST START.
VERY UNCHARACTERISTIC FIVE WALKS
FOR TONY LAST NIGHT.
A LINE DRIVE RIGHT IN THE GLOVE
OF REYNOLDS BY J.T.
HARD-HIT BALL.
DAVE ROBERTS SAID IT WAS
IMPORTANT FOR JULIO TO PITCH
DEEP IN THE BALLGAME BECAUSE
LAST NIGHT, IT TURNED INTO A
BULLPEN GAME.
SCOTT: NICE LITTLE EXTRA SQUEEZE
IN CENTER FROM BRYAN REYNOLDS TO
HOLD ONTO THE BASEBALL.
STARTED THE YEAR IN THE CORNER.
PIRATES COULD NOT FIND WHAT THEY
WERE LOOKING FOR IN CENTER FIELD
AND SAID, OK, BRYAN, LET'S
SEE WHAT YOU GOT.
CENTER FIELDER ON THE OTHER
SIDE, CODY BELLINGER, 1-3 TODAY.
A SINGLE IN THE THIRD INNING.
EVENTUALLY, HE SCORED.
UNDERWOOD, JUNIOR, BACK TO WORK,
THE 26-YEAR-OLD WHO PITCHED ON
TUESDAY.
SEAN: HEY, JERRY.
THAT IS THE PITCH RIGHT THERE AT
95 DOWN THE MIDDLE.
IT SEEMS LIKE BELLINGER IS A
LITTLE LATE ON THE HEATER.
IS THAT WHAT YOU HAVE BEEN
SEEING SO FAR FROM HIM THIS
SEASON?
JERRY: WE HAVE BEEN SEEING THAT
SO FAR.
CODY BELLINGER MISSED TWO MONTHS
OF THE SEASON.
REALLY DID NOT HAVE A SPRING
TRAINING BECAUSE HE HAD SHOULDER
SURGERY IN THE OFF-SEASON SO HE
IS KIND OF BEHIND.
HE DOES NOT HAVE A WHOLE LOT OF
AT-BATS THIS YEAR SO HIS TIMING
IS A HAIR OFF.
THE DODGERS WOULD LIKE CODY
BELLINGER WITH TWO STRIKES NOW
TO SHORE IT UP AND LOOKED TO PUT
THE BALL IN PLAY LIKE HE DID HIS
LAST AT-BAT.
SCOTT: DIGS FOR ONE AND FINDS
THE SIGNAL.
HOW ABOUT THAT DUST FINDS THE
SINGLE -- AND FINDS THE SINGLE.
HOW ABOUT THAT?
JERRY: BEFORE TWO STARTS, LET IT
RIP.
THE LITTLE ICHIRO SWING HERE.
DOWN AND AWAY, HE BARRELED IT
UP.
LOOK AT THAT SWING.
HEAD DOWN ON CONTACT.
GREAT CONCENTRATION.
SURE ENOUGH, HE GETS A HIT
OUT OF IT.
SEAN: YOU HAVE TO COMPETE
SOMETIMES WITH TWO STRIKES.
YOU DON'T NEED TO BE UP THERE
TAKING A BIG RIP.
COMPETE.
YOUR SWING DOES NOT HAVE TO LOOK
PERFECT.
HE DOES A GREAT JOB OF WAITING
AND FLIPPING IT TO LEFT.
.
JERRY: WITH HIS SPEED, BALL IN A
GAP, IT WILL BE A TO RUN
BALLGAME.
THAT IS WHY YOU ALWAYS FIGHT.
IF YOU ARE CODY BELLINGER,
MOOKIE BETTS, FIGHT WITH TWO
STRIKES TO GET ON BASE BECAUSE
YOUR SPEED IS A DIFFERENCE
MAKER.
SCOTT: BEATY ON THE GROUND, LEFT
SIDE, AND HE COMES THROUGH.
BELLINGER SHOWING OFF THE
WHEELS.
HE WILL GET TO THIRD EASILY.
RUNNERS ON THE CORNERS NOW WITH
ONE OUT IN THE SEVENTH.
JERRY: THERE IS THAT SHIFT.
IT COMES INTO PLAY.
I AM SHOCKED THEY ARE SHIFTING
ON MATT BEATY.
HE HANDLES THE BAT, GOES THE
OTHER WAY, SEES THE LEFT SIDE IS
OPEN.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I WILL HIT A HARD GROUND BALL
AND GET A BASE HIT OUT OF IT.
GREAT APPROACH.
CODY BELLINGER FLYING AROUND
SECOND BASE.
SEAN: NOTHING BETTER WHEN THE
BALL IS IN FRONT OF YOU AND YOU
KNOW YOU CAN TAKE IT AND RUN
RIGHT IN THE GUY'S FACE.
SCOTT: BACK-TO-BACK BASE HITS.
HERE IS MCKINSTRY.
JERRY: ESPECIALLY NOW WITH A 1-1
BALLGAME.
UNDERWOOD IS LOOKING FOR
SOMETHING DOWN, HOPING FOR A
GROUND BALL DOUBLE PLAY.
IF YOU ARE ZACH MCKINSTRY, YOU
ARE LOOKING FOR THE PITCH UP.
AT THE VERY LEAST, YOU WANT TO
HIT A SAC FLY TO PUSH THE RUNNER
ACROSS AND MAKE IT A TO RUN
BALLGAME.
SCOTT: DID HE GO?
NO.
MCKINSTRY WAS OFF TO A FAST
START THIS SEASON.
QUICKLY MAKING A NAME FOR
HIMSELF.
HE WAS LEADING ALL ROOKIES WITH
14 R.B.I.'S ON THE 20TH OF APRIL
WHEN HE HIT THE INJURED LIST
WITH A STRAINED OBLIQUE.
A LITTLE QUIETER SINCE HE
RETURNED.
SMACKS THAT ONE PASSED IN FIELD,
AND THE DODGERS HAVE A TWO-RUN
LEAD.
BELLINGER COMES IN.
IT IS 5-3.
SEAN: THAT IS WHY THAT FIRST AND
THIRD SITUATION IS SO IMPORTANT.
THEY GOT FIRST AND THIRD WITH
BELLINGER THERE.
IT OPENS UP THE HOLE ON THE
RIGHT SIDE.
MCKINSTRY DOES A GREAT JOB.
I THINK THAT WAS A CHANGEUP.
HE JUST HOOKS IT.
YEAH, IT IS A CHANGEUP THAT
BACKS UP.
SOMETIMES AS A HITTER WHEN YOU
FEEL YOU HAVE GOT HOLE, YOU TRY
AND SHOOT IT ON THE GROUND TO
MAKE SURE YOU GET THE GUY IN.
SEE THAT HOLE RIGHT THERE?
I REMEMBER BEING TOLD THERE IS A
LOT OF MONEY IN THE FOUR HOLE
WHEN YOU HAVE A GUY ON FIRST AND
THIRD AND CAN SHOOT IT.
IT IS A GREAT PIECE OF HITTING
RIGHT THERE.
JERRY: THAT IS A GREAT POINT.
YOUR CONFIDENCE AS A HITTER
SKYROCKETS WHEN YOU KNOW ALL YOU
HAVE TO DO IS GET A BALL IN THE
AIR AND A GUY LIKE CODY
BELLINGER IS ON THIRD BASE.
I CAN AT LEAST GET A SAC FLY.
I AM LOOKING FOR HARD CONTACT.
YOU GET A BASE HIT AN R.B.I..
DODGERS HAVE ACTIONDOD DODGERS
HAVE ACTION ON FIRST ANDG
SECONDER -- DODGERS HAVE
ACTION.
ACTION ON SECOND.
SCOTT: SINCE THEN, TIMELY
HITTING FROM THE DODGERS SCORING
IN A VARIETY OF WAYS.
JERRY: THAT IS SOMETHING MOOKIE
EMPHASIZED LAST SEASON WHEN HE
FIRST CAME OVER TO THE DODGERS.
WE NEED TO SCORE.
IF WE WANT TO BE A CHAMPIONSHIP
TEAM, WE NEED TO SCORE IN A
VARIETY OF WAYS.
YES, THE LONG BALL IS COOL, BUT
WE HAVE TO EXECUTE.
SAC FLY, MOVE THE BALL ALL OVER
THE DIAMOND, AND EXECUTE.
THE DODGERS HAVE DONE THAT SO
FAR TODAY.
SCOTT: EIGHT HITS FOR L.A., ONE
HOMER, SEVEN SINGLES, INCLUDING
ONE FROM LUX.
JERRY: YOU SEE GAVIN LUX THE
LAST MONTH OR SO HAS BEEN SO, AT
THE PLATE.
-- SO CALM AT THE PLATE.
CONFIDENT KNOWING THAT HIS
TALENT IS STARTING TO SHOW AT
THE BIG-LEAGUE LEVEL.
SCOTT: HE WAS THE BEST PLAYER IN
THE MINOR LEAGUES IN 2019.
CALLED UP LATE THAT SEASON.
PLAYED IN THE POSTSEASON FOR THE
DODGERS THAT YEAR.
YOU CAN SEE HIS NUMBERS
ADVANCING TO ANOTHER LEVEL SINCE
THE MONTH OF MAY.
1-2.
SEAN: I THINK ONE THING WITH LUX
KNOWING HE WILL PLAY EVERY DAY
AS A PLAYER, WHEN YOU KNOW YOU
ARE PLAYING EVERY DAY, YOU CAN
RELAX AND KNOW THAT IF I AM 0-4
I AM NOT COMING OUT OF THE
LINEUP.
I GET A CHANCE TO SETTLE IN AND
GET MY RHYTHM GOING AND TIMING
GOING EVERY DAY.
JERRY: THAT'S A GREAT POINT.
I THINK A PLAYER, ESPECIALLY A
YOUNG PLAYER, ALWAYS NEEDS TO
FEEL NEEDED.
YOU SEE BICKFORD GETTING READY
IN THE BULLPEN.
YOU ALWAYS WANT TO BE NEEDED.
WITH THE INJURIES AND COREY
SEAGER ON THE I.L., HE KNEW THAT
THEY NEEDED HIM TO BE THE STAR
PLAYER, AND HE PERFORMED.
SCOTT: RISING TO THE OCCASION.
THAT IS BALL FOUR.
BASES LOADED UP FOR THE DODGERS.
LUX IS SO WISE BEYOND HIS YEARS
WITH A PHRASE THAT STOOD OUT TO
ME IN SPRING TRAINING AFTER A
REALLY DOWN 2020.
DID NOT START THE SEASON ON THE
BIG-LEAGUE ROSTER.
HE SAID, IT IS PROBABLY A GOOD
THING IN MY CAREER TO STRUGGLE
EARLY ON, LEARN HOW TO DEAL WITH
IT, LEARN HOW TO DEAL WITH
FAILURE.
NOW THERE HAS BEEN SUCCESS FOR
HIM AND MAYBE MORE COMING FOR
THE DODGERS.
THEY LEAD BY OF THE BIG ARMS FOE
PIRATES COMING IN, BUT --
BEDNAR.
>> BATTING THIRD, PLAYING RIGHT
FIELD, ROBERTO CLEMENTE.
>> YOU WANT NUMBERS, HE HAD THE
NUMBERS.
FOUR BATTING TITLES, 15 ALL-STAR
GAMES, 12 GOLD GLOVES.
>> CAUGHT BY CLEMENTE WITH A
TREMENDOUS DIVING CATCH.
>> BUT WITH CLEMENTE, HE WAS SO
MUCH MORE THAN THAT.
WATCH THE OLD FILM AND YOU SEE
AN ARTIST AT WORK, AN ARTIST WHO
PAINTED WITH A BAT AND HIS
GLOVE, HIS LEGS, AND THAT
UNBELIEVABLE RIGHT ARM.
>> ROBERTO CLEMENTE FIELDS THE
BALL AND DISPLAYS HIS ARM.
>> HE WILL TRY FOR THIRD.
IT MAY BE CLOSE.
>> GREATEST RIGHT FIELDER IN THE
GAME OF BASEBALL, ROBERTO
CLEMENTE.
>> LIKE ANY GREAT ARTIST, HIS
WORK IS A LITTLE DIFFERENT THAN
ANYBODY ELSE'S.
AND WITH CLEMENTE, THAT WORK WAS
ABSOLUTELY CONNECTED TO WHERE HE
CAME FROM.
>> IN PITTSBURGH, THEY CALL HIM
THE GREAT ONE.
>> THIS MAN IMPRESSED ME SO MUCH
THAT I WILL NEVER FORGET
CLEMENTE.
SCOTT: PUSH YOUR FAVORITE
PLAYERS TO THE TOP THIS SUMMER
WITH THE 2021 GOOGLE MLB
ALL-STAR BALLOT.
VOTE DAILY AT MLB.COM/VOTE AND
ON GOOGLE TO SEND THEM TO
DENVER, COLORADO.
THE BALLOT FEATURES TWO PHASES
OF VOTING.
GO TO, BE.COM/VOTE OR SEARCH ON
GOOGLE -- GO TO MLB.COM/VOTE OR
SEARCH ON GOOGLE.
PHASE I IS NOW.
AND THEN WE PICK THE TOP THREE
PLAYERS AT HIS POSITION PLUS
NINE OUTFIELDERS AS WE CONTINUE
ALONG AND EVENTUALLY ANNOUNCE
STARTERS ON THE NIGHT OF JULY 1.
THIS IS DAVID BEDARD.
MAYBE A RELIEVER MAKES IT TO THE
ALL-STAR GAME FOR PITTSBURGH.
THEY HAVE A FEW VIABLE OPTIONS.
BEDNAR, OF COURSE, THEIR CLOSER.
RODRIGUEZ HAS BEEN AWESOME SO
FAR THIS YEAR.
ADAM FRAZIER IS A CANDIDATE.
SO IS BRYAN REYNOLDS.
WE KNOW THE DODGERS ARE LOADED
WITH ALL-STAR CANDIDATES.
THEIR MANAGER DAVE ROBERTS WILL
BE REPRESENTING THE N.L. IN THE
DUGOUT AS THE SKIPPER.
AUSTIN BARNES WITH A BIG CHANCE
HERE.
BASES-LOADED.
JUST ONE GONE.
BEDNAR BRINGS SERIOUS HEAT.
96, A BIT OFF THE PLATE.
BARNES FOULS IT AWAY.
THREE TIMES THIS AFTERNOON,
BASED -- THREE TIMES THIS
AFTERNOON BARNES GOT ON BASE.
SEAN: EXACTLY.
[LAUGHTER]
SEAN: WHERE WAS IT?
SCOTT: IN THE BRAIN.
SEAN: BEDNAR HAS BEEN REALLY
GOOD THIS YEAR, GUYS, AT
STRANDING INHERITED RUNNERS.
AND ALSO WITH RUNNERS IN SCORING
POSITION, NOT LETTING THOSE GUYS
SCORE.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS HERE IF
HE CAN REALLY ATTACK BARNES.
HE CAN GO FOR A STRIKEOUT RIGHT
HERE.
JERRY: THE COUNT IS IN HIS
FAVOR.
2-1 FOR AUSTIN BARNES.
LOOKING FOR A FASTBALL HERE.
SCOTT: BARNES WEEKLY ON THE
GROUND.
BEDNAR GOES HOME, AND THEY GET
THE FORCE.
SO NOW TWO DOWN.
JERRY: REALLY GOOD PLAY BY
BEDNAR, HOPPING OFF THE MOUND,
MAKING SURE HE GOT THE OUT AT
THE PLATE.
PRETTY GOOD ATHLETE.
HE IS A BIG DUDE.
GOING TO SEE HIM POP OFF THIS
MOUND HERE AND MAKE THE PLAY.
SEAN: WHO SAYS PITCHERS ARE NOT
ATHLETES, JERRY?
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
JERRY: I SAY THAT ALL THE TIME,
BUT THAT IS ATHLETIC.
I WOULD NOT SAY THAT OF BEDNAR
SEAN: YOU WOULD BE IN TROUBLE.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: THE DODGERS ARE GOING FOR
IT HERE.
CHRIS TAYLOR COMING UP WITH THE
BASES LOADED AND TWO OUTS IN THE
SEVENTH.
JERRY: WE TALKED ABOUT MAX MUNCY
EARLIER, ABOUT BEING THE TEAM
M.V.P..
HERE IS THE OTHER GUY.
HE'S IS VALUABLE AS IT GETS.
33 RBIS, LEADS THE BALLCLUB IN
RUNS GORED AS WELL.
JUST BEEN AN IMPORTANT PIECE FOR
THE DODGERS.
HE'S GOING TO GIVE YOU A GREAT
AT BAT.
SEES A LOT OF PITCHES, DOESN'T
WASTE A PITCH.
SEAN: WHAT A WEAPON FOR DAVE
ROBERTS TO HAVE ON THE BENCH.
YOU SEEN CHRIS TAYLOR START THE
GAME BUT YOU'RE STILL ABLE TO
BRING HIM UP IN A HUGE SITUATION
IN THE SEVENTH AND HAVE A GOOD
MATCHUP AGAINST BEDNAR.
SCOTT: IN THERE, 0-2.
JERRY: CHRIS TAYLOR, EXCELLENT
FASTBALL HITTER WITH THE BASES
LOADED.
FIRST TWO PITCHES, BREAKING
BALLS.
A KNEE BUCKLING CURVEBALL RIGHT
HERE.
NOW 0-2.
SCOTT: THAT PITCH WAS THE SPLIDE
R.
SPLITTER-SLIDER MIX FROM BEDNAR.
SEE WHAT HE DIALS UP ON THE 0-2.
GOT HIM.
SERIOUS BREAKING STUFF FROM
BEDNAR TO COMPLEMENT THE BIG
TIME FASTBALL.
LOOK AT HIM GO.
IN A FIND, HE COMES IN,
PREVENTS FURTHER DAMAGE, BUT THE
DODGERS HAVE A TWO RUN CUSHION
AS WE HEAD TO THE BOTTOM OF THE
SEVENTH.
LET'S STRETCH.
>> IT'S TIME FOR ASK THE
DODGERS, WHERE THE PLAYERS
ANSWER QUESTIONS SUBMITTED BY
THE FANS.
>> I'M JUST WONDERING WHO HAD A
BIG INFLUENCE ON YOUR LIFE
GROWING UP?
>> THANK YOU FOR SUPPORTING ME,
I'M DOING WHAT I CAN TO BE A
ROLE MODEL TO A LOT OF KIDS, SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
I WOULD SAY PROBABLY JUST MY
PARENTS.
BOTH OF THEM WERE HUGE ROLE
MODELS FOR ME, THE WAY THEY
TREATED PEOPLE, THE WAY THEY
WENT ABOUT ALL THEIR BUSINESS.
THEY PUT EVER LASTING
IMPRESSIONS ON ME, AND I'M
TRYING TO DO THE SAME FOR THE
NEXT GENERATION.
>> CONGRATULATIONS ON WINNING
THE WORLD SERIES.
WHAT ADVICE WOULD YOU GIVE TO
YOU YOUNGER SELF DURING THE
LITTLE LEAGUE WORLD SERIES AS A
WORLD SERIES CHAMPION?
>> TO JUST ENJOY IT, DON'T TAKE
IT TOO SERIOUSLY, BUT HAVE FUN
AND PLAY THE GAME HARD.
>> BELLINGER TAKES THAT ONE TO
LEFT FIELD.
GOODBYE, ANOTHER HOME RUN.
>> CODY BELLINGER, STILL
RIDICULOUS.
>> THANKS FOR WATCHING "ASK THE
DODGERS."
SCOTT: A LITTLE SEVENTH INNING
STRETCH.
SOME TIME TO THINK ABOUT THE MO
BE GAME OF THE WEEK LIVE ON
YOUTUBE, PLAYER OF THE WEEK.
WHO GETS THE TROPHY, LIKE PETE
ALONSO DID LAST WEEK.
COMPETITIVE PLAYERS IN THE SPORT
WANT TO ADD EVERY SINGLE PIECE
OF HARDWARE TO THE RESUME.
WE WILL UNVEIL THAT POLL LATER.
WHERE WOULD YOU MOST WANT YOUR
HOME RUN TO LAND?
THE WINNER, MCCOVEY COVE WITH
40% OF THE PIE.
ASHLEY SANDERSON, MCCOVEY COVE
FOR ME WOULD BE A BIG SPLASH.
I LIKE THIS ONE FROM THE
PITTSBURGH PIRATES CHANNEL.
ALLEGHENY RIVER, IT COULD FLOAT
AWAY AND I COULD SAY I HIT 100S
OF MILES.
THAT'S GOOD.
-- I HIT ONE HUNDREDS OF MILES.
SEAN: ALLEGHENY RIVER, I'M NOT
TOO MUCH OF A FAN UP BECAUSE IT
SOUNDS TOO MUCH LIKE ALLIGATORS.
SHARKS, ALLIGATORS, I'M NOT A
FAN.
JERRY: THERE'S NO ALLIGATORS IN
THE ALLEGHENY RIVER, I PROMISE
YOU.
SCOTT: HOW DO YOU KNOW THAT?
JERRY: I JUST KNOW.
THERE MIGHT BE A COUPLE OF TIRES
AND THERE, BUT THERE'S NO
ALLIGATORS.
SCOTT: THE NEW PITCHER FOR L.A.
IS PHIL BICKFORD.
PHIL LAST PITCHED ON SATURDAY IN
ATLANTA, SCORELESS INNING, JUST
13 PITCHES.
HEAVY FASTBALL GUY.
USES THE FOUR-SEAMER 80% OF THE
TIME.
OFF-SPEED, 1-2.
SEAN: HE HAS BEEN A FINE FOR THE
DODGERS.
A LOT OF INJURIES THEY'VE HAD
WITH THEIR BULLPEN.
HE HAS BEEN ASKED TO COME IN AND
PITCH IN LATER INNINGS,
SOMETIMES THE SEVENTH, EIGHTH
INNING TO GET KEY OUTS.
HE'S DONE A GREAT JOB.
SCOTT: AND HE STRIKES OUT
GONZALES.
SEAN: THAT WAS A FILTHY SLIDER
RIGHT THERE.
LOOK AT THIS, THE DECEPTION OF
THAT PITCH.
IT LOOKS LIKE IT'S RIGHT DOWN
THE MIDDLE.
YOU THINK IT'S A FASTBALL AND
THEN IT JUST LEAVES YOU.
GREAT PITCH.
JERRY: THAT'S WHY THE FASTBALL
IS SO IMPORTANT.
WHEN YOU GET AHEAD WITH THAT
FASTBALL, AND THAT SLIDER IS
BASICALLY ON THE SAME PLANE AS
THAT FASTBALL, IS VERY DECEPTIVE
AND TOUGH TO HIT.
SCOTT: THAT IS SOME SERIOUS
HORIZONTAL MOVEMENT ON HIS
SLIDER.
MOSTLY A TWO PITCH GUY.
THERE'S THE HEAT.
JP, THE DODGERS HAVE A FEW ARMS
THAT COULD GET THE JOB DONE,
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
JERRY: 1-4, IT'S HARD TO THINK
OF A BETTER ROTATION ANYWHERE IN
BASEBALL.
THE BULLPEN HAS BEEN SOLID, AS
USUAL.
BUT I WOULD SAY THAT PITCHING
DEPTH IN GENERAL WILL BE A FOCUS
OF THIS TEAM AT THE TRADE
DEADLINE.
CONSIDER WHAT HAPPENED IN LAST
NIGHT'S GAME.
TONY GONSOLIN IN HIS FIRST
OUTING IN THE MAJOR LEAGUES THIS
SEASON, 1.2 INNINGS, FIVE WALKS.
I THINK WITH HIS STRUGGLES LAST
NIGHT, OF COURSE DUSTIN MAY OUT
FOR THE YEAR, BUT WATCH GONSOLIN
CAREFULLY.
WHEN YOU CONSIDER HOW MUCH THEY
LIKE HAVING DAVID PRICE AND
JIMMY NELSON IN THE BULLPEN,
THERE MIGHT BE A SPOT FOR A
SWING-TYPE PITCHER WHO CAN
EITHER START FOR YOU OR BE A
BOLD INNINGS GUY LIKE THAT HAD
WITH DUSTIN MAY LAST YEAR IN
OCTOBER.
THAT ROLE SEEMS AVAILABLE FOR
THIS TEAM GOING FORWARD.
SCOTT: THANKS, JP.
2-2.
BICKFORD IS PRODUCING SOME
PRETTY UGLY SWINGS, THE FIRST
COUPLE OF HITTERS HE HAS FACED.
LOOKS LIKE IT'S BEEN TOUGH TO
PICK UP THE BASEBALL.
SEAN: THAT 93-94 IT LOOKS A
LITTLE HARDER THE WAY SOME OF
THOSE SWINGS THESE GUYS ARE
TAKING.
IT LOOKS MORE LIKE 96-97.
JERRY: TWITTER IS SOMETHING
ELSE.
I JUST GOT TWEETED AT, THIS IS
FROM THE PITTSBURGH
POST-GAZETTE.
ANOTHER ALLIGATOR FOUND ROAMING
PITTSBURGH.
SO DEFINITELY, THERE ARE
ALLIGATORS NEAR THE ALLEGHENY
RIVER.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: I THINK IT'S A UNIVERSITY
OF FLORIDA GRADUATE, IT IS A
FLORIDA GATOR.
THEY ARE CONFUSING THINGS.
JERRY: I'M TELLING YOU, OCTOBER
2, 20 19, GUYS, WATCH OUT,
ALLIGATORS ROAMING THE SWAMPS
AND RIVER.
LOOK OUT.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN AN ALLIGATOR
OUT THERE IN THAT RIVER.
I'M TELLING YOU, I HAVE SWIM IN
THOSE RIVERS BEFORE.
I DIDN'T COME OUT TO CLEAN, BUT
I WAS SWIMMING.
SCOTT: 3-2, BROKE HIS BAT.
SHALLOW CENTER, WHO'S GOT IT?
IT'S TAYLOR.
SO L.A. IS TRYING TO PICK THINGS
UP IN A VERY COMPETITIVE
DIVISION.
THEY HAVE DOMINATED AGAINST THE
FIVE FIRST TEAMS IN THE NATIONAL
LEAGUE.
LOOK WHAT IS COMING UP, A
LAST-PLACE TEXAS RANGERS TEAM.
A DECENT PHILADELPHIA PHILLIES
SQUAD, AND THEN THE WORST TEAM
IN BASEBALL, THE ARIZONA
DIAMONDBACKS, THEN THE GAUNTLET,
PADRES, CUBS, GIANTS.
L.A. GOING FOR A THIRD
CONSECUTIVE WIN THIS AFTERNOON.
A LITTLE SOFT SPOT IN THE
SCHEDULE.
JERRY: I PLAYED FOR MANAGER
DUSTY BAKER, AND HE ALWAYS
EMPHASIZED, WHEN YOU ARE PLAYING
TEAMS YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO BE, YOU
HAVE TO MAKE SURE YOU DO NOT
LOSE YOUR CONCENTRATION.
CONTINUE TO PLAY YOUR GAME.
DUSTY NEVER GAVE PEP TALKS WERE
FACING TEAMS WERE NOT THE ELITE
TEAMS BECAUSE HE KNEW HIS TEAMS
WOULD GET UP FOR THOSE GAMES.
SCOTT: KEVIN NEWMAN INTO LEFT
CENTER.
ZACH MCKINSTRY CAN PLAY
WHEREVER.
THREE UP, THREE DOWN IN THE
SEVENTH.
A GOOD ONE HERE ON YOUTUBE THIS
AFTERNOON.
>> THAT BALL WAS CRUSHED.
>> STRIKE THREE.
>> THAT WAS A GREAT PLAY.
>> THAT WAS REMARKABLE.
>> SOMETHING LIKE THIS WAS WHAT
THEY CAME FOR.
SCOTT: GOOGLE IS HELPING TO
POWER STATCAST, TAKING YOU
DEEPER INTO THE GAME THAN EVER
BEFORE.
GOOGLE CLOUD IS THE OFFICIAL
CLOUD TECHNOLOGY OF MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL.
A LITTLE BIT OF DRIZZLING GOING
ON AGAIN AT PNC, THE SKIES
GETTING DARKER.
COVID-19 VACCINES ARE SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE.
JOIN THE TEAM AND GET THE
VACCINE TO HELP GET US ALL BACK
TO WHAT THAT'S DOING WHAT WE
LOVE TOGETHER.
VISIT MLB.COM/COVID-19 RESOURCES
FOR MORE INFORMATION.
DODGERS 5, PIRATES 3, HEADING TO
THE EIGHTH.
THE PIRATES CUEING KYLE CRICK TO
TAKE OVER.
ANOTHER EXCELLENT RELIEVER.
THE BEST PART OF THE PIRATES HAS
BEEN THE BULLPEN.
SO WHEN THEY DO HAVE A LEAD,
THEY COULD SEAL THE DEAL.
THAT'S WHY YOU'VE SEEN QUITE A
FEW CLOSE WINS AND LOSSES FOR
THE PIRATES BECAUSE EVEN IF A
STARTER STRUGGLES LIKE MITCH
KELLER TODAY, THE BULLPEN HAS
BEEN REALLY SOLID, DOING THEIR
JOB ALL SEASON LONG, AS THE RAIN
GETS A LITTLE HEAVIER NOW.
SEAN: CRICK HAS BEEN REALLY,
REALLY GOOD.
BATTING AVERAGE .0 61.
THIS GUY HAS REALLY BEEN FILLING
UP THE STRIKE ZONE.
SCOTT: THIRD TIME REACHING TODAY
FOR MOOKIE BETTS.
A WALK, A HOMER, AND NOW A BASE
HIT.
JERRY: REALLY THE LAST COUPLE OF
NIGHTS HERE IN PITTSBURGH, GETS
A BREAKING BALL, OUTER THIRD,
GETS THE BARREL ON IT TO LEFT
FOR A SINGLE.
SCOTT: JUST THE FOURTH HIT
ALLOWED BY KYLE CRICK ALL
SEASON.
SEAN: THAT'S AMAZING.
JERRY: PRETTY GOOD SPEED.
I KNOW THE RAIN IS COMING DOWN,
SLICK CONDITIONS.
MOOKIE BETTS ALWAYS A THREAT TO
STEAL A BASE.
OOPS!
SCOTT: BETTS OFF TO SECOND.
TOUGH TO HOLD ONTO THE BASEBALL.
THAT WAS CALLED DEAD ON A
TIMEOUT.
JERRY: MAX MUNCY HITTING SECOND.
A GUY WE HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT SO
FAR TODAY IS ALBERT PUJOLS.
HE HAS BEEN ON FIRE EVER SINCE
HE PUT ON THAT UNIFORM, HE'S
BEEN BIG OFF THE BENCH.
HAVE YOU HAD A CHANCE TO TALK TO
HIM SEAN: IS A CONTENT WITH HOW
THEY ARE USING HIM?
JERRY: HE'S BEEN ON-AIR IN L.A..
MOOKIE IS RUNNING ON THE PITCH,
FOUL BALL.
TO GET BACK TO ALBERT, HE HAS
BEEN ALL SMILES.
CLAYTON KERSHAW TOLD ME HE HAS
BEEN THE HAPPIEST HE HAS EVER
SEEN HIM.
HE IS REALLY ENERGIZED WITH THIS
BALL:.
BEFORE SIGNING UP -- WITH THIS
BALLCLUB.
THEY WEREN'T PLAYING VERY GOOD
BASEBALL, THE DEFENSE WASN'T UP
TO THEIR STANDARD, OFFENSE
WASN'T UP TO THEIR STANDARD, BUT
ALBERT PUJOLS INJECTED LIVE TO
THIS TEAM AND HE HAS BEEN AN
INCREDIBLE TEAMMATE.
GUYS LOVE HIM AND HIS PRODUCTION
HAS BEEN THERE.
HE IS SWINGING THE BAT, KEY
R.B.I.'S, AND I BELIEVE HE HAS
FOUR OR FIVE HOME RUNS IN THAT
DODGERS UNIFORM.
MANAGER DAVE ROBERTS IS GOING TO
USE HIM WISELY.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO RUN HIM
OUT THERE EVERY DAY.
HE WILL GET ENOUGH AT BATS TO
KEEP HIM RELEVANT.
SCOTT: GIVES THE DODGERS FOUR
FORMER MVPS ON THEIR ROSTER.
ONLY FOUR TEAMS IN BASEBALL
HISTORY HAVE BEEN ABLE TO SAY
THAT.
IT SEEMS LIKE AN IDEAL FIT.
HE DIDN'T HAVE TO MOVE MUCH
GOING FROM THE ANGELS TO THE
DODGERS.
THERE'S THE TEAMS WITH FOUR
FORMER M.V.P. WINNERS.
THE BIG RED MACHINE IN 1978 WITH
ROSE, MORGAN, FOSTER AND JOHNNY
BENCH.
BUT ALBERT PUJOLS IS THE OLDEST
PLAYER IN MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL.
HE MOVES OVER FROM THE ANGELS
AND CONTINUES HIS 21 YEAR CAREER
AND FINDS A HOME WITH L.A. WHEN
NOT ONLY WERE THEY GOING THROUGH
A LULL, BUT THEY NEEDED SOME
HELP SPECIFICALLY WITH
LEFT-HANDED PITCHING, AND THAT
IS WHERE ALBERT HAS THRIVED THIS
YEAR.
JERRY: AND ANOTHER POINT THERE,
THE DODGERS, LIKE A LOT OF
CLUBS, THEY USE ANALYTICS, BUT
THEY ALSO UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF HAVING GOOD
CHARACTER.
GREAT CLUBHOUSE GUYS.
IN YEARS PAST THEY'VE HAD DAVID
FREESE, CHASE UTLEY, NOW ALBERT
PUJOLS.
HE PROVIDES LEADERSHIP.
THOSE INTANGIBLES, THAT
CHAMPIONSHIP TEAMS NEED.
SCOTT: I THINK HE WOULD LOVE TO
GRAB ANOTHER RING BEFORE THE
CAREER IS ALL SAID AND DONE.
SEAN: THAT'S WHY HE'S THERE, I
REALLY BELIEVE THAT.
I WAS FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO PLAY
AGAINST HIM.
MOST OF MY CAREER WAS THE N.L.
CENTRAL.
I GOT TO SEE PUJOLS WHEN HE CAME
UP IN 2001.
FOR THE NEXT SIX YEARS, IT WAS
UNBELIEVABLE.
THE WAY THIS GUY COULD JUST LINE
TO LINE, GAP TO GAP.
NEVER GAVE A PITCH AWAY.
HE WALKED MORE THAN HE STRUCK
OUT.
IT WAS A CLINIC WHEN YOU WATCHED
HIM HIT.
SCOTT: FULL COUNT PITCH.
STATCAST POWERED BY GOOGLE
CLOUD.
LET'S LOOK AT THE SPLITS.
FOUR LONG BALLS WITH THE
DODGERS.
HE WENT DEEP FIVE TIMES WITH THE
ANGELS.
THERE IT IS, SEAN.
HE CAN SEND IT TO ALL PARTS OF
THE BALLPARK.
FOR A FEW SEASONS HE WAS
PRIMARILY JUST FULL POWER, BUT
HE'S GONE BACK TO SPRAYING THE
BASEBALL WITH POWER ALL OVER,
AND HE HAS DONE IT WELL FOR THE
DODGERS SO FAR IN HIS SHORT TIME
WITH THE TEAM.
THAT MISSES TO MUNCY, BALL FOUR.
NOW TWO ON FOR L.A..
YOU THINK ABOUT THE VALUABLE
BENCH ROLE THAT ALBERT PUJOLS
HAS PROVIDED BEHIND MAX MUNCY AT
FIRST, ESPECIALLY WHEN MAX MUNCY
HAS DEALT WITH AN ANKLE SPRAIN
IN THE LAST WEEKS OR SO.
IT'S A NICE BACKUP TO HAVE IF
YOU ARE L.A..
JP, WHAT ELSE DO YOU HAVE FOR US
ON PUJOLS?
HOW IS THE WEATHER OUT THERE?
J.P.: THE FORECAST HERE IN THE
BEAUTIFUL CITY OF PITTSBURGH
CALLS FOR SOME RAIN WITH A
CHANCE OF ALLIGATORS.
WAIT, DID I SAY ALLIGATORS?
I THINK WE WILL BE OK.
I SEE NO ALLIGATORS HERE.
I'M THE MEMBER OF THE BROADCAST
CREW MOST CLOSELY POSITION TO
THE RIVER, AND I SEE NO
ALLIGATORS, LET'S MAKE THAT
CLEAR.
ONE OF THE PEOPLE IN THE FRONT
OFFICE FOR THE DODGERS, ONE OF
SEAN'S FORMER TEAMMATES INTO
TORT COME IS ONE OF ALBERT'S
CLOSEST FRIENDS IN THE WORLD.
I REALLY THINK THAT
RELATIONSHIP, WHEN ALBERT WAS
THINKING ABOUT WHAT HE WANTED TO
DO NEXT, SOME PEOPLE WERE ONLY
-- MAYBE SURPRISE WHEN HE WENT
TO AN N.L. TEAM.
HE WANTED TO GO TO A PLACE WHERE
HE KNEW IT WAS ALL ABOUT
WINNING.
JUST KNOWING WHAT THE DAUGHTERS
WERE ALL ABOUT WITH A HUGE
REASON WHY ALBERT SIGNED HERE.
JERRY: THAT'S A GREAT POINT
THEREBY JOHN.
ALBERT PUJOLS UNDERSTANDS, I MAY
HAVE ONE OR POSSIBLY TWO YEARS
LEFT OF MY CAREER, I WANT TO
MAKE THE MOST OF THE NEXT YEAR
OR TWO.
L.A. WAS CERTAINLY THE BEST FIT
FOR HIM.
SCOTT: TURNER SENDS A BALL TO
CENTER AND IT WILL FALL ON A
WEIRD SPAN AND SCORE A RUN.
MOOKIE BETTS, COME ON DOWN.
DODGERS DOUBLING UP THE PIRATES,
6-3 IN THE EIGHTH, IN RAINY PETE
AND SEE PARK -- P.N.C. PARK.
SEAN: HE STOLE THAT BASE ON
CRICK, WENT FROM SECOND TO
THIRD, NO BIG DEAL.
SET THIS UP FOR FIRST AND THIRD
FOR TURNER.
JERRY: WE TALK ABOUT MOOKIE
BETTS, THE HEARTBEAT OF THIS
BALLCLUB THE LAST FIVE OR SIX
YEARS, ESPECIALLY FOR THE
LINEUP, HAS BEEN JUSTIN TURNER.
WE JOKE AROUND BUT HE HAS
DEFINITELY BEEN THAT.
HE HAS BEEN THE PERFECT
THREE-HOLE HITTER FOR THE
DODGERS THE LAST FIVE OR SIX
YEARS.
SCOTT: BELLINGER IN THE CLEANUP
SPOT, WHO HOLDS ON DECK.
THE RAIN COMING DOWN PRETTY
GOOD.
HERE IN THE EIGHTH, BETTS BASE
HIT, UP TO SECOND ON THE MUNCY
WALK.
BETTS STEALS THIRD AND COMES
HOME ON THE TURNER SINGLE.
NOW BELLINGER.
LOOK AT KYLE CRICK, THREE HITS
ALLOWED IN HIS FIRST 17
APPEARANCES.
AND THE DODGERS SAY, SO WHAT?
WE'VE GOT TWO TODAY.
NOBODY OUT IN THE EIGHTH.
WE WILL SEE IF THAT IS GOOD
ENOUGH FOR HAYES TO GRAB, AND HE
GOT IT.
SEAN: WHAT A PLAY.
OH, MY GOSH.
WHAT A PLAY RIGHT HERE BY HAYES
ON THE TARP.
HE HAS TO GO SO FAR.
I'D HAVE TO SAY HE WENT OVER 100
FEET TO GET THIS BALL.
LOOK HOW NICE AND EASY HE COMES.
THIS IS UNBELIEVABLE, JUST
NONCHALANT, RIGHT BY THE TARP,
MAKES THE PLAY.
UNBELIEVABLE.
JERRY: WE SAW MOOKIE BETTS
EARLIER, NOW HAYES, OVER HIS
SHOULDER, CATCHING AT THE TARP,
RAIN POURING DOWN.
CODY BELLINGER CAN'T BELIEVE IT.
INCREDIBLE PLAY BY HAYES.
SCOTT: THAT'S A FUTURE GOLD
GLOVER RIGHT THERE.
IF NOLAN ARENADO EVER WANTS TO
GIVE UP HIS STATUS IN THE
NATIONAL LEAGUE.
BUT HAYES ALREADY LOOKS LIKE ONE
OF THE BEST IN THE BUSINESS AT
THE HOT CORNER.
AND NOW, HERE IS ALBERT.
2-0.
SEAN CASEY TALKED AS MUCH AS
ANYONE I WOULD SAY IN MAJOR
LEAGUE HISTORY AT FIRST BASE
WITH OPPOSING BASE RUNNERS.
WERE THERE EVER ANY COMBOS WITH
THIS GUY, AN ALL-TIME GREAT?
SEAN: I HAD MANY CONVERSATIONS
WITH ALBERT.
HOW DO YOU HIT LINE DRIVES ALL
OVER THE PLACE WITH THE
AUTHORITY THAT YOU HIT IT WITH?
ONE OF THEM WAS, I REMEMBER HE
WAS TALKING ABOUT STAYING ON TOP
OF THE BALL.
ONE DAY HE WAS LIKE, CASE, JUST
DO WHAT I DO.
I TRY TO JUST COME DOWN TO THE
BALL AND DRIVE IT TO RIGHT
CENTER.
YOU MAKE IT LOOK TOO EASY,
BROTHER.
IT'S NOT THAT EASY.
GREAT GUY, THOUGH.
MANY CONVERSATIONS WITH HIM.
GREAT GUY.
JERRY: YOU WERE FORTUNATE ENOUGH
TO PLAY AGAINST ALBERT ALL THOSE
YEARS, WHERE I WAS UNFORTUNATE
TO PLAY AGAINST ALBERT, BECAUSE
I PLAYED FOR THE CUBS COME THE
BREWERS, THE REDS.
IT USED TO KILL OUR TEAMS.
HE'S ONE OF THE BEST HITTERS
I'VE EVER SEEN.
INCREDIBLE TOP HAND.
I THINK THEY WERE TALKING TO THE
GROUNDS CREW.
SCOTT: THEY WANT TO CHECK OUT
THE RADAR.
YOU CAN SEE IT, YOU CAN HEAR IT,
WHEREVER YOU ARE WATCHING FROM
WORLDWIDE ON YOUTUBE.
6-3 DODGERS AND THE EIGHTH.
IT IS TARP TIME.
THREE DAYS IN A ROW IN
PITTSBURGH, THE GAME WILL STEP
ASIDE FOR A MOMENT, THANKS TO
MOTHER NATURE.
THIS HAPPENED ON TUESDAY AND
WEDNESDAY TO DELAY THE START OF
THE GAME.
THIS TIME WE MAKE IT TO THE
EIGHTH.
AND HERE COMES THE TARP.
JERRY: GUYS, I'VE BEEN SO
SPOILED.
I'M HERE IN L.A., HERE AT DODGER
STADIUM.
BEAUTIFUL SKIES HERE IN L.A..
THE EAST COAST IS DIFFERENT.
YOU'VE GOT TO DELAY.
SCOTT: BUT YOU GET THE SEASONS
OUT IN THE NORTHEAST.
THE VARIETY, JUST LIKE THE
DOCTOR OFFENSE THIS YEAR.
BUT IT'S BEEN A LOT OF THE SAME
THIS WEEK.
PRECIPITATION IN PITTSBURGH.
DODGERS WITH 10 HITS TODAY, SIX
RUNS TO SHOW FOR IT.
SIX HITS FOR PITTSBURGH TO
ACCOUNT FOR THEIR THREE RUNS
THIS AFTERNOON IN A GAME THAT
STARTED WITH MITCH KELLER AND
JULIO URIAS.
A LITTLE RAIN DELAY ACTION ON
YOUTUBE.
LET'S TALK IT OUT.
CAN WE COME ON CAMERA SO WE CAN
SEE WHAT THE ACTION IS LIKE FOR
JERRY HAIRSTON JR.?
HE IS IN L.A., AND IT LOOKS SO
NICE.
JERRY: I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
PROBLEM IS.
[LAUGHTER]
DODGER STADIUM, IT'S 75 DEGREES,
PERFECTLY SUNNY OUT.
SEAN: IT'S 75 AND SUNNY EVERY
DAY IN L.A.
A LITTLE RAIN, IT'S NOT BAD.
FOR THE ALLIGATORS IN THE RIVER,
YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING
OUT THERE.
JERRY: THE POST-GAZETTE SAID
THERE ARE ALLIGATORS IN THE
RIVER, OCTOBER 2, 2019.
AM I RIGHT?
SEAN: I NEVER HEARD THAT, BUT
YOU ARE RIGHT.
I BLAME EVERYTHING ON GLOBAL
WARMING.
IT MUST BE GLOBAL WARMING THAT
SOMEHOW ALLIGATORS ARE IN THE
ALLEGHENY RIVER.
SCOTT: I FEEL LIKE YOU MIGHT
HAVE A FUTURE WITH A POTENTIAL
YOUTUBE SHOW WHERE YOU TAKE US
THROUGH THE RUGGED TERRAIN OF
ALL THESE DIFFERENT BALLPARKS
AND EVENTUALLY SHOW US SOME OF
THE WILDLIFE THAT IS AROUND IT.
THERE IS ALWAYS A VIRAL VIDEO
AVAILABLE TO SEE, WHETHER IT'S A
RALLY SQUIRREL, A CAT.
WE'VE SEEN ALL KINDS OF
CREATURES MAKE THEIR WAY ONTO
FIELDS.
JERRY: I'VE GOT A PLACE HERE IN
MANHATTAN BEACH.
I'M REALLY GOOD SWIMMER, I JUST
DON'T GET IN THE WATER.
JUST BECAUSE YOU ARE A GOOD
SWIMMER DOESN'T MEAN YOU WILL
SWIM IN RIVER.
LET THEM HAVE THEIR HABITAT, AND
WE STAY ON LAND.
I AM A FIRM BELIEVER IN THAT.
SCOTT: SMART MAN, JERRY.
YOU ALSO HAVE THE FORTUNE OF
WATCHING A TEAM THAT WON THE
WORLD SERIES LAST YEAR THAT TAKE
EIGHT STRAIGHT DIVISION TITLES.
WHAT HAVE YOU WITNESSED SO FAR
THIS AFTERNOON FROM THE DODGERS
FROM AFAR, COMPARED TO WHAT YOU
HAVE SEEN ALL SEASON LONG?
JERRY: THE LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS
THEY'VE DONE A PRETTY GOOD JOB
OF PUTTING THE BAT ON THE
BASEBALL.
EVEN THOUGH MOOKIE BETTS HAD
THAT LEADOFF HOME RUN, THE
DODGERS HAVE DONE AN EXCELLENT
JOB MANUFACTURING RUNS.
A COUPLE OF TWO OUT R.B.I.'S.
URIAS HELP HIS CAUSE BY HITTING
A CLUTCH TWO OUT R.B.I..
MANAGER DAVE ROBERTS TALK TO US
ABOUT NEEDING JULIO TO PITCH
DEEP IN THE BALLGAME.
HE WAS ABLE TO DO THAT.
LATE IN THE BALLGAME, JUSTIN
TURNER, HUGE R.B.I..
SO THE DOCTORS, A PRETTY GOOD
GAME SO FAR.
SCOTT: -- DODGERS, A PRETTY GOOD
GAME.
SCOTT: THE BULLPEN DOING AN
EXCELLENT JOB OF KEEPING THEM IN
GAMES.
A LOT OF CLOSE CONTESTS FOR
PITTSBURGH, EVEN THOUGH THIS IS
A TEAM CURRENTLY RIGHT NOW THAT
SITS IN LAST PLACE IN THE
DIVISION.
YOU SEE SOME BRIGHT SPOTS THAT
CAN CONTRIBUTE TO BETTER TIMES
AHEAD IN THE FUTURE AND ALSO A
TEAM THAT STARTED OFF AT 12-11
ON THE SEASON.
THEY NEED MORE DEPTH.
THAT'S WHY WE SAW SOME OF THOSE
THAT DEALS IN THE OFF-SEASON,
TRADING AWAY SOME OF THEIR
BIGGER PLAYERS.
THEY HAVE A NUMBER ONE PICK
COMING UP.
KE'BRYAN HAYES LOOKS LIKE A
STAR.
REYNOLDS LOOKS LIKE A SOLID STAR
TO BE AN ABOVE AVERAGE
CONTRIBUTOR.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THE PARTS
SO FAR IN TERMS OF DEVELOPMENT
AND TURNING INTO ANOTHER WINNING
WINDOW LIKE WE SAW FROM
2013-2015?
SEAN: THEY HAD TO MAKE A COUPLE
OF DECISIONS TO GET SOME YOUNGER
PLAYERS.
LOOKING TO THE FUTURE FOR THE
PIRATES, YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE
TOP OF THIS LINEUP RIGHT NOW
WHEN YOU HAVE FRAZIER, KE'BRYAN
HAYES AND REYNOLDS.
THOSE GUYS ARE IMPACT PLAYERS.
KE'BRYAN HAYES IS THE GUY THE
FANS REALLY WANT TO COME SEE.
YOU SAW THAT PLAY HE MADE THIS
INNING, OVER HIS SHOULDER.
REALLY STARTING TO DRIVE THE
BASEBALL.
THE BULLPEN HAS BEEN A BIG ASSET
FOR DEREK SHELTON ALL SEASON
LONG.
THERE ARE SOME BRIGHT SPOTS FOR
THE PIRATES.
AT THE END OF THE DAY IT'S GOING
TO BE CONSISTENCY.
A GUY LIKE MITCH KELLER WHO HAS
A POWER ARM, HE'S BEEN A BIG
PROSPECT FOR THEM BEFORE THIS
SEASON.
REALLY HAS TO LEARN TO PITCH IN
THE BIG LEAGUES AND THROW MORE
STRIKES.
BUT THE FUTURE IS BRIGHT FOR THE
PITTSBURGH PIRATES.
SCOTT: PIRATES TRAILING BY THREE
RUNS NOW.
CASE, WATCH OUT.
ANYTHING CAN HAPPEN ON YOUTUBE.
I KNOW SEAN CASEY HAS PRETTY
GOOD HANDS.
FORMER FIRST BASEMAN.
SEAN: IT IS RAINING SIDEWAYS.
SCOTT: I SAW IT YESTERDAY.
I AM STATIONED IN NEW JERSEY.
THERE WAS QUITE THE STORM, BUT
THEN IT PASSED IN ABOUT 30
MINUTES.
WE WILL KEEP YOU POSTED ON THE
WEATHER.
WE WILL EVENTUALLY TALK TO J.P.
MOROSI AS WE HANG OUT WITH YOU
HERE ON YOUTUBE.
SEAN: THEY ARE KEEPING ME SAFE.
THEY ARE DOING EVERYTHING THEY
CAN.
I HAVE PAPERS FLYING EVERYWHERE.
THE RAIN HIT ME IN THE FACE.
JERRY IS OUT THERE WHERE IT 75
AND SUNNY.
I AM FACING THE ELEMENTS, GUYS.
JERRY: DEPENDING ON HOW LONG
THIS DELAY IS, I'M STARTING TO
GET A LITTLE HUNGRY.
NOBODY IS HERE.
I MAY ORDER A DOORDASH AND GET
SOME IN AND OUT SENT TO ME.
SCOTT: WE HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF
TIME.
A TALE OF TWO CLIMATES.
PITTSBURGH IS WHERE SEAN CASEY
IS AS THEY HOPE TO CONTINUE THIS
GAME.
6-3, PAUSED IN THE EIGHTH
INNING.
SIT BACK, RELAX, HANG OUT ON
YOUTUBE AND CHECK OUT THE 2020
PLAYS OF THE YEAR.
WE WILL KEEP YOU POSTED ON THE
ACTION IN THE STEEL CITY.
>> IT'S A WALKOFF HOME RUN.
WHAT A CATCH.
>> THROWS HIM OUT FROM THE SEAT
OF HIS PANTS.
♪
>> A NO-HITTER, THE 19TH AND
WHITE SOX HISTORY.
>> WHAT A PLAY.
ABSOLUTELY CRUSHED.
>> SEE YOU LATER.
>> WELCOME TO THE CAPITAL ONE
PREMIER PLAYS OF THE YEAR.
I'M YOUR HOST, LAUREN GARDNER.
WE MAY HAVE GONE FROM 162 TO 60
GAMES, BUT THAT DEAFLY DIDN'T
SLOW DOWN THE ACTION ON THE
FIELD.
OVER THE NEXT TWO HOURS WE WILL
BRING YOU EVERY REMARKABLE
MOMENT AND PLAY OF THIS
UNPRECEDENTED SEASON.
LET'S NOT WASTE ANY TIME AND GET
THINGS STARTED WITH SOME BIG
STYLE AT NUMBER 100.
>> THE 25 EURO CATCHER FOR THE
DODGERS, AND A HIGH FLY BALL TO
LEFT.
WILL SMITH, THE BIGGEST SWING
AND HIS YOUNG CAREER.
THE DODGERS JUMP ON TOP 4-2 HERE
IN THE SIX.
>> A SPECTACULAR PLAY BY THE A'S
PLATINUM GLOVER AT THIRD BASE
AND JUST AT THE RIGHT TIME.
>> BALL HIT INTO LEFT CENTER
FIELD.
WHAT A CATCH BY MILES STRAHL,
LAYING OUT ON TO THE WARNING
TRACK.
A GREAT DEFENSIVE PLAY.
>> A PHENOMENAL PLAY BY MYLES
STRAW.
TURNED ON THE AFTERBURNERS, THAT
WAS BEAUTIFULLY DONE.
>> FLY BALL, WELL HIT CENTER.
ROBLES GOING BACK TO THE TRACK,
TO THE WALL, AND IT'S GONE.
DANSBY WITH A WALKOFF HOMER IN
THE NINE.
DON'T GIVE UP ON THESE BRAVES,
THEY DO IT AGAIN.
THE BRAVES TAKE GAME ONE FROM
WASHINGTON.
>> SWINGS AT THE FIRST PITCH AND
HITS IT DEEP TO CENTER FIELD.
LEAPS, AND MAKES THE PLAY.
TOOK AN EXTRA-BASE HIT AWAY FROM
D'ARNAUD.
>> SO MUCH FOR THE COURTESY
PITCHES TO START THE GAME.
TWO HARD HIT BALLS, BUT A GOOD
PLAY BY HICKS.
HE JUST SAVED TWO RUNS ON THAT
PLAY.
>> CORREA SENDS ONE TO CENTER
FIELD.
LAYS OUT AND MAKES ANOTHER GREAT
CATCH.
OH, MY GOODNESS.
>> KIERMAIER WITH ANOTHER RUN
SAVING GRAB.
TAKES AWAY A BASE HIT FROM
CORREA AND STRANDS A COUPLE
MORE.
TO CENTER FIELD AND DEEP, ROBERT
GOING BACK, LEAPING.
DOES NOT MAKE THE PLAY AND
CRASHES INTO THE FENCE.
BUXTON WILL HAVE A HOME RUN
TONIGHT.
BYRON BUXTON OFF THE CENTER
FIELD FENCE, HIS NINTH HOME RUN
OF THE YEAR.
>> THAT SPEED KICKED IN.
>> FLARED TOWARD THIRD.
THE TAG ON SEAGER, HE IS OUT.
JUMPS UP AND COMES DOWN,
RETIRING THE SIDE.
>> ANOTHER GREAT PLAY BY JI-MAN
CHOI.
>> TAKES THE THROW FROM JOEY
WENDLE AND APPLIES THE TAG.
HIGH IN THE AIR.
STILL GOING TOWARD THE LINE.
HE DID CATCH IT.
THAT WAS A GREAT, GREAT PLAY.
>> RANDY AROZARENA, HOME RUN,
TIED IT FOR THE RAYS AFTER THE
YANKEE SCORED IN THE FIRST.
THROWS HIM OUT FROM THE SEAT OF
HIS PANTS.
THESE DEFENSIVE GYMS ARE GOING
TO START POPPING UP ON ALL THE
HIGHLIGHT REELS.
>> CURVEBALL LIFTED IN THE AIR,
RIGHT CENTER FIELD.
A DIVING GRAB.
WHAT A PLAY FOR RANDAL GRICHUK.
A DIVE IN THE LEFT CENTER FIELD
GAP.
IT DESERVES A STANDING OVATION.
ONE OF THE BEST DEFENSIVE PLAYS
OF THE YEAR.
LAURA: RANDAL GRICHUK MAKING HIS
MARK ON THE 2021 SEASON.
WE CHECK IN WITH THE TORONTO
OUTFIELDER WHEN THE CAPITAL ONE
PREMIER PLAYS OF THE YEAR
CONTINUES.
WELCOME BACK TO THE CAPITAL ONE
PREMIER PLAYS OF THE YEAR.
TIME TO LAUGH OUT LOUD AS WE
CHECK OUT THE BEST BLOOPERS OF
THE SEASON.
>> DR. ANTHONY FAUCI EACH OF
THROW OUT THE CEREMONIAL FIRST
PITCH.
DR. FAUCI JUST A BIT OUTSIDE.
>> A DAY AT THE BEACH FOR ZACH.
I'LL JUST BE HERE, YOU GUYS LET
ME KNOW WHEN YOU ARE DONE.
>> I'M TAKING A SNOOZE.
>> KOLE CALHOUN IS NOT SOMEBODY
YOU WANT TO RUN INTO.
HE TOOK THE WISE MOVE AND RAN
INTO THE FENCE INSTEAD.
>> HERE IT IS.
I'LL ACT LIKE A LAWN DART TO
START WITH.
>> RAN INTO HIM, AND DROPS THE
BALL.
BACK TO THE WARNING TRACK, TO
THE WALL.
IT'S GONE.
>> YOU SAW THAT SCOUTING REPORT,
THE ACRONYM FOR RANDY.
THAT'S ABOUT ALL YOU NEED TO
KNOW.
>> THE PADRES ARE GOING BACK TO
THE BROWN AND YELLOW COLOR SKIM.
-- COLOR SCHEME.
>> HOSMER DRIVES IT TO LEFT
FIELD.
CAN HE CLEAR THE BASES AGAIN?
>> I THINK THE PADRES ARE THE
TEAM TO WATCH THIS YEAR.
GETTING OFF TO A GOOD START
CERTAINLY HELPS.
>> FERNANDO TATIS IS ONE OF THE
TOP SLUGGERS IN BASEBALL.
>> WHAT A TURN OF EVENTS FOR THE
PADRES.
JUST LOOKS UNCOMFORTABLE TO ME.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS.
>> KIRBY YATES IS WALKING OFF
THE FIELD.
>> THEY JUST GOT TO GET IT
GOING.
>> OF GRAND SLAM AND THE PADRES
GO ON TOP.
>> THAT SWING, LET'S GO, LET'S
GET MORE ACTION.
>> FOR THE FIRST TIME IN MAJOR
LEAGUE HISTORY, A TEAM HAS HIT A
GRAND SLAM IN FOUR GAMES IN A
ROW.
>> NICKNAME SUNSHINE, GOING TO
SAN DIEGO.
>> A THREE RUN HOME RUN BY THE
NEW GUY, AUSTIN NOLA.
>> ONE MOVE THAT WOULD BE THE
BIGGEST WOULD BE TREVOR
ROSENTHAL.
>> A SHUTOUT FOR MIKE CLEVINGER.
>> IN THE AIR TO DEEP RIGHT
FIELD FOR GRISHA.
GRISHA HAS TIED THE GAME OFF
CLAYTON KERSHAW.
>> FOR THE FIRST TIME IN 14
YEARS, THE PADRES HAVE CLINCHED
THEIR SPOT IN THE POSTSEASON.